Hello everyone, welcome to Next Level
Commander. This is Jin and today we're
doing something massive. We're going to
look at not one, not two, all 99 Final
Fantasy commanders. And we're going to
do two things. First, we're going to try
to build a deck around it. Maybe not an
entire deck, but we'll brainstorm an
idea. We'll try to do something unique,
something interesting for each legendary
creature. And we will make a skeleton,
right? We'll put some cards into this
architect file, architect list. and like
the key cards, the direction we're
taking it to give you a rough idea. And
the second thing I'm going to do is
because I'm not super familiar with
Final Fantasy. I've played Final Fantasy
Tactics when I was like 15 and also
recently I tried Final Fantasy 7
remastered for about 10 15 hours and
that is the extent of my knowledge. I
didn't go any further. So based on that,
this is a top- down set. I'm going to
try to guess what these characters do
and who they are, what their perk is.
And we're starting with color multiolor
just because it's easier. I saw some
really interesting strange ones in mono
colored. I'm not looking forward to
building those, but we'll start easy and
we'll work our way up. It seems like
they put colorless first. So, we'll
start with that. Ultima.
Ultima. Okay. I mean, this guy is like a
mutant thing. four arms like kind of
Esper from Charzelara vibes almost
Tesarette vibes. He's Oh, he's a god.
Okay. Well, yeah, this guy's definitely
like a final final boss kind of thing.
The kind of boss is not coming to you.
You're going to him and you probably
have to traverse through this dungeon
where he lives cave and the cave somehow
has perfect lighting. Seems like yeah
like he extends his domain with whatever
like alrazi do and I'm guessing crystals
because that's the
thing. Yeah. And what the ability the
first ability seems interesting but I
don't think we can build around it. You
put a blight counter becomes it loses
all abilities is nonbasic
land but it's too slow. The commander is
five mana and it happens once a turn. So
we are not going to build around that
unfortunately. We have to build around
double mana doubling. I said
unfortunately because once you go this
path in colorless as far as I know there
are only two ways to do it. Alrazi or
artifacts. And big mana I'm guessing
it's aldrazzi.
But but I'm going to try artifacts. I'll
see if there's enough mana sync in
artifacts for it to to make it work
because what turn five this turn six
we're going to have 12 mana ideally.
So, I'm going to skyfall for mana sync
in colorless. I'm not sure this is a
thing to be
honest. Mana sync.
Whoops. Oh, does Oh, it works. Does
it? Nope. Does not work. Although, I
learned something about Skyfall is that
if you It's something that feels
searchable. something that is a common
term in magic and you don't know the
same text you just you just Google
scrifall mana
sync it works look at that mana sync
okay tag oracle tag does it work yeah
these are mana syncs and then I have to
combine these with colorless
right so wait not here not here uh
back colorless mana
sync this should do what? What did I do?
No, nice. Although it didn't do color
identity, but it's okay. Resort by EDH
rank. I find this to be so useful. It's
more useful, I think, than looking at
EDH rank, but we'll see. Uh, never mind.
We have to go for colorless identity,
otherwise we'll have too many random
trap. Okay.
Then put that
in sort by ADH
rank. Okay, there you go. Lots of lands.
Sure. Walking ballista. Four mana up to
counter. Mana sync. Mana sync. Oh, staff
of domination.
Okay. Dark
depths. Yeah, I don't think we have
enough. So, we're just doing a drawing,
which is
fun. We're going to search like this
colorless something big.
So, a a a
a not a value greater
than seven. Let's go. We can do Aladdin
tribal. Nope.
Yeah, artisan. Okay, because your
commander is five mana, we're not going
to we need to ramp into it, right? We
need to play lots of mana rocks. So,
Kazzle is key here for refilling our
hand. Yeah, seems like as a popular
Ugan, of course. I mean, I mean, all of
these are going in. All these are going
in. Ulamog, I'm just putting in the key
cards for now. The Kaik I think is super
important.
Um, anything any other big mana? Yeah,
sure. Rise of the outrage. Yeah, you get
the
idea. And after that, he's a god. Do you
have any
synergy? I can't think of any synergy
with god
or Yeah. So, just some mana rocks, you
know, uh, like so
raring here. I will search for mana
rocks just so we have a complete
skeleton of the deck.
Boom.
Boom. Add as well. All I'm going to say
add and then color. Oh, it's going to be
land. We don't want land.
Land. Not
land.
Why? Oh, we don't want we don't want
this.
So ringing not aren signate not thought
vessel mstone
sure metry. Nope. Throw dynamo. Yeah
this is basically I don't want to spend
too much time on this because seems like
I mean people enjoy colorless and this
is definitely a viable commander but
it's not nothing too unique that we're
doing. So what we'll do here we'll
select all. We'll add this into a new
category called Ultima.
This will do. Moving on. Sin spy rust
punishment.
Sin. See, a lot of the Final Fantasy
names are super on the nose. So, it's
like you mean this feels like some
ancient force of nature kind of thing.
Not necessarily evil, but you have to
fight it probably because of plot
reasons.
And yeah, it's probably the seems like
one of the biggest creatures by the art.
Leviathan avatar. Holy crap. Flying.
Whenever interest or attacks, ex exile
permanent card from your graveyard at
random. Then create a tap token that is
a copy of that card and it stops when
you exile a
land. So you want to dump cards into
your graveyard because this guy is not
coming down. This is like the finisher,
right? So your entire early game will be
setting up for this guy and then boom,
sin comes down. You have a massive
board. But the problem is if you mill
yourself, you still have to do graveyard
hate too. So self mill graveyard hate.
So you can, you know, remove all the
lands from the
graveyard. I guess one way to do it is
to play those return all lands cards,
but there's like two of
them. Another way is to play looters.
Maybe we can do looter tribal because we
have a lot of lutters to set up for sin
and then of course ramp and boom sin
comes down. Okay, we'll try that. We'll
try that. Makes sense. Okay, so we are
doing how do we draw search for looter?
We search for draw discard I'm guessing.
Yeah,
draw and
discard a card, right? Lutters don't
loot for more than one usually. pipeline
anything. Well, we will avoid instances
sources for now. Only prominence. We
want repeatable ones. So, not not and it
has to be within sins colors. Oops.
Power
identity is
rank.
Necropotence Yoth Crater. Good. Wait,
this one discards. Oh, this is like a
He's like a looter. It's like a looter.
Yeah, I like it. I like it. You know
what? Sweet. It's a cool card. And it
also seems to be Yeah, they seem like
decent friends, right? They probably
live live in a swamp
together. Yeah, cool. Neighbors maybe
pretend to like each other, but secretly
plotting to consume each other. Nezahal
and sin loot ran. We'll skip it for now.
We're skipping for now. Ghostly piler.
Yeah, this is
good. Fra. Sure. This also ramps us into
sin. Yeah, you can stack treasures into
sin. Discard a card trading post. Is
that worth it? Stack an artifact. Not
really. Cafari. Yeah, Cafari loots every
turn. That's sweet. It's like a triple
quadruple looter. Jason's archavist.
That's looting for too much. We don't
want to do this again because we don't
want lands in the
graveyard. I'm starting to work. Are
there actually enough good looters? I
mean, this this one is great. Um,
whenever you discard a creep. Okay.
Payoff for discarding. We have a deck.
Yeah, we have a deck here. Definitely.
Kitsa.
Nice.
Payoff.
Um, is that it? Nope. We've got
more. Psychic
frog. Yeah, seems good. Bag of holding.
No, absolutely not. It exiles your
discards. Oh, but it's You may This one
is You may though. Two mana. Draw a
card. Discard a card. Put a card exiled
into your graveyard. If it's a land
card, create. It's not terrible. I do
think we
uh we can't really be picky here. How
many is it now? We have 13. Maybe 10
lutters. A few more. Sure. Just the
average
lutters. Overlord. Yeah, it's fine. It's
fine. I like it so far. I like it so
far. Three mana.
Sure. Yeah. And once we do that, we want
big permanence, right? Let's look at sin
again. We want create a tap token. That
is tapped token. That's copy of the card
interest or
attacks. So, I think we just play the
biggest permanence honestly because we
can discard them anyways. So we don't
have to play like responsibly. We don't
have to care about the curve too much.
We got these ones. So we're going to
search for the biggest splashiest
permanence in since colors. I like it.
It's like a mass reanimation deck. Uh
where's mana
cost greater than? Let's go
six. And if you want to go thematic, you
can play Leviathans, right? Because with
this deck, it doesn't really matter what
fatties you play. You can play the
fatties to adjust the power level. If
you want something higher power, sure,
you can play the good stuff like Avenger
Crater Crater. No, they entertapped,
right? Once again, they
intertapped. Yeah. So, we're not going
to Alpha
Strike. And I like I like that because
otherwise it's just a combo, right? It's
not super interesting. The game will
just
end. Does it Wait, does it say Yeah. Top
token. Okay. And
then go to shield. Absolutely. I like
shield. Novel.
Sure. Yeah. This is again personal
preference. Mahalo is in coslet can't be
mil. Triple mana. Do we need? Not
really. Car draw.
Sure.
Emissions. Sure. You know all these
stuffs. Yep. And what else do we need?
We need some ramp. We need to ramp uh
Sin out. Do we play the typical
ramp? Sin doesn't care about instances
sorceries. Yeah. So, we can just play
the typical ramp cards. Cultivate Reach.
Scryfall
Webp. Yeah, super useful. Wait, did I
speak to her? Oh, it's
fine. I was just surprised the first
card was blue for some reason. Oh,
speaking of Speaking of, there's a card
we need. It's
called It's called um
Dreamscape Artist. Dreamscape
Artist. Yeah, this is like the perfect
card for this deck. Discarding every
card in your hand becomes
hero. We want
that.
Cultivate Kama. Why is Kodama so much
lower? And we have a deck. We have a
skele skeleton. All right, moving on to
the next
legendary Choco, Seeker of Paradise.
This is the mascot, right? Has to be the
Wait, but this is the mascot. This is
the
vehicle because I remember in Final
Fantasy Tactics like they had this
attack where they had just a line of
choco balls rushing and then it's like
terrifying because it's really powerful
and a bird whenever one or more birds
you control attack look at that many
cards from the top of your
library. Yeah. So he must be like a
tribal thing where they they never
probably never show up in once, right?
Even though
There's one that is like the part of the
main squad, but they always call it to
each other, right? Except like there's
this special one. It's like what's that
Pokemon? I forgot the name, but it's
like the the special one is alone, but
every other Choco you see, they will
come in swarms is my guess. Uh they play
you put one into your hand, then put any
number of lands coming tapped. Okay, so
bird and landfall whenever land you
control enters choco gets plus one plus
O. Now this ability is not strong. We
yeah I don't know it's like a trap. Some
people may be misled to build build
landfall but just plus one plus O is
might as well be nothing.
So, we're building bird tribal and we're
hoping that bird tribal has some synergy
or has some interaction that we can also
build around that. But if there's
nothing, then we are we have to do
landfall because once we have enough
birds, we're landfalling maybe two,
three times a turn. We'll see. We'll
search for them
birds. Event search
[Music]
bird. Yeah, this is the kind of deck
that's super straightforward. I can't
think of anything that we can do that's
unique. Yeah, it's even when you attack.
Not even
ETB. All right. View
name. Birds of
paradise. I should put this in for Oh,
first I have to change this
[Music]
to what's the name again? Sin. Yes.
And now Choco comes
in. And Birds of Paradise, of course.
Did I forget to do color? I did. So, we
have to change
that. Boom. Boom.
Boom. I don't Bird. B bird tribal in
Final Fantasy cares about lands, but I
don't think the majority of the cards we
have will care about lands. Okay. Legend
fighter. We'll put in all the good ones.
Sure, because we want a low curve,
right? We want to be able to attack.
Yeah, we want to be able to attack early
because Choco doesn't care about itself
attacking. Throwing throwing birds
proliferate probably not mocking bird.
Sure.
T-sh right now there's no co cohesive
theme aside from
flying. So wait from anywhere other than
your hand. Vega, this is not happening.
We don't cast spells from our No, we
don't. Great card. A interrupter. Great
card. Aerial Extortionist. Whoops.
Whoops.
Whoops. DVI. Great card. Goose
mother. Yeah, we are not we are not
going to have much of a theme. We will
see about we'll see about building
around creatures with flying. So or
building around
flying
creatures with flying or creature with
flying. Let's see if that gives us
anything. Attap all creatures without
flying. That's something. I know. I
know. We play
moat. That is not a game changanger, is
it? It's a wallet changer. A boilos
awakening.
No, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no. Yeah, this is a bit too broad. I I
guess creatures for flying. Get
something.
Get Nope. I guess we're doing
landfall, but we're not going to play
the land like skew swarm, are we? Yeah,
we still have to win through flying.
I'll try again. I'll try again. uh
creatures with
flying
get or we need to quotation mark these.
I think this
is if this
fails. I don't think well keep trying
but okay. Yeah, it seems fairly clear
what we're doing here. If you want, you
can again do some landfall
shenanigans because you're getting two
or three lands consistently, but then
you're building like two different
decks, birds and lands. There's very
little interaction between each other
aside from your commander. So, I want to
just go with flying and try to find
cards. Like the one I can think of is
the gravitation
gravitational shift. There you go. This
kind of stuff.
Okay,
let's let's select
all
Choco. Next up, oh, this is sick. Kevfka
have our first transform card. Kevka,
Court Mage. This guy seems like the
Joker. I know he's special because I've
seen the name a lot. Like when you know,
you don't see the same character twice
unless it's a special character. And
Kefka is like the Joker in Final Fantasy
except less complex. I know he has a
tower and the tower probably has no
stairs, just
um just teleportation circles. And he
probably has a clown themed like a
circus themed crew. Super on the nose
and all the clown
tropes. When Kelvka enters or attacks,
each player discards a card. Then you
draw a card for each card type among
cards discarded this
way. And then eight
mana. Each opponent sacrifice a
permanent transform as
sorcery. We'll see what the back does.
But this is way too
expensive. Kevkar, ruler of ruin. The
end draws near. All right. This is cool.
Avatar wizard. Wow. Yeah. the kind of
final boss that like at first he's
trying to be super tricky and sneaky and
doing all these cool, you know, show off
things and then he realizes, okay, this
I might die and then he just gives up
all that bull crap and goes in with raw
power brute
force. Yeah, whenever an opponent loses
life during your turn, you draw that
many cards. This is super powerful. Wow.
So, lightning bolt draws you three
cards, but I don't think it's possible
to build around this just because I mean
five mana plus eight at sorcery
speed and the front side and the back
side there not isn't necessarily any
synergy. So, I think we're going
for Yeah, I think we're going to go
for building around the front side. And
this is so powerful. Each trigger is
like you're drawing two, three
cards. I think we're Yeah, I think we're
just going to go Kefka Blink.
Kefka clone and
blink. And we're going to draw more
clones and more blink. And then you ramp
so that eventually you can clone and
blink it twice, three times a turn. And
eventually your opponents run out of
cards. That's when you transform him.
We do need maybe some link conditions,
but for now I think we we have a we have
a deck. So, uh yeah, just all the blink
cards. Exile
return. And they're all blue, I believe.
So, I'm just not going to search for any
other
color. So, I'll return. Yeah, let's try
it.
Yes. Displacer kitten. Yes. Ghostly
flicker. Oops. Oops.
Whoops. Near. Thasa. Yes. Thosa. We have
a blink deck here. Essence flux. Dead
eye. Sure. Yeah, you get the idea. And
then once we blink, we can also play the
red clone
spells
like
copy target
creature. Those also work as blink. Uh
they trigger the ETB, not as blink, I
mean, but they trigger the ETB. That's
all we need. Hey, hey, EK
Shrek dual caster
mage. I guess this is a cool blink
payoff. Are we doing just full on blink
for now? I want to do do Kefka. Build
around Kefka. But we'll see after that
what else we can do. This
is This is good. Yeah. Making
copies. Yeah, seems good.
Okay. So now that we have all these
blink, we have all
these kev cut triggers, we have to do
discard, right? Whenever
discard
whenever opponent. Yeah, discard.
Basically the necusar package kind of.
And uh boom boom. Just kai. Not just
kai. Grixes. Grixes. My apologies.
sort something like what's it called?
There's this artifact format
artifact. Forgot the name,
but yeah. Yo, this kind Yeah. Arch
faint. How good is this? The internet is
a bit slow. Maybe I have to go adjust
it somehow.
Let's
see. Okay, we
good. Whatever. Yeah, waste not. Of
course. Tur grid. Where's Tur grid? Has
to be in here. Tur grid. Is that a game
changer? We'll
see. Oh, yeah. This one doesn't show
because I didn't choose commander
because if I choose commander for this
deck, it will what's it called? It will
highlight everything red. So I I think
target is a game changanger, but
whatever. We'll build first. Discard,
discard, discard, discard. Yeah, there
you go. Guess Grimro, that's the card I
was talking about. So now we have all
these payoff. How do we win the
game? Do we have the rack effects? Is it
called the rack
where if an
opponent has less card in
hand? I'm not going to take out I'm
going to take out
n. Can that win the
game? Those are usually super slow, so I
might not include them. I might have to
find a different
way. Banditis Talon each card. Two
cards. A few cards in
hand. Yeah, I don't think this is too
good. Wait, what about the rack? I'll
search for the
rack. The rack.
got the name wrong. Oh, there. I didn't
I didn't choose an opponent. Yeah, we're
not doing that. So then looks like we'll
have to win with the backside, right?
How does the front side win? Four, five.
The backside also doesn't win too
much. Or maybe we need a few blink
targets because the backside you need to
play pump spells and the pump spell will
draw you more cards into more pump
spells. But that kind of dilutes our
game plan a little bit too much. So
maybe we just win. We control the game,
drop on the cards, and in the end we win
with some ETB creatures, blinking ETB
creatures. So enters the battlefield.
We'll see.
the battle. I think this is this is
enough. Oh, forgot to do
colors. Greater than six, let's
say.
Oops. Yeah. Primor. Yeah, this is the
kind of stuff we're talking about. Oh,
yeah. Yeah. Never mind. Blink. We can
just steal from our
opponents. I like that more. Yeah, I
like that more because blink is kind of
boring. It's like a different archetype.
If we just blink Kevka a bunch and then
we reanimate
from Yo. Yeah, I like this idea because
also at the same time those reanimation
spells can serve as blink as long as we
have sack outlets in lands. Okay, that
that's a much much better idea. I'm glad
the first one was support. Okay, so what
we're doing here, we are finding return
from
graveyard. Return from graveyard and
doesn't have to be a
creature.
search and
[Music]
uh oh I I have a CMC regular uh
restriction. My apologies. No CMC, no
meta
value. I want to return from any gra. So
none of
these. What happened to
reanimate? Oh yeah. Oh, they don't say
return. That's tricky.
Target
creature. Creature creature
graveyard
[Applause]
battlefield. This has to Oh, sorry.
Creature graveyard battlefield. Creature
graveyard
battlefield. Okay.
Afterlife from the lone. And there you
go. There you go. Animate
dead. Victimize.
No. Living death.
Nope. Rise from the dark realms.
Absolutely.
Yes. You get the necromancy. Yes. You
get the idea. And you can also steal
spells from opponents. I guess we are in
the perfect color for that.
Uh like the Louisian
primordial.
Yep. And there's a card I like a lot.
It's from Shadow War. It's four mana.
You can straight up just cast a spell
from opponent opponent's graveyard and
it's instant. So I will search for it.
Instant search uh graveyard.
Graveyard Instant
Sorcery. This should
do. Uh, there's a few. There's a few.
Oh, there you go. Memory Plunder. This
is the one I'm looking
for. You may cast target instant sorcery
cards from your opponent's graveyard.
And this is your win condition. You
know, this deck looks really fun and
powerful. We also need lots of ramp, of
course, because Kevka is five mana and
we will not be short on cards. We'll be
drawing a lot of cards as soon as we get
Kevka down. For commanders that can ref
uh refill your hand, you don't mind
being greedy with rep. So, all the all
the mana rocks. I'll just add a few.
add
soaring all these. Sure. Sure. We don't
mind the three mana rocks just because
um wait what
happened? Why are they not
working? And then
uh yeah, all the sickness. Why not?
just to get an
idea. Okay, this deck looks sweet. I
would want to play this deck. Not sure
if it's fun to play against, but you
know, you have friends and then you have
really close friends that you don't mind
doing this
to. Select
all. Go to Kevka.
[Applause]
Next
up, Noctis, prince of
Lucus. This is like
the Yeah, this guy seems like the the
mirror version of our main character,
right? Super cold, aloof, doesn't care
about anything with this hair. It's like
who I imagined myself to be when I was
in grade
seven. Yeah, lots of weapons. probably
speaks more to his weapons than
people. So, lifelink, you may cast
artifact spells from your grave. Oh,
artificer. Yeah, of course. Paying three
life in addition to paying their other
costs. If you cast a spell this way, the
artifact interest with a finality
counter on it. So, you're returning out
of artifacts from
graveyard. And there's no one a turn
restriction. The restriction is life.
But life we can work around, we can get
around. So I think this is the deck for
small
artifacts because if you're playing big
artifacts, you can just do chroom. There
are tons of other options and you have
to cast them,
right? I'm thinking this is the deck for
artificer intuition. You'll see what I
mean.
Artificers intuition.
This is a survival of the fittest for
trinkets. Discard an artifact. Search an
search for an artifact with one CMC. So,
you can keep chaining those. Like you
can activate it three, four times and
then cast them all from your graveyard.
Now, the only thing is we have to see
what the small artifacts look like if
they're good enough. But for now, I
we're going to try we're going to try
we'll try
the small artifacts. the artifacts that
can crack themselves so you can get
double value. It's almost like eggs
second breakfast, but we're not playing
second breakfast
because maybe we can play Second
Breakfast. We'll see. We'll see.
Okay, so now we're searching for
artifacts that
are one CMC. Yeah.
artifact one mana value equal to one
search.
Whoops. I have to restrict the color to
blue black
asper. Why? What's wrong with this
color? Oh, sorry. Color identity.
Wait, first bobble. Of
course, that reminds me there's a card
called Salvaging
Station. I'll see if that if that works
here. Yep. Salvaging Station
here. Return target non-creature
artifact card with converted mana cost
one or less from your graveyard to play.
Whenever whenever creature is put into
graveyard from play, you may untap. So
whenever you kill a creature, we'll have
to hold it here. We'll see what the
trinkets do. If they're able to kill
creatures, I doubt it. But if not, we
don't have an enabler for this. But here
are the trinkets. That's for sure. We'll
see. Uh this is the kind of stuff. Yeah.
Expedition
map. Graveyard hate. Yes.
Gingerbrook? No, probably
not. Uh, do we want to mill each Oh,
each opponent. No, we
don't. What about where are the bobbles?
Okay, codeex rer is
great. A vexing bobble, sure. Draws you
a card. Yeah, all the ones that draw you
a card are
fine. Ether spell bomb,
sure. What does the stone do?
Oh, that's a good one.
Star. Sure. We are playing eggs. Yeah,
we're playing eggs. The only problem
though is they cost life to
do. So, we have to figure out ways to
gain life. But basically, right now, we
we can get a full board of artifacts
fairly easily
and we'll have to work with
that. Yeah, this I How is this one so
low? It's like the best one. My house
spell we don't want relic can pretend
this but traveler's amulet is
fine. This card a card create a food but
this
good this one is good. Wait this one is
decent because it gains you life and n
but food costs too much mana to crack.
We'll see if we're desperate for life.
We'll come
back. Yeah. So we have kind of an eggs
package and then we need payoffs and
what the payoff will be
is for each artifact you control
something like that. So we
will search for
that for each or each
artifact you
control. See where see what we can get.
Why?
Why CMC? Oh,
CMC. Okay, now it should be
good. How can I just default wreck by
EDH? I I maybe we can do
that. Or is
this your artifact make? Yeah. Yeah,
that's a game changer. But we'll see.
We'll put it in for
now. Equipped plus one for each
artifact. Can our commander go Voltron?
He's got
lifelink.
Okay. You know what? Seems
decent. Whenever one or more artifact
artifact creatures enter the
battlefield.
Nope. Nope. Oh, yeah. This is the
payoff, right? It's like every all my
artifacts are full force
flying. Yeah, we can alpha
strike create a white gnome. Each
artifact in the main phase, you tap five
untapped artifacts. Okay, this seems
like the cast artifact use mana produced
by bra. You white gnome
soldier. Uh, but it only happens once a
turn. I still think it's Yeah, I still
think it's good. Still think it's good.
Cranial
plating. Cranial
plate. I think it's
fine. Horizon shine.
Yes. Yeah. This is the Yeah, this is the
kind of ability I want. Tesarette,
master of the bridge, deals X damage to
each opponent while X is the number of
artifacts you control. You gain one
life. Beautiful. You gain X life. Sorry.
Whenever an artifact
N cost one last to cast, reveal cards
until you get an
artifact, create
to whenever you cast an artifact spell.
Yeah, this is the kind again, this is
the kind of payoff we want. Okay, we
have a deck. We have a deck. We have
payoff. We have engine payoff.
And yes, yes, yes, yes. Za Öza, chief
artificer.
Perfect.
Karm. Okay. So, we'll stop here. And
yes, we're going to need some life gain.
Need some life gain. So, how we're going
to do it is I think
artifact. Oops. Whoops. What did I do?
What did I
do? Sorry.
Artifact gain
life. I remember there being an angel.
That's super good. Why are these We're
not searching for trinkets. Don't give
me trinkets.
Staff of Domination, Elixir of
Immortality, Trading
Post. I mean, I'm discarding a
card just to play it from the graveyard
for three life and then I gain four life
out of it. No, no. Ether Flux.
Yes. I mean it's again the the 50 damage
ability is getting more and more awkward
just because again it's 50 life and also
because of deflecting squat is
everywhere now. So but the life gain is
super relevant. Avengers sphere. Why
not?
Sure. Uh but we need more life
gain. Life gang. We got this already. We
got
Tesarette. Lambus. What does Lambbus do?
Shuffle.
Wait, it's shuffle.
No. Does this gain life?
Nope. Is that all? No, there's the
angel. Even though the name is called
filigree
angel. Also, salvation station is
probably not going to work just because
we don't have the
enters the battlefield. Yeah, this is
massive life gain. And also, I think we
need just some straight up life gain
like uh one of my favorite
cards. This is awkward. I forgot the
name of my favorite card. It's called
Resolute
Archangel. Please be right. It is right.
Wrestle Archangel. When it enters, my
life goes back to 40. Need
it. Is this the deck for Thought
Foundry? I think it is. I think it is
because you gain a life and it's just
Yeah. It's just
value. Yeah. Yeah. Again, this is the
kind of payoff. Beautiful. I'm sure
there's more. There's more what we're
doing here. Like the one with affinity
for artifact. What's it called?
Monitor something. Monitor. I think
there 13 of them. The one with flying
three uh draws you two cards when it
enters. Thought monitor. There you
go. Oops. But there's one more card.
That's it. Tainted Sigil. Yeah, you
sacrifice tainted sigil. You gain life
equal to the to life total life lost by
all players this turn. So what you do
here
is you can, you know, cast a bunch of
artifacts, cast this, sack it to gain,
say 21 life, and then you can cast it
again, pay three more life, and then
gain 24 more
life. Yeah, this will just double your
life total. Not double, but double the
life
loss and then gain that back. So, seems
really good.
Then lastly, we're going to look for
some second breakfast cards. Second
sunrise. And what's the other one? Faith
something. Second sunrise. Sure. Faith
re
something. Faith renewed. Faith's
reward. Yes. Beautiful. Just a few just
to see. Yeah, we have a This is deck
looks really fun to
play.
And we are 47 minutes in. Holy crap. How
many decks do we have? Five decks. 47
minutes in. Okay. I I mean, I'm going a
little bit deep with these, but I'll try
to maybe have a label for all the decks
so that you can skip to the deck you
want to see. But for
now, if you watched all the way to here,
thank you. And if you're still awake,
you should be falling asleep to this
probably. So we are doing select all and
put them put them all into Noctis.
Noctis next Ignis
Scientia. This is the
nerd. And what's what does he do? He
enters look at the top six cards of your
library. Put a land card. Okay. So this
is like a a mana rep, a meta elf in
commando. That's good. And then the
ability says he's
cooking. Exile higher card from
graveyard. If a creature card was exiled
this way,
create. Oh, this is
terrible. How? So it's graveyard hay for
three mana and then you make a food that
you can crack for two mana to gain three
life. Like it's not even we're not even
building food. I I'm not going to fall
for it. I'm not building food because
you're making one food a turn. It's
awful. Getting a land is decent. But
this guy, yeah, like he's camping. He's
cooking, but he's cooking with
chemicals. And none of these bottles are
probably labeled properly. So, I think
he'll cook whatever comes
up. And this is the crap uncommon of
simic. I'm hoping I'm hoping this is the
worst worst one. Uh, but I think we're
just going to build around the first
ability. We're going to ignore the
second one. I mean, late game you can
use it. But we're able to get five mana
on turn four. That's what's important,
right? So, we can play five drops. We
can play, I guess, beatd down. We can
play value, whatever. We'll see what
five drops we have in
Simic. This is the only way I can think
of. So, let's go to simic. Whoops.
Simic. And we're not going to restrict
card type. We're just going to go mana
equal
five. We should have some. I mean,
you're in semic, so it's never bad. And
your commander again ramps, so your deck
is probably fine. But this is the least
interesting commander we've seen so
far. It's probably not an important
character. Probably shows up everywhere,
but doesn't do
much. Has that energy in him.
Return of the wild
speaker. Okay. First of all, double
season shatic
revelation seabore
muse so we can make more
food.
Sure. No, it's a game changanger. Let's
avoid it for now. Tata, sure. Why not?
All these cards are better than a
commander,
but contra. Oh, we can blink our
commander. It's so bad. Is this a blink
deck? It's
not. Sure. Maybe we can go
aggressive. Yeah. Yeah. Let's let's go a
bit aggressive just because we want the
game to finish fast
because we probably hate our own
deck. Double whatever type of for uh
it's only
forest. Yes, these kind of
cards. Garoot,
sure. Yeah, you can't really build
around food or landfall because it just
doesn't do anything. That doesn't do
enough to to enable
either. So, yay. So, we're back. Oh,
dear.
Castle. So,
whoops. Yep. This is how far we're
taking it. Don't Don't build this guy.
Don't build Ignis. Omega Heartless
Evolution. I hope this one is better.
But see some I look at sometimes some of
these abilities have names but some of
them don't. Why is that? That's super
confusing. This is like a robot. It's
probably like the ultimate weapon of the
villain, right? It seems. I mean seven
out of 88.
So just one second. Let me bring
Ignis. Excuse
me. When Omega enters for each opponent
tap up to one target nonline permanent
that opponent controls. put X stun
counters on each of those permanence.
You gain X
life. So
your H. Okay, that doesn't do much for a
seven
drop. How are we building gain life and
it cares about nonbasic lands, but the
payoff isn't
amazing. So do we play Omega Heartless
Evolution? Do we play aggro for this
just to just be like at the top
end or we can play blink? We keep
blinking Omega to gain life and top
things down and then voltron people with
Omega. Omega seven meta though. What do
we do before he comes down? Ramp ramp
and
blink. Is that any
good? I guess. Yeah, I guess it's better
than just playing aggro because Simick
is not that great for being aggressive.
We had no choice with Ignis, but with
Omega, I think I like the blink and
clone. Yeah, maybe the blink and clone
it as much as we can and use it to
voltron people because we just need plus
three for this to be a two shot. And
we're not too worried about life because
we can gain a decent amount of life like
probably, you know, five life per per
ETB. Okay, we will try that. Omega. So
first of all we are going to blink
spells equal to no this is not what we
want.
Simic
exile
return. So some of the same cards with
kefka
believe. Yes. Yes. Yeah we can in theory
we can just tap everything down.
Why? Where's the maybe board? Here you
go. Sure. Also serves as protection
because our commander is so expensive.
Sure.
Displace
blur planer in session to freeze. Now,
don't blink on your main face because
your opponent, your commander can't
attack if you do that. a blink on your
last opponent's
turn. Estrid. Okay, so we have blink.
And now what? Now
we we can place some payoff cards for
placing counters. Like my favorite card,
my other favorite card is called
generous
patron. Yeah.
Whenever you place a counter on
opponent's cards, you get you you draw a
card. So each blink you're drawing maybe
three cards, which is really good. And
then maybe some other payoff for tapping
your opponent's things. Let's see. Uh
we're going to search for
tap
opponent creature. Tap
whatever. This should
do. It's probably not too many. There's
a bunch.
Okay, maybe we play the top deck.
Topping things. We'll see if there's
enough payoff. I don't think there's
enough payoff. There's
a white blue deck. I forgot the name,
but it's like the ice queen from
from not hra. Yeah, but you need white
in blue. There is Oh, there's rarity
circle. It's decent.
And then fear of sleep
paralysis. Okay, that's some
payoff. Looks like that's all we
get.
[Music]
Sometime draw a card for each top. Well,
there's draw a card for each type
creature your opponent's control. Is
there? I remember there being one of
those. Draw a card for each tapped
creature. We'll try it. Draw a card for
card for each tapped
creature. Let's
say target opponent though. We want all
of our
opponents. Nope. Three. Six mana though.
Not sure about
that. Are there no better options?
Top up to two target creatures with stun
counter. Gain control. Draw card. Target
opponent. Target
player for target your opponent has in.
Is this target
opponent? Target opponent. Okay. Not
that much payoff for tapping things.
Tapping things. Yeah. So then we are we
need rep. lots of
rep because our commander is so
expensive. Again, I'm not sure about
building around this commander,
but this is the only kind of interesting
way to do it. So, we'll try it. We'll
try it. Uh,
ramp
scrifall
ramp. Let's get it.
So put in some ramp cultivate kamas
reach of
course and
uh kamas
reach.
Yeah. And we also need some ways to kill
with our
commander. So we just need plus three.
Now what are the best ways to give plus
three is my question.
Plus three or just plus X. Plus X plus
something. Target
creature. It has to be
green.
Go. All right. Pumping our commander.
Protecting
it. This is fine. Pump.
This is fine. Plus two though, not quite
what we
want. Yeah, like the combat tricks will
be lowered down just because there's a
lot of good value cards that Yeah,
overprotect. This is what we
need. I was wrong. Never mind. We don't
want plus three. We want
plus We want plus
five. Yes. Because otherwise we need two
spells. Yeah, we want plus
five. So let's see some bigger pump
spells. Maybe an aura or
something. Plus five.
any Yeah, this kind of card. We need to
finish the
game. Yes,
trample. I also remember there being Oh,
there you go. Final
burst. Yeah. Yeah. So, we have blink
cards, we have finishers,
and what about life gang
payoff? Not in simic. I cannot think of
any in simic. Okay, this is a deck.
Again, this is so far of all the decks
we've built, I think this one will be
the least effective. And if you have a
better way to do this, please let me
know. But it's a cool card. I want to
make it work. So, maybe I'll try again
later. So select
all new category
omega. All
right. The wandering
minstrel. This is the bard. Yeah. This
guy clearly
homeless. And uh again everywhere you
see them everywhere but doesn't do
anything. Knows every song except for
the one you want to hear. And uh again
homeless so he overcompensates with all
the stories he tells about the towns
he's visited. Yeah. Cares about all the
towns. And when you question him he
overreacts, pumps
everything. You never know who I played
for. Uh creatures get plus X number of
towns, but there's not that many towns.
And this ability is not good. You get a
creature every turn.
So yeah, I'm feeling I'm starting to
feel both of these ability, the second
and third ability combined won't be as
good as just the first. The first one is
just an emulative vigor. That's super
good. And we can play Yeah, we can play
EDH Summer Bloom. Titan Bloom. Bloom
Titan. Is that what it's called? Yeah,
that sounds fun. But Bloom Titan
requires you to play a few balance a
turn. use all that mana to do
something. I've always wanted to do this
deck in EDH. Maybe this is the best
commander for that. The deck with 10
bounce lands and all the extra land land
drop spells. Cool. So, we're playing
bounce
lands. Uh, return land pipeline land.
Bounce land, bounce land, bounce land.
You get the idea. We want all 10. And
then we
want, of course, emulet of
vigor as backup for our
commander. And now that we're playing 10
bounce lands, maybe more. Are there
other bounce lands? Maybe. But for now,
we're playing all these bounce lands.
What we want
is payoffs for lands entering. Oh, we
want to play extra lands. Okay.
Additional land. Whoops. Additional.
Yeah, additional
land. Green doesn't have to be green.
Green. No. Yeah, just additional lands.
Enough.
Try
ausa. Oops.
Azusa.
Exploration. Why this happens?
Exploration.
Oracle. Do I want that? I don't I don't
want to bounce two lands. That's not
It's not
advantageous. Original land. Sure.
Landfall. Yeah, it's six mana, but you
will get this out super early. So, the
play pattern will be you play your
commander and
then hopefully an exploration effect.
So, on turn three, you will play
exploration or a Zusa and then you play
bounce land
tap, bounce land
tap, and you have like six six mana on
turn three or turn
four. That's nice. That's nice. We'll
we'll figure out how to use that manner
later, but we still want to Yeah, we
want more enablers cuz we want to
consistently be able to drop extra
lands. And
uh
sure. Okay, now that we have this, what
do we do with the mana? We're going to
draw lots of cards because this mana we
get on our main phase. So, we don't need
instant speed draw. And we want some,
you know, for
example, what's it called? the best draw
spell recurring insight and this is like
to this day I don't think any draw spell
tops this in terms of e efficiency six
mana draw 10 12 sometimes more and uh
seagate
restoration oh yeah this reminds me we
we should play a lot of these MBFCs
right
because you can play them and you can
bounce for a value you can use them like
later. Yeah. So MDFC's
shorter modal double face is that okay
let's
see why only
two sure this is fine I think if we if
we end up playing some
creatures. No, no,
no. Yeah, just add a few just to as a
reminder. Sure,
sure. Oh, there's Yeah, there's a lot we
can choose from. Okay. And next
up, so now that we have land, we have
card draw, we have this big huge value,
what are we doing with
it? I think the easiest way is just
again do landfall payoff.
Is there a better something better more
interesting we can
do? I don't think so because again we're
this ability is not good. It's not good.
We'll play some towns of course. But
we'll see what towns there are I
guess. Excuse
me.
Town not
NDFC. This is so bad. Gain two life. Oh,
we can bounce it in game more life. It's
still pretty
bad. It's
terrible. I guess we're playing
them. Are
we? I mean, at least ah I don't think
we're using the ability. Are
we? Maybe at least make it, you know,
overrun. It's not It's not terrible as a
mana sync because you will have a lot of
mana. Okay, we'll play some towns. Yeah,
like this capital city cycling. Not
this. We want colored mana. Hide
away. No, it doesn't work.
I Eden, seat of the sanctum, mil to
return a
thing. Think we want
colors. Yeah, we'll play this cycle.
Don't care what they
do. What's this? Unless it's your first,
second, third pay one. Sure. Starting to
town, the gold coin flip town. Thunder.
Yes. Beautiful. Now, yeah, I'm pretty
sure we're doing landfall
payoffs. Text
landfall. No
MDFC.
Excuse
swarm Avenger.
Sure.
Yay. Anything more
interesting? Not
really. Do you have a
deck? And since you're saving a lot of
money because you don't have room for
dual lens or shock lens in this
deck, we can play something expensive,
right? Because you're playing five
color. Your budget should be high. We
are playing the tabernacle. Wait, not
the tabernacle.
Condalabra because we're playing bounce
lands. This
is super
ramp. Anything we want to add? Cuz five
color is so open. You can do a lot of
things. But I think this is yeah a
decent skeleton. If you can think of a
better payoff than landfall cards, let
me know because I'd love something a
little bit different. But this deck
seems fun to
play. All right, next
up, Cloud. Okay, this is the main
character. I know Cloud. He's the kind
of guy that says, "Oh, I I fight alone."
And then joins the team
fight. Only works for
money, but then I remember doing a lot
of free quests. So, a very conflicted
character. Doesn't know what he wants.
Also, not a lot of character development
from what I
saw, but I guess I I only played for 10
hours. So, Cloud Planet Champion Red
White during your turn as long as Cloud
is equipped. One second. I need to move
this. This one
is bar the wondering minstro
minstro. Okay, back to cloud. As long as
cloud is equipped as double strike. Wow.
And
indestructible equip abilities cost two.
Wow. Okay. This is really good. It's
like it reminds me of Zurggo from the
the old Zurggo Mardu where it's
indestructible. So you play a bunch of
board
wipes. Why are these not
in Oh. Oh wait.
What? One second.
Minstro. Okay, now Cloud can
go. But we'll play a bunch of
equipments. What equipments will we
play? The ones that take advantage of
the double
strike equip cost two. Yeah, it's the
swords. Uh, sort
of blah
blah. Not this one. Maybe this
one. Yeah, we can one-shot people with
it. Sure. And it's not going to cost too
much because I mean cloud is five mana
and other equipment would be another
three or four so it's reasonable. And
equip two. Yeah.
Perfect. Body and mind. Nope. Feast of
feminine. Yes. Sword and fire and ice.
Yes. Hearth and home. Do we want a blink
cloud? Not
really. But we want the land. We do.
Maybe we can blink cloud sometimes
because equip is cheap
anyways. Sword of
ours. Once in future. What the su and
steel we can play a few of
these. War in
peace. Sword of truth and justice. Truth
and justice. Proliferate. Don't really
need that. Wealth and power. Get
treasure. Cast spells for free. That's
fine.
It's fine. Okay, then we'll play some
board
wipes. Destroy all
creatures.
Destroy all
creatures. Why are we still doing
MTFCs?
Whoops. I think this is
fine. Sure. Frost your command. Good
word
wipe. Fumigay, great board wipe.
Cleansing Nova, good
card. Forgot to do red, white, but it's
mostly white
anyways. Wins.
Nope. Okay, you get the idea. Okay. And
then of of course blasphemous
act. And once you have that, so cloud
will be two shot sometimes one
shot. What more can we do with cloud?
Double strike free to equip or cost two
less to
equip. We want some protection spells
because we are pretty going pretty much
all in with cloud. So, let's look
for Oh, we want also want protection
from color. Yes, because it also gives
us
evasion. So, we'll prioritize these
chromos. See, even if you don't get the
double strike, this card is still pretty
good, but it's expensive. So, we'll
leave it for now because it's not as
good as in other
colors. Sure. Apostle's blessing.
Good. No. Brave the
elements.
Sure. Eldrich
immunity. This is actually good because
it works through the swords because
imagine if I have a sword of oh see
sword
of what's it called? wealth and power
negates
the protection spells. You cannot cast
them. I think it's still good. Still
good. Um, yeah, but if you have like
worm piece equipped, you cannot use the
white protection
spells, but immunity you can still do.
But I still think it's worth
playing. So, we got swords, protection
spells, board
wipes, card draw. Yeah, of course.
Draw equipment. Yeah, this turning into
a fairly standard equipment deck. Not
much not too much interesting things
going on. Draw a card.
Equipment. Attack player with one or
just draw a
card. Tap that
creature. This is decent protection for
cloud, I'd say. Oh, yeah. I want
Boros. Boros.
Whenever equipment you control interest,
you may discard. I don't want to
discard. Search your light grave for
light a card named spirit of Leonitis.
We can play the spear. Spirit is good.
Onto battlefield. Shuffle control attach
deals combat damage. Legendary. How many
legendary equipments do we have? Oops.
Not
many. Search for a spear. But what if we
draw the spear? This card wouldn't be
good.
But still, okay, graveyard hand.
Battlefield. Okay, I think we play
it.
Uh, okay, we play it. Spirit. The spear
is good. I'll search for
it. Double strike is relevant, but you
can create a token or you can discard
and draw. You can filter.
So, Mahiri. No. Yeah, this is what I'm
looking for. Pure
steel and
ceram. Also, we need some finishers
because in Boros, we're not playing the
long game. We have to finish as soon as
we can. So, additional
combat, double strike with additional
combat is just
brutal. Except when I fail the
search. What? Oh, sorry. Addition. No
combat. Why? Oh, what? Addition. No.
Sorry. Okay. Ak battle squad on tap. All
no. I like Aurelia. Do I like Aurelia
more? I think Aurelia is
better. Combat Cbron. Maybe not. No.
Emer. Oh. When my legend needs to die.
Full throttle. The best
one. Genji glove.
Excellent. Great train heist. You get
two treasures. Yes, you get two
treasures. You get pump. You get
additional combat if you pay the full
cost. Decent. This one you get pump and
you
get extra combat. It's slightly risky,
but your commander has
indestructible and also you don't want
protection from red when you cast this.
But I think it's worth it. I think it's
worth
it. And uh this
good five
mana because additional combat cards
should be like not that expensive
ideally so that you can you know squeeze
it in late game and among like but along
with the other uh other things you do.
So I'm thinking maybe we play this one
like overpowering attack.
Yeah, because it will cost three mana if
your command commander gets
through.
Rayu is cloud is not a samurai.
No, it sees the day. One of the best
ones. Okay. And last, I think that's it.
We need some ramp, of course,
but seems
obvious. Yeah, we have a deck. This deck
is pretty strong, I'd say, because cloud
is very pushed.
Makes sense. It's the main
character. All righty. Select all.
Cloud. Next. Guillot, King of the
Dwarfs. Whenever guilt or another dwarf
you control interest, uh, whenever
equipment you control interest, you may
discard a card to draw a card.
Oh, this is not
good. But it's it's really
aggressive. Yeah, you can play this like
cloud, but it's more aggressive
because it's
cheaper. Okay. Okay. We have a plan for
this. We can play those equipments that
enter
attached.
Yes. We'll see. We'll see if there's
enough good ones. Enter.
Attach. Target creature. Uh, attach
creature. All right. Tipline
equipment. And we want it to be red,
white within red, white. Yes.
Done. Okay. I remember some good ones
off the top of my head. If there's
enough, we can have a decent vron deck.
Sure. My throw code. Hammer of non.
Ember cleave. No. Double strike. Hero
was
played. No. Silvershield. Yes. Mall of
the sky. Good card.
Molir. Tap target creature. Defending
play control. Oh
yeah. Again. Doesn't do anything. We're
doing
Voltron. You know when the uncommon
commander doesn't even want to. You are
not a good card.
Hidden blade. Wait, frying pan. Let's
see. Create that many halfling x amount
of life you
gain. Whenever you gain life now, if I
give it a lifelink, there's some
synergy. But right now, it's just plus
six plus
six. No, no, no. Doesn't
work. Doesn't work. This one is
beautiful. Celestial armor. Nuts
card. Uh, three or less return creature.
Oh, this can return a commander. Good.
Good card. Crowbar.
Nope. Rogue. Are we a
rogue? No, we're not. We're like some
crappy side quest
villain. It's like the one that's all
goofy
and turns out to be decently strong but
difficult to take seriously despite
that. We will fight along with you for
the planet or
home. I might be a little bit off. Seems
like seems like a recruitable character.
Hard to say. Dwarf
Noble. All right. Dissection tools. Five
mana is expensive, but you get No, it
doesn't attach to our commander. Morning
Star plus one
trump.
No flying plus one. Yeah, it's
fine. Plus two flash. Yeah,
probably. Uh, hidden
footblade. First strike. We don't need
that. Plus one haste. Plus one haste.
me dualist rap
here plus two. Yeah, we want these
ones.
Okay. And then now that we have all
these equipments enter, we'll trigger gu
a lot. We'll be discarding a lot. How do
we use that
discard? Discard a card. Draw a card.
Play things from graveyard.
Not sure what we can do. I think it's
just for
filtering, right? Whatever. I think it's
quite good. Just discard what you don't
need at the
moment, but I guess we can play some
discard synergies because we're in
Boros. And if we can net some card
advantage from that, we'll take it. Uh
discard whenever discard. Whenever you
discard
a Yeah. Not not equipment.
Sorry. Why? I'll go back. Whenever you
discard. Yeah, we're
fine. We're not fine.
Whenever Oh, sorry. Whenever you
discard. I can't think of some good ones
already. Not this. Yes.
This. No. Maybe. But not not right now.
Uh whenever you discard you can No. No.
Brass tunnel discard draw if you just
send it this turn. Put a board counter
if there are three board counters. What
does it
do? Discover X doesn't do enough. I
think doesn't do enough. Doesn't do
enough. Doesn't do
enough. Whenever you discard one or more
cards extop card library, you can play
it. This might be
okay. Oh, it also pumps our commander. I
think that's enough payoff. Just two
mana
in artist talent. Cast an uncreature
spell. You may discard a double discard.
They cost one less. Is that relevant for
us? A little bit. Yeah, it's relevant.
I'm I'm think I'm listening. If a source
you control deal non Never mind, I'm not
listening. Monument of endurance.
Discard a card. Beautiful. This is what
I'm looking for.
Sturly badasaur. Whenever you discard a
creature card, land card, non-creature
or non land, it
fights. It's decent. Four mana is
expensive. And also doesn't really give
us card advantage. Just fights
things. Guess it's
okay. Now, this is what I've been
looking for. Bag of holding.
Beautiful currency
converter.
Yes. And then we play
the seram and crystal paladin. What else
do what other payoffs do we have in
cloud? P steel paladin.
Seram. I think that was it. I think that
was it. Yeah. Uh so we will do the same
here.
Ceram pure
steel. And of course we want protection
spells for our commander and double
combat. So this is a similar
deck to cloud but it's way more
aggressive. Cloud is more like late
game. It will go into mid game at least
and then it will control the board
boardwide cloud. But this guy is just
all
in.
So
additional
combat. Put it the same
ones. Full
throttle. Genji
glo.
No great train
heist. Grim reapers print. Yeah, there
you go. And then we protection spells.
Of course, we need those. And here we
can play once again. Yeah, once again we
want protection from color.
Ideally protect from
color.
Sure. Sure. Just have a
few brave the elements.
Okay. And now let's just in case just in
case it's relevant, we're going to look
at some dwarfs. I doubt it. I doubt
it.
But we might be surprised because dwarfs
do work with artifacts. Do work with
artifacts. I mean, Saram is a dwarf,
right? I
think. Not going to
check.
Huh? What happened to my
dwarf? No, I need I need type. Sorry.
Creature
type
dwarf. Yes, I think that's why.
Thram. All right, we already have him.
Magda.
Nope. Torban. Torband. Source control.
Deal damage to opponent double damage.
It's okay. It's four mana
though. Bor. Speaking of four mana, this
one seems worth the four mana. Yeah,
this card is excellent for rebuilding
when your commander if your commander
dies or something. Just also a great
finisher. Okay, we have a few decent
dwarfs. Whenever a creature control get
attack, double strike.
Nope. Historic spell create a treasure.
This seems fine. We're casting a bunch
of historic spells,
right? Historic payoff. H might be
good. Another
legendary artifact play
too. Sure. Yeah, we are playing small
equipments, right? Bunch of SC. Ideally,
we want maybe 15 to 20 for these payoffs
to be decent. What does this do?
Kadrick.
Nope. Okay, we have a
deck. Any other graveyard interaction we
can
use? Oh, like something like forge in
you perhaps forge and
you there's a lot of return equipment
you can equip for free.
Yes. All right, we have a deck. So,
select all. Go
into what's his name again?
Guilt rhymes with
idiot. Next up, Joshua. This card looks
cool. It's like a
burning. When Joshua enters, discard up
to two cards, then draw that many cards.
Okay, this looks good. And then we can
exile Joshua, then return it to the
battlefield, transform under its owner's
control. It's very expensive. Let's hope
the backside is
good. The backside is not
good. Wow, this is terrible.
I mean once you get to you can return
creatures from great but but I have to
wait three I have to pay eight mana wait
three
turns flying
lifelink I guess it gains you two life
not two life gains you six life in four
player but man I don't know it's not
good who is this guy anyways in ashen
grip let ember glow to kindle flames in
you Okay. No information
added.
Probably doesn't die cuz Phoenix. It's
all I can think of. Probably a really
strong character that just swoops in for
one of your battles and then leaves.
Refuses to elaborate. Everything is
burning, but his clothes are not
burning. So, these fires are probably
not real fires just for the just for the
looks. Yeah. just for the vibes. The
intimidation
factor seems good. But it looks like we
are building around the discard too.
Yeah, we'll try Boros's graveyard, but I
doubt anything will come
up. I mean, there's something. We'll
see. We'll see. Okay, so just search
graveyard. Graveyard. Yep.
and see what comes
up. Farewell sun titan savings
reclamation
anger
underworld. Yeah, there isn't really any
payoff. Okay, I'll keep looking. Feldon
kind of
is,
but oh boy.
This is rough. I think we might have to
just go borrow good stuff with some
graveyard
payoff. Does the transform really not do
anything? I mean, it is graveyard. Yeah.
So, but you can't build around this
ability is the problem. And you can't
build around the first one either.
What's it going to do? I gain six
life. Yeah. And more importantly, he's
not guaranteed to flip. You're paying
this mana at sorcery
speed. Yeah. Although if I'm your
opponent, I'll let you flip because I
know you're not doing anything. I know I
know the front side is even worse.
Sorry, the back side is even worse.
Yeah, but it's it's reusable, right? The
backside blinks into the front side. So,
you get two more discards for more
value. Okay, so Boros, good stuff. And
that's the easiest one to search for
because you just go Boros. No
text. I think we want no colorless.
Okay, we don't want lands or artifacts
for now. Uh, we want artifacts. Okay, no
lands for now. So,
land.
Cool. You know, I was teaching actually
I I teach some kids English and I was
teaching them about
oxymoron. Boro's good stuff is an
oxymoron. I just
realized. Sure. Play all the cards. All
the good cards.
Yay. Path of swords. Put them
in. But let's go
fast. Sure. We are desperate. Sure. Yes.
Yes. We need all
these faith looting in case later we
have some discard. Yes. The one ring. Of
course, we're we are bracket four, kids.
We're bracket four.
Yes, we don't need this because we don't
need to protect our
commander. Might as well. The redirect
could be
useful. What other good stuff do we
have? Hero's horn. No, roaming through.
Roaming through. Does that is any
good? Human noble wizard. They don't
even share a type. Okay, never mind.
Farewell. Sure. Is that a game changer?
Okay, we want to look for cards that are
actually interesting though. So, go go
go go
go. Yeah, we want we can hopefully find
the payoff for all the discarding we're
doing. I think we
can sometime there's a
payoff
ravenous reclamation target. I think
this is fine. You can get
lands. Sure. Setting up for something
big. It's coming up any moment. It's
coming up. This card is good. Uh maybe
not. Lentax.
Yes. Anger. No, cuz we're not even
creature a creature stack right
now. Underworld
breach.
Sure. It's not good. It's not that good.
[Music]
But where's our graveyard stuff?
I guess it won't come up until super
late. So maybe maybe we What if we
search
Lold? No. Where's the grave search
again? Graveyard. Graveyard. It should
take a closer
[Music]
look. Yes. Yes.
Yes. Dusk.
Nope. And now that we're not really
focused on any theme, we just want
generic graveyard stuff. There's some
some decent
cards. Feldon is fine. Feldon is fine.
We don't have that many creatures, but I
think we we will. Are we?
Uh well, we'll see. We'll
see. Graveyard. I think I wasn't patient
enough. I think I should look more cuz
like you know America effort great card
early
restoration
me temple graveyard
synergy. I think this is the deck. Yeah,
I wouldn't recommend building over
playing this deck. It's gonna cost you a
bunch and not do
much, but unfortunately this is the best
I can do with Joshua. Can you think of
something better? Man, I am
disappointed. I'm disappointed in myself
because
I if you again, if you force it, you can
force kind of build around the two
damage, double the damage, gain lots of
life, ether flux someone, but I don't
think it's I think it's even worse. And
also, I can't wait to move on to my
favorite morals commander in the set,
Lightning. This one I knew about because
I I died to it a lot of times
already. Damn you,
Alex
Joshua. Lightning seems like one of
those main characters, right? Has to be.
I mean, it's a
mythic. And human soldier, lightning, it
flashes bright, then fades away. It
can't protect. It only destroys. So
again, one of these really
one-dimensional characters that just
does one thing, right? Kind of cool.
Doesn't talk
much.
Uh yeah, probably has the same outfit
five
times. It's fast. First try trample
lifelink is super pushed. Stagger
whenever lightning deals combat damage
to a player until your next turn. If a
source would deal damage to that player
or a permanent that player controls,
double that damage. And this is
ridiculous. This is a really powerful
ability in Imboral's aggro like just
because lightning hits first and all
your other creatures will now have
double damage against that
opponent. So, you're taking down one
opponent at a time. I've seen some
people try burning, but burn is just not
that efficient.
And sure, damage is double, but it's not
not to each opponent, right? Burn cards,
a lot of them are for every
opponent. So, I want to try
aggro. Let's see how what small
creatures we can curve
into. Um, lightning, we have Boros, and
we
have just creature for now. And we want
them to be
small, less than four.
Sure. Good start. Facebreaker.
Absolutely. Grand
Abolisher. I think this is good because
again we like cloud and uh what's his
name? Guilt. We we will be doing some
surprise, you know, extra combat
protection evasion. So, we want to be
able to not be responded
to. Do we rack of
them? Probably not. We want cars that
kind of scale with the game that get
bigger, at least aggressively sized,
like this. Yeah, this is the prime
example. Adeline
Cranco Boromir absolutely protecting our
board. We might not drop Lightning on uh
we want to drop it on turn three if
possible. We want to get her I think
attacking as soon as possible. Yeah.
Ranger
Captain. Ranger Captain is not has one
has one
job. Has one
job. is to search for Sarah ascendant
which should come up soon I think is
this good make a thought for every turn
haste not
amazing wizard triggered are we a wizard
we are a human soldier
okay there you go Sarah
ascendant okay so we have okay we want
combat cbrant extra combat is nuts with
lightning just because you can just kill
someone with a an okay board 40 damage
cuz the damage is doubled and then
doubled again for your other creatures.
Yeah. So, we want extra combat.
Absolutely. We won't do that now.
Extra no
additional. This is how Boros we are
playing. We're putting these in almost
every deck except for Joshua because he
sucks. But in every deck, because this
is how Boros wins games, you have to
like your opponents are calculating,
okay, they can do 12 damage to me. I can
untap psychonic rift, but then you do 24
and they're like, oh crap. You have to
catch them by surprise. Um, extra
combat. All
right, we'll
sort
why. Oh, CMC CMC restriction. That's
why Aurelia absolutely is nuts. Carlac,
sure. Scourge is a bit slow. Six mana,
they have to wait for it to attack.
Sure. We want to play a bunch of these.
Want to play seeds the day? Is that
good? Can we vultron someone to death?
Say our commander is three. It attacks
for three and then attacks again for six
and then attacks again for 12. That does
that kill someone? That's not Oh, it
kills someone exactly if it's unblocked.
Oh, no, no, no. What we do is we attack
with our
commander. The rest of the board stays
put and then Yeah. And then we do
additional
combat. On the third combat, if we get
it, the rest of the board goes in. That
is guaranteed to kill
someone.
Yes, I think it's good. I think it's
good. I mean, the interactions is a bit
complicated, but you need to give
lightning some kind of evasion or but
then it's already lethal, but there's
definitely room to play
with.
Uh, yeah. Yeah. Okay, you get the idea.
And also, we need lots of protection
spells. And this time is for the entire
board. So, creatures, oops,
creatures game indestructible.
Uh, strive. No. Oh, Chroma as well.
Absolutely. Holy
crap. Oh, speaking of this, we need we
need some double strike, don't
we? Yeah, we can get some double strike.
Aison, that protection. Now, this kills
our
board. Indestructible borrower. Do we
have it? I think we
do. Yeah, we do.
I chance for
Glory. Is this the deck for Chance for
Glory? No, it's not because it doesn't
even synergize with with our commander.
We want extra combat and double strike.
Divine resilience. Yes. Where is Tfair's
protection? Good
enough. Great card. Grand
Crescendo builds our board and protects
it. Lower hold command.
Yeah. Okay. So,
protection, aggro,
and extra
combat. Is that anything else we want?
We do want some double strike
maybe. So, something like H. We'll see
what double strike there
is. Oh, but double strike only works
with our
commander. It doesn't work. It doesn't
pump the rest of our board.
So, it lets our commander do three and
the six
damage. So, maybe not super necessary.
Maybe we just want some pump because our
commander is I mean it's only three
power, right? Needs to get through. So,
kind of
[Music]
evasion. Okay. Uh what kind of evasion
can we
use? unblock
flying creature get
flying. Don't think it's too
good. Yeah, I think we have to use the
protection from color spells
again. Let's trample though. So, pump
spells.
The pump spells are less good just
because I mean they're great with extra
combat, but on the first attack you're
just pumping. We'll see if there's any
good pump spells first. How about this
plus get plus something and pipeline
will be instant or
sorcery. It could be equipment. Could be
equipment. Oh yeah, like what's it
called? Ember cleave. That's what we're
looking
[Applause]
for. That's the kind of card we're
looking for. Ember
cleave.
Yes. We will do another search. Get
plus. Okay. Can be anything.
Shadow Spear. No command plate. No
glitters. Rising the day. Haste.
Nah.
No. Legendary creatures we control.
Flowering. No.
Rever. Yeah, we don't really want I
don't Most equipments we don't really
want. I think hammer of nazan is
fine. This is fine just for protection.
And also what's it
called? What's the name? Mithro
coat. It's
fine. Am I spelling my
wrong? Myth
coat. What?
Why it's not called coat? There's no
coat in it.
Myth. I can't believe it. Okay, we will
have to search for
it.
Fall
flash equip
indestructible. Mythro cult. Oh, myth.
Sorry, sorry, Mithro. And also this is
great protection spell with evasion
with free to equip flash. Yeah. Holy
crap.
Yeah, this is the kind of card I'm
looking for. I'll keep looking. Does
this do anything? Deals one damage. So,
if you
hit I think this is fine. It's not
amazing. I mean, you hit them and then
you play some creatures, they
become this becomes peripherals, but
then some of your creatures have haste.
You want them to haste, so it's probably
not amazing. Where are my pump spells?
This one? Nope. This is This is a pop
spell. Moon Shaker. Too
expensive. Yeah, you get the idea. This
is a great deck. I would I would love to
play it.
One of my favorite commanders from this
set. Next up, we have Zade Tentilus
thief. Human mutant scout. How is he a
mutant? I don't see
it. Was that a tail?
Oh, it's like a
monkey. Okay, this is Yeah, this is like
the kind of character that lives in the
forest. He lived in a jungle all his
life and then somehow is more sociable,
less socially awkward than the entire
main character
group. Uncommon. Uh, when Zang enters
gain control of target creature and
opponent controls on tap it gains
lifelink and
haste. Whenever an opponent gains
control of permanent from you, you
create a treasure
token. This is not
good. This is not good. It's like the
Zedru deck. It's like the donate
archetype or the act of treason deck.
But the problem is the payoff is
nothing. You get a treasure for all
that. At least give me one card. And you
draw a card. Why can't I draw a card? If
I if I can draw a card, this is
buildable. You can act of treason. They
can trip. You can donate things.
Oh boy, what do we
do? If we do act of treason tribal, so
we steal something every turn and then
we give it back just to smack
someone and then we're defenseless. We
have our treasures to
block. Oh, this is the crap uncommon of
the
set. Give me I don't want to give up.
Give me like 30 seconds. It just it's
interesting,
but I guess we have
to because I know the act of treason
ability is much more powerful at instant
speed. So, would a blink deck be a
thing? Like you blink it. Yeah, it's so
much better when you do it in your
opponent's turn or or you have you
threaten to do it on your opponent's
turn, but I don't think we have enough
instantly blinks to make it work.
Basically, during combat, your opponent
will think that you always have a blink.
So that one, your commander is
protected, and two, they can't attack
you because they attack you, you take
the strongest
creature and block with it, and you end
up with more life than you you started
and they lose their biggest
creature. That's that's really nice.
That's really good. Okay, maybe. Yeah,
maybe this is a thing. The problem is we
cannot do slow blink. Slowblink doesn't
do anything with Zane,
right? Yeah, because you don't return
it. It's till the end of turn. So,
Slowblink doesn't do anything. So, it
has to be the immediate blink. And I
doubt we will have find we'll find
enough, but we will
try. I hope I'm wrong. I hope I'm wrong.
Blink exile
return. Pretty
sure pipeline. We will not restrict the
type. We will search with
these.
Yep. If I'm right, slow uh fast blink.
This is a slow
blink. I saw number you control return
those card. That's slow blink. Slow
blink. Fast
blink. A fast blink.
Oh, we have some decent ones
actually. Mimic fat today.
No. Fast blink. Touch the spirit
realm. Semester's end. This is a slow
blink, I believe. Yes.
Yes. Acrobatics. Is this a slow blink?
This can be a a slow blink. No, we don't
want that. Flicker of Fate. Good card.
Yeah, it's dropping equality real fast.
We only have five. This might not
work. A frozy
displacer. Parting gust is a great card,
but it's a it's a slow blink. No, that's
it. Ghost way. Slow blink. Aldrazi
confluence. This is a blink. Okay. You
can also create a token and choose. You
may choose the same move more than once.
Oh, you cannot blink twice, but you can.
Yeah, you can blink or remove something.
Make Yeah, this is good. Beggars can be
choosers. Just remember to play some
colorless
lens. What does this do? Exile. Oh,
please be a fast.
No, slow blink. Slow
blink. Fast blink. Oh, we have No, not
not quite. We need more. We need more
slow
blink. Oh, this deck needs a
feather. Well, I'm so glad feather came
up with a
search cuz I would never I would never
thought of maybe I would have, but
probably
not. Oh, please just give me Let's see.
Give me one,
two, five more. I need five or six more
blinks. Slow blink. Uh,
sorcery. Sorcery. Scroll shift. Ah,
good. I forgot about these countries.
There's one more. There's one more.
Well, you can't do it. Gaz hourglass
pendant. If a player will be next turn,
that player skips the turn
instead. Uh, no. Yes. Fast blink.
Uh,
okay.
Nice. Flicker Form. I forgot about this
card. Wait. Yes. Okay. We I mean, we
don't have that many that that can
trigger feather, but I still think it's
good cuz we just need one blinking spell
in hand for feather to go nuts. Kind of.
Two is better, but just one astral
drift. When you
cycle, you ex Oh, it's good. It's
good. Ah, end step. Why get away
glamour? No. Against all odds, please.
No, that's not even a blink spell. Other
worldly. Oh, no. It's a slow
blink. Ah, Pegasus exile target creature
control then return. Nice. It's even Oh,
it's even payoff for for blinking.
We have I think we have a deck. I think
we have a deck. Long roll doesn't
work. Astral slide.
No. Whenever uh No.
Morland Parallax Wave. This card is
sweet. Yeah, cuz you can just play for a
mana, hold it, and then blink any number
of creatures. Well, blink up to five
creatures, right? And you don't need to
target five. You can just target sedane
five times if you just want to blink
sedane only. You only get one blink, but
you can in a pinch you can use it and
you can remove five things like
someone's attacking you. You fog
basically or you Oh, I think we are
making a blink
deck. We will see. We will see. Cuz what
else are we putting to the deck? Blink,
right? Stonecloaker angel. Oh, is this
No. Oh, another restoration angel. Yes.
disguise doesn't do
anything. I think that's it. Oh no,
there's an old water. There's an old
card. What's it called? I forgot. We
have to find it. We have to find it.
Okay, this deck I think we might be
going deep with this one. So maybe I'll
leave a time stamp for the next deck if
you want to skip it. Yeah, I will. Cuz
this might take a little while. We are 2
hours in and this is peak and well again
I'm maybe speaking too early. We'll see.
But I have a good feeling about this.
Choose another heart creature. Control
exile.
No. Joshua. Nice to see you
again. Coin of fate. I saw your cards
from No. No. Where's that old
card? If I can remember the name, I can.
It's not here. It's called snappers.
It's not called snap. Someone help me.
Strange. Maybe I'll find it later. But
uh for now, we are going to look for
also red clone spells that can clone.
Zane, but only instance. I'm not sure if
there's any, but we don't want to miss
it if there is. So,
uh,
copy target
creature. Copy
creature
toferno. No, it's
not copy creature. Yeah, I don't think
there's copying target creature in in
red, white, instant speed. So, we have
19 cards and all of them blink
almost. I think this is
fine. And we want to because it's we
have feather. We also want a m Marvin
Mav Mavinda
Mind.
Yes. Because in Boros, we have to, you
know, get the value. We are not getting
too much card advantage.
Now I think we are looking for blink
targets. What other synergy is there?
Can
control. Oh. Oh. Oh. Stiltken. We can
play
stiltkin because we can give some
opponent's cards to what's it called?
Stilt. We can donate someone's card to
another person. Stiltskin. Sorry.
Stiltskin. Target opponent. Gain control
of another target control. Yeah. And
then you pay two to give them that card.
Nice. Usually we'll do this with
commanders. swap their commanders with
each other. And yeah, now we're looking
for enter the battlefield
cards. Enter the
battlefield. We don't want to play too
many. We want to play a few that we can
just keep blinking
and win the game. Hopefully, they can
win the game for us, but we'll see.
We will
see sometime sometime worth
it. Probably
not. Wait, is it a com? No, it's not a
combo with this, but Karma
Guide. Yeah.
Yeah. Sky Cleave Operation. See, this is
This card is good, but I don't think
it's worth a blink because blink spells
are We don't have that many. I mean, we
have a few. We want to save it for other
things. We if we don't have enough
targets, good targets, we will come
back. But
uh
innocence problem is we probably don't
have a lot of two power things. We'll
see. Is the marri shepherd good enough?
I think it might be like it's not ETB,
but we want to keep it on the board just
because just because it's so much value
when we
landfall. I think it's worth
it. Um, Hellkai Corser with this
creature.
Oh, so with this on the field, I can
just blink this. I don't even need to.
It will bring in Zane and
then Zane will
leave. Oh, okay. It's like another
Zedane basically.
It's not super powerful, the but the
interaction is funny. And it's I mean,
six mana is a good card. You can blink
it. Oh, that's really cool. I like it.
Gend. What is What does he do? Nothing.
Flash. Legendary creatures. Legendary
artifact trigger. Oh, double
trigger. Artifact leaving double. I
think that's kind of worth it.
Well, I have to see if we have other
legendary creatures. Uh, maybe not
really. Oh,
but with Gandalf, you have flash with
Gandalf on tap and then you can Zedane.
You blink Zane twice. It's like
immediate
insurrection. Entering or leaving?
Entering or leaving? We'll see. We'll
see. Okay.
Aerial extortionist interest deals
combat exile target non gun
permanent. Okay, this is the card we
This is the kind of removal card we
need. Yeah, sweet. Draws us cards. We
need card draw. Gold gets us an
equipment. I don't think we want
equipments cuz we're blinking unless
it's No, it's not worth it. Yes, this is
the card we
need. Uh, Angeli, by the way. Yeah,
because some of you maybe can't see my
mouse
going. Yeah, you can remove, you can
recur, does everything. Abdo, what does
Abdull do? Exile any number until it
leaves. So, you can
exile. It's too slow, I
think. Samwise, I'm I'm going fast
because these are small cards are small.
Probably don't do much. Angel of
indemnity mana
four mana value
four. I think it's worth it. I think
it's good. I mean unfortunately for some
reason our commander is five mana. I
mean this can be four mana, right? I
guess it's too good and limited
but fine.
Arbaz champion of minus
ter enter the battlefield you choose
monarch you become monarch and it's a
propaganda blinking this we do want
monarch in the game we do cuz it's
difficult for our opponents to target us
but this ability is not what we need
it's fine but it's not we we'll hold it
if we can't find other good monarch
cards we might include this but I feel
Red bite is pretty good for monarch,
right? Glorious
protector until it leaves. Now, this is
like a slow
blink, but can be used as a fast blink
if we have
sacks. Kind of like I kind of want to
play
this
now. How does it work? So, I have a
board and then I flash this in for four
mana. It exalts my board and
now I can just use blink spell on the
angel and it's like blinking
everything. Is that right? And then I
protect my
board. Is that right? I think so.
Whoa, that's super good, isn't
it? Let me double check. Okay, you blink
the angel. Everything comes in, trigger
CTB, and then the angel comes back to
exile everything again. Oh, this is
nuts. I also want that. Oh, yeah. I
missed it, but I also want that card.
This card, right? Because the same
thing. When it enters, exile any
number. Create a token for each one. And
then you blink it. Everything comes in.
You get P.
Oh, okay. We have a deck,
boys. Oh, honestly, I'm sorry,
Lightning, but this might be my new
favorite
deck. I'll have to play it to see, but
this looks sweet on
paper. World. Are we brave enough? No.
Weird. We're not going to world
gorge. What does this do? Scamp. No, not
going to read it. Redemption choir.
Redemption choir enters. If you control
three or more creatures different power
return no glory rise return all human
creatures today is a human what other
human do we
have probably not worth it but exile all
zombies what
if what
if no it's not worth
Essence of
orthodoxy.
No. Bill. What's Bill do? Make two
fruits. Motor load. Mother
load.
Creatures are controlled bust two sent
no Sarah
Leon's two creatures talk said no number
of artifacts are controlled
no I think how many cards do we have we
have 29 cards not that many so I think
there's still
room but how many blink targets do we
have like five or six good ones there's
one I have in mind there's one I in mind
is like
a Oh, is this good? Trove
warden. No, but the one I have in mind
is the the primordial molten primordial.
I think that when it enters, you just
steal two things or one from each
opponent actually, which is really good.
Until we get to that, I'm I would I'm
willing to believe that there's other
quality cards waiting for
us. What does the Buzz Crusher do?
Destroy land. No, doesn't do
enough. Twilight
Shepherd
Ash Lomb number. Oh, it's the same
thing. Do we want another one of these?
I don't think we need another one of
these. Two is enough cuz it's kind of a
bit of a win more card. Like it's nuts
once you get it set,
but also there's not much payoff with
this one. So, I'll skip it for now. Salt
skitter comes into play removed.
No.
Shepherd. The quality is dropping.
Clive. What does Clive do? Discards your
hand. Draw equal to your devotion to
red.
So, we can discard our hand and draw a
minimum
of three, assuming Zane is in play. What
other red permanence do we have? We
don't have many. Let's see the backside.
Although it's probably not relevant. It
is not relevant. Okay. Uh, bishop is
binding. Nope. No. No.
Idolon. Oh, we can have
constellation. Don't think it's good
here.
Boom weaver giant entered search for
battlefield aura card put on battlefield
attached to boom has to be attached to
boom weaver what auras do we have
because I don't want it the only aura is
the what's it called flicker form but I
want that on today so no fear of
abduction leaves the battlefield exile
targeter opponent control no not
goodian savior valued M value too. Nope.
General Leo.
Oh, okay. I'm pretty close to just
searching for that card. Don't think
we're Yeah, don't don't think we're
getting House Molten Primordial Soul.
Nobody plays that card. Card is nuts.
Card is like one of the Okay, maybe not
one of the best, but it's a pretty good
aggro card, I'd say. Okay, let's find
it. Molten.
Prime ore
deal. It's sweet, right? You get to
steal three creatures. You get alpha
strike people and then you get what?
Three
treasures. So now we have 30 cards. And
of course we need some ramp. I might as
well get might as well go there. We need
some ramp. Uh,
Boros
add
artifact cuz Zing is five mana. Five
mana is a lot. We want to be able to get
Zane out and hold a blink spell as soon
as
possible. So, Soul Ring, is this a deck
for
Sunforger? I don't think so. It's what?
Two to uh Sunforger. It's a bit
expensive and all we have is Blink
spells. So, I'm sure we have to play
some removals,
but probably not
enough. Mind stone, commander sphere.
Spear is good. Yeah,
sure. Roaming
throne.
Yes. Yes, we want
that.
Wait. And we can even change the
creature type by blinking it. Not good.
How many humans do we have? It's just
the dang. If it's just the dang, it
might not be worth
it. Yeah. You know what? I don't think
just getting one or two. I don't really
need I just need one steel to shut off
to shut down most combat attempts
against
us. So,
uh sorry, man rocks animal too too big.
Cursed Mirror is sick. Cursed Mirror is
one of the best man. Warm Power Stone is
fine. Relic Legends. This is good
because when you get blinked like Zen
can tap for a mana and then you blink
it, you can tap one more mana. So this I
think is good. Okay, we should play
more, but for now we will just put
these. And next uh 37 cards. We really
we desperately need some card advantage
card draw.
So, how are we drawing cards in Boros?
We
are Monarch. Let's Because again, we are
shutting down combat. We're trying to
shut down
combat. So, let's try to take Monarch.
Although, your opponents can probably
send, you know, two or three small
things at you
and take the Monarch and then it's
difficult for us to take it back. We'll
see if we have any monarch good monarch
cards. Champion is hopefully not the
best
one.
Court Skyland is fine. Ember Wild
Captain. I guess it's like a backup
punishment like for attacking us. I
think this one is fine. I think the
courts are good. Fourth. No. Yeah, I
don't think we want the quartz just
because again because if we get enough
payoff from the monarch, your opponents
will try to take it and then it's like
difficult for us. We have three two
attacking us. Do we do we use Zen or
not? Um
so Impalis Palace Palace Jailer
no Aom king of Rohan double strike when
it
enters put. Okay. When interest target
player becomes
monarch deals damage equal to his power.
I don't think this is that
good. Yeah.
No archon of coronation interest becomes
monarch. As long as you're a monarch
then dam it doesn't
cost. Don't think it's super
amazing. Unfortunately we are going to
have to wait. Is this good card
sacrifice chooses two? No, it's not
good. Unfortunately, we had to find
other ways. I was thinking, what about
humble
defector? Humble
defector. So, you can steal it. You can
steal this with
Zang and then give it again to draw two
cards. So, but the problem is you're
playing you're expending one blink spell
to draw two
cards. In a pinch, it's decent, but then
you're also helping your opponents. And
knowing your shenanigans, your opponents
are probably not going to pass the
defector to
you,
right? Maybe we can play like a mini
package with homework
path. Maybe. Maybe because I just
remember there's another humble defector
in white, but I forgot the name. It's
from
Fallout.
Fallout. It's a roll. Yes man or
something. Yes
man. Oh, it is is Yes. Okay. Target
opponent gains control of target if yes
man personal something. Secure
Securatron. Yeah. What they do? You draw
two cards and put a quest counter. When
yes man leaves the owner create. Okay,
this is this is
good. So we play yesmen and then we have
to have a homework path
package because that's what makes it
worth worth doing. We don't want to
waste our blink spells to draw the two
cards. Now we need things to search for
lands. Search for land.
pipeline. Anything red,
white.
Whoops. Too late. Let's try
again. I do know about weather wafer,
which will be in this deck. But anything
else we can search for lands with. No,
no, no. These are all basic lands. Basic
lands. Basic lands. There's Öza's cave.
I think I can search
for search. No, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no. Oh, this one searches for Yep. Basic
clan. Basic clan. Basic
clan. Weather
wafer. Moon silver key searches for
artifact or a basic. Basic escape
tunnel.
No.
Why? I want nonbasic.
Well, I'm also looking for uh expedition
map.
So, oh, also my favorite card, Thematic
Compass. My third favorite card. And uh
because we are operating mostly at
instant speed, so we can afford to
activate this a lot. And yeah, again,
getting land drops and also eventually
getting a maze of VI is invaluable.
surveyor gift hawk. Basic basic basic
basic. Did I skip or is this cave? Not
yet. Okay, I think I know what I'm
looking for. So, I'm just going to
search for them. The first one is called
expedition
map. Boom. And then
Öza
cave.
Beautiful. All right. And we have 43
nonland cards. We still need more card
draw. We will see what options we have.
We're going to draw cards. Draw a card.
Can't be too ambitious here. Draw a
card. Typeline. Doesn't matter colors.
White or red. Go. think we're going to
need some cards
like desperate
sentinel smothering tithe. We don't
really need the one
ring. We are pretty desperate for card
draw. Maybe maybe it's good war room.
Yes,
absolutely. Now, do we want this card?
We don't really have any synergy with
this card, I don't think. So, no.
Idol. Nope. Vanquisher
whenever cast a creature spell. Nope.
Minus.
Nope. Lauren. It's a blank target and it
draws us
cards. It's not the best, but I think
once again we are in Boros. Beggars
can't be choosers. We don't have enough
creatures to trigger this. I don't think
enough small
creatures. So, no. Seram.
No. Valic awakening. Sure. Card
filtering is good.
Whenever archavist of all whenever
opponent searches can't really rely on
that do we wheel I don't think we
do wheel is pretty wheels are pretty
extreme I'd say I don't think
so reprive no mangara opponent attacks
with two creatures attacking you you
draw a card this is not going to happen
much but whenever opponent casts their
second spell turn draw a card this is
nuts right this will draw a lot of cards
This is close to trouble to trouble in
pairs which I will also play. Should I
keep track of game changers? We have
like three
two
whatever we can adjust later. Throne of
fra no can we afford colect? We
cannot. Theas welcome one or more
creatures you control mana three or less
draw a card. No.
No, no, no, no. Gearhulk. I don't I
don't think this is good cuz your
opponent will just take the damage. It's
like five damage to one
opponent. Unless your play group is
super greedy. I don't think anyone will
let you draw. So, no gear hulk lo
whenever. Oh, it's artifact creatures.
Never mind. Cut a deal. Each opponent
draws a card then you draw a card for
each opponent who drew this way.
this and the secret rendevous from
earlier for this
set. Do we play them? We might just have
to play them cuz the stuff we're doing
is really powerful. We want gas. We want
gas. Excuse me. Secret. No, no, no. This
is not the one from Oh, this is Sorry.
This is not from the new set, but it's
in the new set.
Yeah.
Jaxis, create a token. That's copy of
target creature you
control activate as sorcery.
No cra this one coveted
jewel again. This is like monarch
where yeah I don't think we can defend
it too well. We can defend our life
total well but not our not our
jewel. Draw card draw card draw card
draw card. More
more angel. Yeah.
Zologist.
No, I think this is it for now. Right.
This one smuggler share is not not that
amazing. Yeah, I think this is it for
now. We have 54. We are pretty close to
completing the deck. Of course, we need
some removals and board wipes, right? We
need everyone. Everyone needs that.
So,
uh, I'll
just Yeah, I'll just do it
manually. Chaos
warp
path. Do we play
paths? Exile source flasher. Boros. Do
we defer
protection? We're going all in. We are
We are going bracket four with this.
Uh, it's the best removal
path. I still think it's Yeah, I think
still think path and swords are worth
it. That was a bad idea. That was not a
good idea. Path two. Sorry. Path to
exile. Don't be
lazy.
Really? Are you seriously? No way. This
is No way this is
true. I path to E.
Oh my
gosh. There you go. Thank you. Swears to
shares. I swear. Okay, good. Generous
gift. Maybe we want some slow blink just
to protect our board. I was just
thinking maybe what's that card called?
Erin
interlude. Yeah, because the only our
only weakness here is board wipe, right?
We are pretty protected from most spot
rules, but fast blink you you don't
Yeah, you don't dodge word wipes. So,
what's the other one called? Ghost Ghost
way, I think. Ghost
way. Okay, let's play two of these.
Then board wipes. What are the best
board
wipes?
Farewell. Farewell is a game changer,
but we're going deep. And also, I think
the best one next to farewell is the one
the instant speed one
called
called with escalate. Can't remember,
but we'll find it. Escalade. Yeah, we're
just building this deck.
Escalate.
Escalate. Oops. It is not escalate. It's
spree.
Sorry. Pipeline
instant. Destroy text spree and
destroy. That should give us the
card
destroy. Final final showdown. Yes, it's
called
F. And what are there any creature board
wipes
like? Destroy all. I'm going to give it
a
try. Destroy
all because if there is This is
nuts. Oh. Oh, never
mind. It's an org. There's one that's
similar
color. Give me the right colors and
hitch
work awakening. There you go. But this
one does not work with blink. So there
you go. Some blast angel. Yes. This is
sweet. I think that's it.
Magnus does not work with blink. It
works with slow blink. So
no minen doesn't
work but sun blast is sweet. Okay. Very
happy about finding sunlast.
Sunblast. Just last minute checking is
there any other synergy. We're at 64
cards. So we'll have room for maybe one
or two more
cards. Treasure. Treasure synergy. No.
Lifel link gain life
synergy. We We'll do a quick check.
Whenever you gain
life, we can gain life pretty
consistently with today. We gain
life. Oh, wall of well of lost dreams.
Is that worth
playing? Might be. Not this. Not this.
Not
this. Whenever you gain life, whenever
you gain life, well of lost
dreams. So you blink something on your
main face, you attack, you pay a lot of
mana
to it's really mana intensive, but late
game might just get you back into the
game. It's Is it better than Mind's Eye?
Is it better than Mind's eye? I think
it's better and there's some synergy. So
I'm going
to We'll have to test this one. I'll
have to test. But I think that's it for
life. G King Saturday. Oh, no. G of
hope.
Gain draw or card. Draw a card whenever
you gain life. It's not good enough.
Um,
yeah. Exampler of
light. Whenever you gain life, but no,
it's too slow, I think, because we're
not we're not even guaranteed one life a
turn.
Whenever you can life put that many
counters on, it's decent. Is that was
2T?
No. Let me double check. Dawn of hope.
What is What's the other
ability? H create a one one white
soldier
creature. It's like a mana
sync. It's like a mana sync.
But to use it, you have to basically
sacrifice it. Attack and then pay two. I
don't think it's good enough. Okay,
last. We probably need more removals.
Like whatever cards we we eventually
find to be not pulling the weight, we
will switch what switch for more
interaction. But for now, we'll just
make sure to think of let's think of are
there any lands that can work with today
aside from homework
path link and haste.
land that work with
today. High market of
course
because some creatures we just want to
kill. Hi
Mark. We are two hours 30 minutes into
the video. I'm holding up. Okay. My
voice is hurting a little bit but like
my voice was hurting and then now it's
not hurting anymore. Not sure this can't
be good but but we are dedicated high
market and uh something something
mine is okay
no advanced
search it's called something mine field
cory corey there you
go lazep quy
uh sack creature
Yeah. What else can we sack a creature
with? I'm going to just search for all
lands that interact with creature. Can't
be too many, right? Can't be too many.
Land creature boros.
Go path. No. No. No. No. Saga sources
for No. Cavern souls.
Sure, we can play some utility lens,
but do we play maze of
if is that good? It's
not access tunnel. Nope. Draw a
card. Make a token. We do want some mana
things just because we are playing with
a lot of mana open, right? because we
plot a creature down and then we hold
mana and sometimes often times we only
need one creature on the field to to
control the game. We need one creature
like for
examp mana and play
reactively. Speaking of playing
reactively, do we have enough ways to
finish the
game? Maybe we need another maybe
another finisher or something. This
molten primordial is okay, but okay,
we'll look at lens first. Oh, this is a
great card. Yeah, this is
excellent. You can blink it. Oh, your
attack.
Nope. Minus of Moria Manink. Sure. Yeah,
we're not going to do Oh, tail talon
gates. You know what? This goes into an
earlier deck. So, it goes into what's
his name?
The landfall the the the the amulet blow
commander minstrol. Yes, because you can
keep using it, reusing it over and over.
Yeah.
Okay. Sh. Yeah. Protection spell. It's
always
good. Haven arcane. Do we want plus two
individual ones? Nope. Do we want to
make tokens? Yes, we
do.
Okay.
Mutault.
No, I think that's it for
lands. Think that's
it. Okay. And now we need wind
condition. What's a Boros wind
condition? I guess
insurrection. And there's synergy with
it. So I guess we play insurrection.
[Music]
spreading
insurrection. No. And also just one
more. What's that one that double strike
and goes everything? That card is good,
too. We're just messing with combat
here. Double strike go spectacular
showdown. Yes. Yeah. Now we are at 74
cards, but it's mostly lands that we're
missing yet. This deck is again, I'm
really excited for this. I might
actually build this, but we have to move
on to the next legendary. We are two
hours and 36 minutes in. Okay, Cloud of
Darkness. Oh, first of all, we will move
Sedane. Sedane.
What a pleasant surprise. Cloud of
Darkness. So, this is our main
character, Cloud, but dark
and different gender. Alternate
universe. Is this like a Venom kind of
thing? Venom and
Spider-Man? I don't
know. We are the clout. Okay.
Actually, this is this has nothing to do
with cloud. I'm starting to think, but I
like the first theory better. We are the
cloud of darkness, bringer of wrath, and
destroyer of light. Destroyer of
light. Yeah, this I'm just putting the
puzzles together, the puzzle pieces
together. Uh, let's see what Cloud of
Dark. This is a cool card with a cool
flavor text. It better be good. Flying
33, five mana.
Avatar Particle Beam. When Cloud of
Darkness enters target creature and
opponent controls gets minus X. This is
not looking good. We're
access five mana. We are killing a
creature. That's
it. That's
it. That's all we're
doing. So quite a drop off after
Zedane. Maybe I can think of something
like I did with Zedane. But are we
playing a cloud blink deck? We are
not. When you see a commander like this
that doesn't do
much, the safest bet is just to make a
kind of a deck like imagine this. What
kind of deck would this be in the 99? It
wouldn't it wouldn't make the cut, but
if it has to go in, it goes into
something like a Marram deck, like a
graveyard creature recursion deck,
right? So, this is I'm guessing what
we're going to
build. And that's super easy, super
fast. I think we have to speed up a
little bit just because I think we've
got like 30 more legends to
go.
Um, text
[Applause]
creature
and play the best
creatures. There's one mechanic that
cares about how many permanents there
are in your in your graveyard. It's not
descent. It's the one from the new
Ramnikica block. I'll see if I can
remember it, but probably not. So, yeah,
I just play all the the Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Go, go, go, go. Yes. Sacrifice
roaming throne. Not paper. Probably not.
Uh, sure. Yeah. We're playing the
Golgarity creature, great red deck,
birthing pod, all that sage, grey
merchant. Sure.
Sure. This is super generic.
We'll just take a quick look to see if
there we can find some kind of unique
synergy that is not just a generic
graveyard deck. But I can't remember the
name. Uh can I remember a card? I can
remember a card that is a spider. It's
green. It is seven
mana. I should narrow it down.
Spider that says that says
graveyard. And it is seven mana. It is
uh
seven. There you go. Hat undergrowth.
Okay. Now we search for
undergrowth. Don't think we need color.
Set the color here because it's a
Golgari
mechanic. Undergrowth. When you cast
spell reveal atomic card where access
the number of creature cards in your
graveyard. put a green permanent with
card converted mana
cost when you it's it's not even when
you when you when ETBs it's just not
good. This one is good. Yeah, this one
is fine. So I call it and creates
tokens. So we will you know just to make
the make this feel like a cloud deck we
need to make have some self mill have
some digging dredging or something like
that and have some synergy. Lotless
giant when it enters deals one damage
target opponent for each creature card.
So when it enters it will deal like five
seven. No, not really. Moulder
Hulk. This is not good. Moselium
Secrets. This is not good but we'll play
it
for for the
theme. That's it. That's all. Yep. So we
will move on. This is our deck.
Like I I this is what we do if you
really really have to build a character
just because it's your favorite. But
generally we won't have to do this. Most
people won't have to suffer through
this. So cloud o cloud dark cloud
dark. Next up xdef this better be good.
We have transform. Okay we won't look
just yet. When X deck X death enters,
you gain three
life. This seems like why does he gain
life? It's like a I guess plant-based
person with an armor. No, this these are
not plants. These are these like dark
energy. This guy probably his armor
probably speaks to him. He's not even
bothered by it. He just talks to his
armor.
And when what does he say? Maha. Okay.
Maha. witness what befalls those who
stand against me. I almost read it. Who
stands against us? Then that would make
sense.
But y let's see the flip
side. All memories, dimensions,
existence, all that is shall be returned
to
nothing. Look at this transformation
though. He turns into like everything.
It's like horde of notions kind of bunch
of beasts. So, so this armor is
containing his power. So, he's actually
a he's actually friendly. He's trying
not to unleash the power, but then no,
he's a dick because witness what befalls
those who Yeah. Yeah. And then Okay. So,
he's kind of
just I don't
know kind of going lowkey. And at the
beginning of your end step, if there are
six more permanence, is it permanence in
graveyard?
again. It
is the backside better be good. It's
just a big dude, isn't it? It is. Which
is fine because this is different than
cloud. This is different than cloud
because we we want to build around the
commander more,
which we want to self mill. We want to
get things into graveyard quickly so
that he will enter, flip, and beat
people down.
For this to be two shot, sorry, two
shot, we need at least 11 power. So, we
need eight permanency in graveyard. So,
we need to do it really aggressively.
And when we judge aggressively, there
are things we can do to to use the
graveyard. Again, the payoff is not
quite good enough, but we are building
around this.
So, I mean, you can also build this just
like cloud like with a control deck
where this is the finisher. This is
fine, but we want something a little bit
different. So, we're searching for
basically
into
graveyard. We're putting things into
graveyard. Uh,
anything
go
crank.
Whenever Conrad, whenever another
creature dies, we're This is good
because we're milling ourselves a lot.
Void Walker. No in probably good. It's
because yeah, bury alive. We are working
with the graveyard a
lot. Um, six. Is six good? Six is good
cuz we can, our graveyard is like our
hand, right? But we want, again, we want
to start with mill cards, but I guess
our search is a bit too broad. We'll see
what we kind like griely salvage. This
is the kind of card we want. Rest into
your graveyard.
Uh uh Marin Agent. Yeah. Sad wayfinder.
This is the kind of card we
[Music]
want. Perpetual. No. What does this do?
Ren reveal top four. Put all lands into
your
hand. We want something faster. I think
it's too
slow. Is this faster? Mill three cards.
Put a permanent card on. Oh yeah. This
is good enough. Three
mana underground lich. The kind of card
we want. It's five mana, but the it's
payoff is great. This also is the kind
of card we want. Landing of dominaria.
We get all of our lands back because we
when we mill ourselves, we want to use
our graveyard quickly. We don't want to.
It will be gone soon. Yogas
will I guess it's good. It's not amazing
though.
This I mean you're not storming off or
anything. You're just casting cards. So,
it's like a slightly better
regrowth. Yes. Play lands. There you go.
This is the YOLO variant we want. Maybe
board. How do I Okay, maybe board.
Hermit Druid. Yes, Hermit Druid is the
kind of card we want in this
deck. Okay, I think we got the point
across. Oh. Oh, six fingers. That's
cool. Sure.
Okay. So, graveyard. And now we want
some payoffs. Like there's a card that
it's called harness
something. Harness the
eternity. No. Hardness. Harness.
Jeez. Hard. Oh gosh. Harness. Don't even
bother with the
the
harness. Infinity. I'm glad I didn't put
the in there. Exchange your hand and
graveyard. Oh, this is the deck for for
what's it called? Exchange your library
and
graveyard. How do I search for it? No,
not
here. Exchange library
and
No. No.
What's it called? Moral morality
shift. I
think it's the name. It's the name. I
deck. You can tell we are three hours
in. This is a marathon. Ah, this is
why I am smart.
Yeah, you do this and then you kill
someone someone with your commander.
Okay, we have a
deck solid. I like it. Not the worst,
unlike Cloud of
Darkness. His name is
Xaf. Next up, we have Gova.
Gova, Ancient Calamity.
This is an
alien. Yo, she's got all this tech,
these tubes and stuff. This is I don't
see this often in Final Fantasy
art. Let's see. What is she up to?
Alien. She's probably pissed. Like, she
probably cuz ancient calamity, right?
So, she maybe created the world with
technology and then the people decided
to be like people decided to pick up
magic. She's like,
"Why? This is not what's supposed to
happen." And then she comes back for
vengeance. And then she's she controls a
bunch of things. I guess mutants based
on the
text. Yeah. It looks like a cool
character. Final Fantasy 17. No, no,
seven. Sorry. Oh, it's in Final Fantasy
7. So, I will see her if I keep
playing. Okay, that's tempting. All
right. At the beginning of your combat,
put a counter, a number of counters
equal to power on up to one target
creature. That creature becomes a
mutant. Whenever mutant you control dice
during your turn, you draw a card equals
to power.
Okay. So, we have to manipulate
power. But do we do we want to be
placing counters onto
Genova? because we have to place
counters onto Gova and then play a
creature that cares about counters and
then put the and then put counters onto
that creature and then sack
it. Now what do we do with the
cards? So seems a bit convol if we just
play large creatures, right? It's a lot
easier. We will see how many counters
matters creatures there are in Golgari.
If there's a bunch of good ones, we'll
do it. If
not, we will see. We will see.
Okay. So, counters matter and power
[Music]
matter.
So,
equal
to power then it has to be a creature.
Is this wording right? Equal to power. I
think
so. That's a good one. We'll place it
here for
now. Old stick. No, it's not good. Lord
of Extinction is good. Doesn't care
about power. I mean, doesn't care about
his own power, though.
Michael Tyrant when for each time you
descend. Oh, this goes into my other
deck. Goes into Exodath
X. Cool, cool,
cool.
Sling. Oh, I I'll just search for Gary.
Sorry. Next time I won't do this. I
promise.
Power, power, power. Add mana equal to
power. Drain equal to
power. This one is good except it drains
your opponent. We don't want that.
Drinks I mean drains target opponent.
Not all
opponents. Power. This we do want. Sack
equal to
power. Golding hydra. Sweet. Sweet.
Oh, we want Lumra in
uh we want Lumra in
Acadef. Got to bring those lands back.
But okay, green
sleeves. Nope. Nope. Nope. Nope. Nope.
Wait.
Power enters or attacks. So you pump it.
I'm not sure we have enough payoff for
power. This is a payoff. That's
good. Guff triplets is a decent payoff.
I'd
say yeah,
because it's pretty convoluted. It's
pretty
convoluted. Farewell gold. We can play a
bunch of counters onto it. That's
good. It's fine. How many counters
realistically can we put? How big can we
make our commander
realistically? Not that big,
right? Okay, we'll skip this for now.
But if we can we have enough ways to
make our commander huge, then we'll
consider
[Music]
it. This is not
bad.
immigrant body
launderer. It's okay. It's not great.
So, yeah, the payoff for equal for equal
to power is not there's not a lot. I'll
try with counters
uh for each counter.
Twitch doll
counter.
I don't see anything. Oh, blood tracker.
Okay, blood tracker is
good, but it's like we're drawing
already. What are we going to do with
all the card
draw? Wait, these are in the wrong deck.
Sorry.
So, Oh, I know. I know. we play pump
spells because the spells that place
counter are terribly
inefficient. But if we play pump spells,
pump spells are inefficient. I mean, the
ones that place counters are inefficient
in terms of mana, but pump spells are
bad for in terms of value, card
advantage. But we don't care because we
Yeah, because we we get that card
advantage
back. I like that. I like this idea.
Okay, we're doing it. Instant
sorcery. Green mostly. Oh, green. Black
has some. Black has some. So, we're
going to do
plus target
plus. This can be fun. Um, never
mind. Why? What did I do? Oh, instant
and sorcery. Ha. Ha.
And we want some protection for our
commander because our commander is going
to smack people. It's going to get
big. Um, tie bar stand.
Yes. GS gift. Sure.
Thank battle. Revitalizing pass. Sure.
Why are we getting I want pump spells.
Why are we getting protection spells?
Fame death. No.
To be fair, this is a pump and also
brings our creature
back. We'll place we'll play these
later. For now, we want just straight up
pump like this over
protect. We want bigger pump though. We
want we want to go greedier. So, we're
playing pump and protection.
Sorry, I was putting blue blossoming
defense. Uh, thanks of Colonia. Then
double the
counter. But my commander doesn't have
counters on it, so maybe
not. Now this is good. This is good.
Assyrier's
thirst. Is this good? Or does he
confluence? Let's see.
equal to Genova's power up to one target
creature.
[Music]
Uh
no, invigorate is good. Adraic
confluence is not not amazing. I
think vines is good. We want instance.
Berserk. Ruinous intrusion is good. I
think giant grove. Sure, it's good.
Yeah. So then
we pump our commander to pump the other
creatures. This way when we draw a bunch
of cards, we can voltron with our
commander or we just kill people with
our
creatures. So then we play something
like big. We play big creatures that can
kill
people. Ink puff
nexus. This kills
people. And also we want something like
overwhelming stamp just because makes
them
huge.
Overwhelming
stampede. And
next is
What's it called? Psychics.
Yes. Sacrifice a
creature. I don't want instant
sorceries. No. No. Go Gary.
Go
a
Yeah, we do. We do want mana.
Yes. Fant tower.
Yes. Mercer here. I don't like this card
too much just because it sacks. Sure.
But the doesn't do that much and you
need to play a creature. You need to
play Mercer
here. We'll see if there are better
ones. Fatar is good. Void walker is
good. Void Walker is good because he
sacks
himself, is
it? There's no synergy with the rest of
the deck though. High market dementia
alter dementia. We don't need to mill
right. Carryan feeder grave pack
playcfter children. Where's uh crater?
Uh do we need to draw that many cards?
I guess we do just because like as a
backup to our commander there. This the
kind of cycle that we want instead of
asser Yagmoth. Yes. Although we don't
really need more card draw, but we can
blur for
eight. Okay. This is our
deck. I think it's solid. I think it's
solid. The winning the game is a bit
iffy. Like how are we going to win?
We're going to play a bunch of pump
spells in Voltron or kill people with
just kill people with card
advantage and big dumb
things. Yeah, I think it's
fine. Let's uh add one more. The the the
goat something something
ibex ibex ibex
ibex pathbreaker. Yes. There you
go.
Next. What is this? This
is Oh, this one melt is melted into by
the two I think two monocolor
legendaries. So, we will save this for
later when we go to monocolored. Okay.
Shanto, tactician magician. This seems
like the brat that nobody wants to deal
with, but you have to because it's the
main
quest. Okay. Yeah. And what do they
Okay. Oh ho ho. Of course works. It's
like ma maha. Oh ho ho. Yeah. Clever. I
might be the harshest mistress in all of
Venadel, but I may yet forgive you if
you my feet. You're like, come on. Come
on. It's like the character is probably
not bad, not evil, but just
annoying. Whenever you cast a
non-creature spell, Shanto gets plus X
plus zero until the end of turn. We're X
is the amount of mana spent to cast the
spell. X is four
more. I hate
it cuz what are you going to do,
Voltron? So, you're paying cuz you can't
even cheat. You can't even cheat this.
It doesn't look at the CMC. Looks like
the It looks at
the mana
spent. Yeah. So there's you have to
spend 10 mana a turn, seven mana a turn
just to just to get it to work to get it
to attack for
something. And
then and then what does it
do? Yeah, I don't think Voltron is going
to
work. The second ability is still not
good, but I think we're going to have to
build around it. Wait one second. We're
moving this
This deck is What's her name
again? Gova.
Yes,
Shanto. Why? Why didn't you
move? There you go,
Shanto. Yeah. No, I I I can't think of
anything to do with this. We just have
to do like is it good stuff deck with
power four with X is four or more and we
can't even we can't even play cost
reducers. It does say none creature
spell,
but yeah.
No, hopefully this is the one crap
uncommon that we have to deal with.
But we are dealing with it
now. Not
creature
CMC
4 for maximum value. We want to
minimize. We want to play four
basically.
Uh four.
the one
ring. Uh, sure. Stuff like big score can
be
good. Big score is just a great card. I
mean, along with the other one, I forgot
the name. Yeah,
Etherize. So, we're just playing, what
are we doing here? We're playing a four
mana spell every turn.
just
to just to control the game, I
guess.
And I guess Shanto works well with cards
like like what's it called? Chundraas
invasion. Tundra's ignition,
sorry. Any other card like that? I don't
think so. Tous Ignition. Well, I mean,
there are there are a few more cards
similar. There's one on the new set.
Something
him. Hopefully it will get us there. How
many he magic? A few apparently. There
we go.
Nibbleheim. But this one is only four
damage, but it could could be seven.
Okay. And do we have anything that
synergizes with four mana spells
specifically?
four
mana. Oh, there's a ether vial for
spells, isn't there? Bring in a jar,
it's
called. It's terrible,
probably, but because we want to have a
little bit of theme for a charge
counter, we have to
do cast an instant sorcery converted
mana cost. So, we need to charge it
once, twice, thrice, and then we get a
free spell kind
of. We'll play it just
because we are desperate for some kind
of
identity. And look
for Whoops,
sorry. Four mana.
Not looking
good. Four mana. Four mana. Four
mana. Four
mana. No. Is this good?
Oh,
four.
Oh, this is a mechanic of the
set. I guess we're playing them. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Sure. We'll read this
later, but I mean, has to be good,
right? Has to be good. Wait, this is
also at least four mana. Create a
treasure token
series.
Seriously, terrible. And this
selfie so
bad. Uh, this one, four mana, tap
creature.
Eight mana. Put eight counters on it.
We're not going to get to eight mana,
but four
mana.
Fine. I want a different
deck.
Okay.
Shanto, get out of
here. Now we are into the four mana.
Yeah, the four mana tribals. Tella,
great sage. Whenever you cast an
uncreious spell, create. See, at least
this is good, right? If four or more
mana spent, draw two. Okay, this is
good. It's just strictly better. And
this one, we don't have to do four mana
tribal cuz if eight or more mana was
spent to cast this spell, sacrifice ta
if eight mana or more
mana deals that much damage to each
opponent. Okay, how are we doing this?
Um, so I think it's just a spell slinger
deck and then late game we can win. We
can win with Tela. And how we win is we
store mana and late like we control the
game, store mana, and late game we cast
one massive spell like 15 mana, 20 mana
spell, and then your opponent can't even
respond to like because the triggers on
the
stack. I think this
works. Yeah, we will play generic
spells. Oh, I know. Because you're
create you're creating tokens. So
something like, you know, Ash's altar,
the
altars. Might regret this again. I'm not
Am I regretting it?
Almost. Yep. Every time I'm lazy.
Actually, this time it's okay. This time
is
okay. We got the two altars. And
sacrifice creature get
mana. Uh,
creature creature
mana. See if we can do
that. Yeah. Control the board, create a
bunch of tokens, and then
eventually eventually go nuts
with hopefully convert them into
mana and go nuts with Ta.
Tella creature mana. Creature mana.
Creature mana.
Doesn't seem like we have anything
here. Are these artifact tokens? They're
colorless tokens.
Nope. Doesn't seem like we have too many
other
options. So, we are going to play spells
that create treasures probably.
probably. Yes. Okay, we're going
treasures.
Treasure. That's all. Yeah. Go nuts.
Vic score. Oh, of course. Storm fl
artist. Sure. Are we playing? Are we
playing a lot of small spells? We are.
Actually, we might not be doing
that. Might not be doing that. We'll
see. We'll see because this is not worth
it unless we're playing a decent amount
of small spells. Do we want to? No. This
is way more unexpected windfall. Gold
spend dragon. Probably play it just
because Oh, wait. Tell us noncreature
spell. Do we play the
dragon? Yeah. Kind of win more. I'd say
sacrifice treasure vault. Absolutely.
This the kind of stuff that stores help
us store
treasure. Uh sworn. Yeah. Mines.
Yes. Seize the spoils. Three mana. No.
No. Prismari
command. No.
Brass's bounty is almost eight mana sub
mana but I think it's still
decent
sorcery like once you do it your
opponents know what you're going to do
right so it's too on the nose and you
have to tap out for it usually bhord
draosaur oh this is good yeah you can
just attack people with your tokens and
get a bunch of treasures
How many can we get? We one, two, three,
four extra combat and then two star
target
opponent. Yeah, but it doesn't really
fit our theme, but you can draw two
cards if you do
it. It's fine. I think it's
fine. Ring of
Riches.
Yeah. Fight for benitry. Hit the
motherload. This cover card is six.
No, Coronto vault is good because we are
not a treasure deck. So, I don't think
we are going to play too many. We just
want to play the best ones that make
treasure and then we move on to other
ways to make
mana. Yeah, this is the one I was
waiting for. Anything else? I think
we're good for now. And then now we want
big mana cards like
manager card is nuts in
commander manager and then we are just
playing because in this case it's worth
it to play four mana spells but ideally
you want them to be instance because you
don't want to tap
out. So once again we search for some
four mana spells. Do we have them here?
We
don't cost stat value
four non
creature.
Nice cor in ether flux. No ether eyes.
Yes. Yes. The same factor
fiction. Sure, it's decent. Distant
melody is good
because you get to draw a lot of cards
with the heroes. Is your commander a
hero? He is not. He's a human wizard.
This guy seems like the kind of wizard
that probably doesn't live for the
entire game because he's too powerful.
Helps you a little bit and then gets
betrayed backstabbed by I don't know
this guy, I guess.
Yeah, it looks super powerful. The great
sage. Yeah, probably lives in the
library. Tries really hard to not burn
it
down. Yeah, that's the that's the trope
I'm
thinking. Tefairy, angels, insight,
distant melody, mindbreak, trap, chain
reaction, layline le I think we want
one.
Yeah. So, right now, good stuff. I don't
think I don't think we need to look at
too much. But the problem here
is the problem here is we don't still
don't have enough things to build
towards the late game. But because we
are drawing cards, drawing a lot of
cards
with our commander, I can we can afford
to ramp a fair bit.
So,
yeah. Add
And we can go a bit greedier than with
some of the other decks just because I
mean look at form of alrain or find
animal. It draws you two cards, right?
Why
not? Why not?
Roaming
form seems a bit
windon same thing doesn't work
metamorph
no to lotus
sure
archive
sure okay ving let's put that in okay
although this one to restrict the color,
but it's still pretty good, I think. Is
it man chosen color? Yeah, we just say
for red or
something. Uh, but then that second No,
never mind. I think it's a bit too
limiting. So, yeah. What else can we
add? Oh, we want ways to we want to
waste the wind with our tokens, of
course, because we're making a decent
amount of tokens. Not a ton. We're not
really storming off with a small spells.
Although we do have to put in some
smaller spells for interaction and
stuff. So we
are what's the what are some cards that
can pump tokens? Not sure.
Creatures get
plus enter
type doesn't matter.
[Music]
Going
no creature. Oh, I was
thinking there are some overrun effects
here. There are some. So maybe I will
limit it to instance and sorceries.
[Music]
sorcery or sorcery.
Sorry. There you go. Hazel Rage. Except
we wait does buyback count towards the
mana cost mana you spend. I think it
does.
So if you just buy back, you draw two
cards, make a
token. You can do it twice a turn maybe,
but it's not in the pump. I don't think
this is what I'm looking for. Exile
target instance sorcery creatures
control get plus X plus O.
Yeah. Yeah, that's the kind of card.
Pyatic charge discard your hand. Draw
four cards for
recurs. It's
decent. Can plot it for later. It's
decent. But plot doesn't synergize with
our commander
though.
Fine. And also we need big spells for
ending the game
with. So we need X. No. Oh X.
Oh, it doesn't
work. Meta cost has X. Does that
work?
Nope. Where X
is? Uh, no. How
about ah, how do we search for X? I
don't know. How about criteria? X
spell. Okay, we'll search it in two
ways. X
cards. I am stuck.
There you go. We did it, boys. We did
it. Pull from
tomorrow. Finale of
Revelation on top
five. This is good. Explosion because
it's also a burn
spell. Now our commander will just
die. Yeah.
Can we bring it back with something? We
cannot. We
cannot. Uh, no.
Okay. Convo doesn't work because it's we
have to pay the mana
unfortunately. Improvise does
work, but these are not winning the
game. These are
just Yeah, I'm not sure we want too many
of these. Think we cut a few. Let me cut
surveillance. What we want is the X
burns though. So X
damage
damage deal X
damage. Yeah, Kraco. Absolutely. Comet
Storm
definitely. Inferno. Yes, I think that's
enough. We have a few
And oh, my favorite red card from my Red
Burn deck. Where is
it? Molten Disaster. Now, this card, if
you kick it and cast it, your
commander's ability goes on the stack,
but your opponent cannot respond to any
of
this, right? So, you're guaranteed
pretty much to get whatever. Let's say
you do this for 10. X is 10. X is 10.
You kick it. You're guaranteed to get 13
damage to your opponent from your
commander and then 10 more damage. 23
damage. So, this is sweet. Yeah. Now
that we have the big X
spells, I think we have a deck. I think
we have a deck. This will need a lot of
tuning. We have to figure out the ratios
and stuff, but play some removals, play
some interaction, maybe some counter
spells, and yeah,
solid. the emperor of
Palamia. Okay. What is his
thing? Uh, it's an emperor. Probably
this guy's boss, but less relevant, less
important in the story, and he's not
happy about it. He wants to be
important. So, yeah, the Lord Master of
Hell. Yeah, he's pissed. All the world
shall fall by my hand.
Cool. At see this is already good. Add
mana. Spend this mana only to cast non
creature spell. So you're guaranteed a
four drop spell on turn three basically.
And then rewards playing four drop
spells. Is the reward good? At least
four mana was spent to cast it. Put a
plus one counter on emperor. If there
are three or more transform, it's not
terrible. It's not
terrible. What is the
backside? Whenever the Lord master of
hell attacks, it deals X damage to his
opponent. This reminded me I need to add
one more card to tell which
is needs is in both this and TA. It is a
land. Can you
guess?
witches
clink. Yeah, it will just gain you all
the life
back goes to
Ta. I will now move Ta. Sorry, not TA.
I'll move. Yes,
[Music]
TA. Why?
category and the clinic also goes
into the lord master the
emperor. Okay, so how is the emperor
different than tala is the question. We
play some four mana spells. No problem.
We got
those. Honestly, we still have them
probably. Oh, we don't.
But aside from
that, guess
counters deals X damage or X number of
creature nonline cards. Okay, so this is
different. We want to be aggressively
dumping things into our graveyard,
right? Where X is number of non-creature
and nonline cards in your graveyard. And
there's a way to do that. Now, we want
it we want to transform him really
quickly, aggressively, and then start
shooting your
opponents. So, how do we transform this
guy quickly? The ramp does
help. Can we just place counters onto
him? Yeah, because it's a lot of spells
we have to cast.
So, plus one
counter. And with red and
blue, probably not much.
Although we can proliferate. That's an
option. Spark double. That's one way to
do
it. Uh if you spend this mana to cast
your commander, it enters. Yeah, Opalis
is a good card for this
deck. Can replace target legendary
creature gets a counter. I think it's Is
it worth it? I mean, with this mana, we
can just cast we just cast another four
mana spell, right? It's like this cost
three mana. So, maybe not. Except is
this a god? If there's some god synergy
here, it is
not.
Okay. Door of destinies metallic mimic
creatures counter slip out the back.
This is protection and counter. This is
good.
Essence Flux it. This one removes the
counters though, so it's less
good. Um, crime novelist not
good. Choose target commander of that
interest.
Yeah, I guess lens lands help, but aside
from that, there's not too much.
Um, yeah, we don't have too
much. So then what do we do? We have to
find some proliferate
cards.
Proliferate.
Okay. Hopefully four mana. Carbastian.
Again, we're not paying this mana for
free. It's not worth it. Flux channeler
on the other hand is perfect because it
helps us get two counters per
spell. Yeah, Tazarus Gambit. We can
Yeah, we can pay four mana, pay the full
mana cost. We will do
that. Inexorable tide is probably not as
it could. We can pump our
commander. Yeah, but it's too expensive
and it's too slow. Look at the top three
cards. Put them into your hand. But one
of the Oh, that's so good. Okay. Tech
cuall. Does this do anything?
Proliferate twice.
No. Repulse of potential. This protects
our commander and proliferates. Yeah,
just what we need. Dream tie. Well, this
proliferates like
crazy. It's also a big
body. I think it's fine. I think it's
fine. It's three mana though.
I guess we can still benefit from flip
even after flipping. Not as much but not
as
much. Turn two commander turn three. No,
it doesn't doesn't work so well with the
curve. Contentious planer draw a
card. Then the question is why don't we
just like if it's just for the
periphery, why don't we just play uh a
four mana spell, right? So, let's not do
that just yet. Around
Storm. Okay. I think we don't we can't
really depend too much on place
encounters. So, some four mana spells.
Now, does this deck play different four
mana spells than these two decks? Let's
see. On turn three, we play this. Turn
four, we will
play I think we'll play very controlly,
very responsive. Yes. Like the moment we
untap with this, we are defending our
commander because the commander provides
us with a win
condition. And it's not a bad
one. We'll see. But yeah, we so we are
playing all the counter spells at four
mana. Uh so mana not equals to four.
Uh we will consider four and fives. Four
uh greater than four, three, a mana
value less than
six. Sure. Let's do four and fives for
now to see because there are some good
fives and we don't want we just want
instance. I'm pretty sure. Yeah, we just
want instance cards with
flash. We will look at
both force of world doesn't trigger.
Yes, this is the kind of card
again. When we don't end up casting a
counter spell, we play it and it's so we
don't waste the mana and it's and we get
a store we get a store of mana which is
excellent. So factor fiction.
Sure. Bolt
bend. We we don't have the option to pay
the full mana cost if our commander gets
big. So no rewind. Excellent.
Confluence. Yes. Evacuation. No. Virtue.
No. Cryptic command. Sure. Sure. Why
not? Desynchronization. Sure. C double
this. This is great because you can
choose to copy or counter or both,
right? Maybe both. Spell.
Excellent. Rtorm. Not excellent. Behold.
Yes. We're never going to forell it, but
even just for four mana, this is a
pretty good card. Access denied. Sure. I
mean, Archcomander is a man rock, so
that helps a lot. Maybe we don't even
play Manor Rock in this deck. Just the
entire deck is four mana spells and
eventually two four mana spells a turn.
So then, okay. So now we have this and
once he untaps, we are going
to play protection spells. We have a few
here, but not enough protection spells.
I guess these cards are protection. The
counter spells are protection spells.
But we're going to play pump
spells. Do we have efficient pump
spells?
No, we don't play. We play mill. We play
self mill. That's what we're doing.
Yeah. Yeah. It doesn't care about the
power.
Sorry. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Self
mill first card to finish the game.
Traumatize and
then target player male.
[Applause]
Merlock Queen.
No.
No. We need to move for a lot. Amass
orex cards were X's amass or no psychic
spiral. No. No. No. Really? Where's I
guess all the mill is for opponents
because traumatized is too broken. So we
are not self-milling. We
are are
we wheeling? No, I don't think we
wheel we we have to uh how do we do
it into the graveyard
cards? So we want how many let's say how
many we want in our graveyard.
want
10. Another way to do it is just play
the control game and pressure with our
commander. But that's a bit slow. I
think like your opponents will
eventually catch up to you. So, I do
think we want some more aggressive
milling
cards, maybe more
loot. Okay, let's try this into the
graveyard.
Uh, any type. Any
type I guess non creature
ideally. Okay, let's take out
creature. I mean, there could be some
good male creatures out
there. Can I think of any? I
cannot. Into the graveyard.
Uh why? Oh, sorry. We've got the mana
cost and the creature restriction wrong.
So, Z
go. See how well we can do here. This
will determine if our deck is a meme or
actually the dream factory fiction.
Okay, we play lots of Yeah. draw spells
that dump into the
graveyard.
But intuition intuition, it's not great.
Commit echo. Nope. Tongue twister.
Fraying
sanity. Search for at camp.
No, it's not the kind of card we need to
go fast. Yeah, I think we need to go
faster otherwise this video will be five
hours. It will be five hours actually.
So, uh, and that with that actually five
hours for the multicolored I I have I'm
going to have to take a break after
multicolored, but I will do monocolor in
a few days. Well, yeah, even just
multiolor is a five hour video easily.
So, good times. Good times. If you're
still here, honestly, if you're still
here, thank you. Thank you. You're
probably asleep, but thank
you. hear this in your dreams. I love
you.
Okay. Yeah. Stuff like strategic
planning is
decent. Wait, does this say none? Our
commander says non creature nonland.
Yeah.
Let's see. Epiphany at the Drown Yard.
No,
wait. It's
okay. Psychop factory
fiction. I was hoping for more cards
like strategic planning, but I don't I'm
starting to think that we don't have it.
So, it looks like we just have to play a
game
of controlling everything.
controlling
everything. At least four mana was spent
to cast a polifous encounter if that's
three. Yeah, the synergy here isn't
great
anymore. But you can traumatize to win
on the spot. But aside from
that, where x number n in your
graveyard
self. Oh, I forgot something. I forgot
to when I did the mail, I didn't search
for all the mail cards. Each. No, not
each. Just mail. Just mail. And see what
we
get.
Okay. All tarp dimensia doesn't do much
here. Me whenever opponent takes micro
orb. Yes, this is the kind of milk card
we want.
Thought scour. Absolutely. Yes.
Yes.
Yes. Age player male fractured.
No. Yeah. This drowned in the dreams.
This is the kind of card you
want. Uh
Bruvac.
No. No. Roundre. Nope. Frame. You can
enchant yourself, but we don't have that
many mill
cards. Okay, I think this is fine. We
try to push through damage. We try to
mill to accelerate it. And if we don't,
we can still keep up in the late game.
In the late game, our gets our our
commander does get better as long as we
don't get greater or hate it, you know,
as the game goes. So, decent. Next up,
VV or a tier. I have an entire video
about this, so I'm not going to go deep,
but basically we're playing pump
spells.
[Music]
We Yes. Draw uh plus plus something,
right? We want
red
and low
cost less than
three. How about four? And then instant
or
sorcery because that triggers Vivv's
damage
ability. Does
it? Oh, it's non creature spell. So,
equipments could work too, but for now,
we're doing instance and sorceries
because they pump for
more. For
example,
this this is actually for later on, but
this is excellent for killing people
with Vivv. That's her deck. But first,
we move Select
all the
emperor. Okay, time for
Eevee. Fist of
flame. Siege smash. Sure. Split second.
Titan strength. Crescendo is not plus
three is okay.
Brute force, you know, all these pump
spells. All these pump spells plus two,
but treasure token. Okay, I'll take it.
Monsters rage, even better. Yeah. And
then once we do that, we play big draw
spells because it can make blue mana. So
again, draw X
cards.
Why? What did I do
wrong? Oh, the name.
We smart. Nope. Wrong. Wrong. Wrong.
Ashley is fine. I think we're
fine. We are not
fine. Hello
blue. There you go. So once we pump EV's
power to pretty high, we can make say 10
mana a turn. Then we hope for tomorrow
revelation doesn't matter.
face. Brousan is not that efficient
anymore, but sure, we play it. You know,
all these cards might spring. And then
we have a huge VV. And what we do is we
play evasion spells like slip through
space. Yeah. And your opponent will be
dead really fast. Also some interaction,
you know, counter spells, protection
spells, and offer.
This deck sounds really fun to play. VV
is super expensive now apparently, but
still this the rest of the deck is
cheap. Again, I have a video about this
and building budget decks. So, please
take a
look.
Viv, we are done with is it now we are
on to what is this called? Origin. Yes,
Judge
[Music]
Magister Gaby. This guy probably never
leaves his
armor. Probably showers and sleeps in
the
armor. Never seen a bed that is not made
of
stone. Yeah, this guy is hardcore. Let's
see if the abilities are hardcore
menace. Whenever another creature or
artifact you control dies, put plus one
plus one counter on
judge. It's
terrible. I slew your king. I slew your
country. Do these deeds not demand vent.
So what? So he the character he's like
okay
I killed I I committed crime and I
should be judged. It's like does he
regret what he did? But he doesn't want
to kill himself because closure reasons.
So waiting for the challenger to finish
him. We have some we have a lot of but
then we have menace. So we are avoiding
combat. We have like multiple
personalities at work here. And
meanwhile, the card is garbage. What do
you do whenever a creature artifact you
control dies? Oh, congratulations. You
You get a plus one
[Music]
counter. Try to build around
this.
I Yeah, I guess we can place lots of
sacrifice aristocrats and then finish
with our
commander. Is there a better way? Is
there a better
way? I don't think so.
So
aristocross. Oh, but I want to do
something different. I want to do
something different. It's It can grow to
a decent sight as a threat, but it seems
like Yeah, just a finisher like a like a
crappy finisher in a aristocrat deck. So
creature honestly just search for all
the forats. Just search for all the
permanence that are less than non-land
permanence that are less than three
mana, less than four mana, let's say.
And then oh,
also not land, not
instant, not
sorcery, not
sorcery. Wait, where? Ah, there it is.
Okay.
Boom. And then play the best ones in
orov. It's like that's the one thing or
does in
orov. Okay. Let's also add Oh, the
artifacts might be useful actually like
skull clap, right?
So, play them all.
Play them all. Jump. Jump. Play them
all. Yay. Yay. Not this one.
Yay.
Sure. We do want indestructible because
when someone board wipes or when we do,
the commander stays and it's
huge. So that's a thing, you know, have
some
synergy. Play. Sure. This is good. Yeah.
Don't think there I don't think you'll
be all familiar with
aristocrats judge. That's judge
magister. Select
all. Interesting personality but boring
card.
Judge. Next. Roffus Shinra. Let's hope
this is good. It's a guy with a
dog. Like he's he acts all cool and
powerful and then he lets the dog do the
fighting. He's only a two four. Yeah.
But his name is Shinra. Shinra is a
special name. I know that. I control the
world. I'll control. Okay. So he already
controls the world. It takes too much to
do like my old. So yeah, the basically
the the prince the new ruler except he
still has to fight with his dog for some
reason.
Can't just send his mechs or
mercenaries. Whenever Rufus Shinra
attacks, if you don't control a creature
named Darkstar, create Dark Star a
legendary. Oh gosh, this is even worse
maybe. Do we play
aggro? Like when So like when when I
don't know what to do, I go for aggro. I
mean, it's decently aggressive, right?
Two for No, it's
not. Do you play aristocrats? Because he
makes a count. He makes a token every
turn. 30 seconds. I'll give it 30
seconds. Named Dark Star. Create dark
star. A legendary plus two plus two or
two two
dog. I think it's better in Aristocrat
just because it's like a crappy bitter
blossom that makes a token every turn
for you to
sack. All right, guess we're back at
Yeah, I'm just doing this for people who
don't watch the video but want to see
the
list. So, you're asking why are you why
are you placing the same ramp artifacts
into five different decks? This is why
cuz people probably won't be watching
the video, the full video at least.
Whoops. Yeah. So, I just just so they
know we are doing we're doing
aristocrats. Let's add a few more.
Anything for synergy?
Nope. All right, let's go to
Squall. This guy is Rufus. Roffus. It's
a goofy name.
Roffus. Squall. C D seed mercenary. This
is like the mirror character of our of
Cloud. He's from Final Fantasy 8. So,
it's like Cloud but black but dark.
Maybe it's got some conflicts, internal
turmoils, internal struggles. It's like,
do I kill people or do I help people or
do I help people by killing people? I'm
guessing this is what he's doing here.
Whenever a creature you control attacks
alone, it gains double
strike. Whenever squall deals combat
damage to a player, return target
permanent card with mana value three.
Okay, this is not bad.
Yeah, again we I don't want to do
Voltron again just because we are this
is a worse Voltron commander than the
Boros ones, but we can
play we can play like recursion because
we're getting two things back a turn as
long as we keep Squall, you know,
protected and unblocked. So yeah, we
can Okay. Okay. So what we're going to
do is we're going to pile things into
the graveyard first.
or play cards that want to
die. The first cards I can think of are
Selfless
Spirit,
Boromir, and there's one more. There's a
legend from from Stricks Haven.
Stricks
Haven. I forgot the
name. Why don't we just play cards that
sacrifice
themselves? Yeah, let's do that.
Sacrifice
[Applause]
themselves.
Sacrifice or sacrifice
others could be decent. Oh, we want CMC
three or less value less than four.
Okay. Let's
[Music]
go. Burnish cart. Why not? White Walker.
Yes. Yeah, we're just getting value. And
we can dump things to things into the
graveyard. We can try, but we cannot
depend on it too much because in mono
black we don't I don't think we have too
many cards for that. Yeah, definitely.
Definitely these ranger
captain. We'll see about this one. We'll
see if we There are enough one drop for
us to
tutor.
Warren, sure. Flashbag.
Sure. Are yara? Maybe not. A cursed.
Yes. Commando.
Yes.
Um. Okay. Now that we have creatures
that sacrifice them, I think we don't
need to put them all. They probably all
can go in, but again, we are. Yes, we
need cards that protect our
commander. Selfless
savior. Sir Ginger. That's not
good. Not
great. Sacrifice a food. Fang. Sacrifice
a creature. Nope.
We need you to sacrifice
yourself. The priest does it. The priest
can bring back. This is like a loop with
squall, right? Yeah. So, the priest is
good. Tasa.
No. Necrotic sliver destroyer. I think
three
mana. It's not too bad. It fits the
deck, I think.
Ruthless sacrifice a creature when you
do. Yeah, that's a good
card. Has to sacrifice another creature,
but it should be fodder. Maybe not.
Should be fers. I good
card. I'm waiting for
uh I'm actually waiting. Okay, this Kami
is good. Yeah, Kami is good.
I'm waiting for this card, benevolent
bodyguard. Like, it's terrible in most
decks, but in this deck, I think it
makes sense because it protects your
commander. And this one, Valentine, can
repeatedly destroy opposing
commanders. Yeah. Is that good? It's
okay. And then, oh, wait. There's one
more here. Werew. What does it do? Word
fox. Nothing. Okay. Then we want
permanents that sacrifice
themselves.
So can we search for permanent? We
cannot. So in not instant, not
sorcery.
Sorcery.
What?
Sorcery. I I'm giving up. I'm not
thinking straight
anymore. Not sorcery. Not instant. Yes.
And low mana. Yes.
Okay.
Oops. Taking a look at lands. Of course.
I think yeah, the lands are fine. Mind
stone is fine. We want Yeah, commander
sphere is fine. And in this deck, I
think we want all the fetches.
all the uncolor
fetches. Yeah, because just getting that
ramp is huge when you have nothing else
to bring
back. Great reverse bottle.
Sure. Fable passage. Okay, you get the
idea. But we want we want to look for
some other cool permanence. Oh, and also
commander beacon and the commander so
that you're never paying commander tax
cutlet.
Sure. Why are we still looking at
creatures?
I don't want a creature. I don't want
creatures.
Creature not
good. Whoops. Sorry. Sort by set. What's
set review? Is that like a limited
review? We will see. Lotus would have
been nice. Map
market
down. We don't want lands. We want
permanence.
Treasure map codeex shredder
etching sacrifice a creature of the
chosen type. No, not great seal. That's
fine. Not good
enough. Cathonian nightmare. Sacrifice a
creature. Return target creature. This
is good. This is good. Yeah, because
we're we're a low cost permanence
deck. Being able to bring bring back two
permanence a turn is just so good. So
good. I don't see many permanence that
are super worth bringing
back. Yes. So I think I think Oh,
solitary confinement is a lock.
Absolutely. You won't never take damage
again.
A spell bomb. Sure. Use it on your
opponents.
Yeah. Oh, oblivion stone. That's
good. In a pinch, we can wipe the board.
Okay. Y 37 cards in also. We need to
look at ways to pile the graveyard. So,
into the
graveyard. Into your
graveyard. And I think in this case we
want yeah we want all
types and we don't want to limit the
amount of cost for
this not this the
CMC. All
right. Nope. Intomb.
Yes. Part of life
100%. A tumor. It's okay. Not the best,
but I'm looking for ways to pile our
graveyard. I'm sure there are some
options
here. Demonic Council.
Nope. Some
backup for a commander. Once you can
play a land, cast a permanent spell with
mana three or less, but if you do, it is
not coming back again. Is that worth
it? Might be worth it. Might be just a
crappy, really crappy backup for a
commander. Okay. Yeah. Exile the top
three cards. Hostile negotiations. Exile
top three cards. Look at the cards in
each pile choice. Yeah. This is the kind
of card we might want to
play. Come back round. Back for seconds.
Back for seconds.
Bargain. Yes.
Warlock
class. Yeah, good. Okay. Yeah, I think I
think Oh, we also
need we have some protection for our
commanders for our commander, but we all
know we need to get through, right? So,
something like this will be
perfect. Whoops.
Silver
shroud
costume. Yeah. And then
myth coat. Get indestructible. Protect
him. Yeah. We have a deck. Every turn.
We're getting two things back with our
commander. Seems reasonable.
We're not really utilizing the double
strike thing because I I don't think
black and white has a lot of damage
trigger cards. I could be wrong,
but this is good. All right, we are
Yeah,
Squ. Hey, we are on to Celestnia,
Garnet, Princess of Alexandria. This is
the one character that does all the wind
uh the waving around.
all the colorful magic, but in the end
it heals for two
HP. Yeah, someday I will be queen, but I
will always be myself. Wow, really edgy.
Lifelink. Whenever Garnet attacks, you
may remove a lower counter from each of
many any number of sagas you control.
Put a plus one counter on Garnet. For
each lower counter, remove this way.
There is no other way to build this. The
plus one counter payoff is not good
enough. But the only thing you can do
here is to make sagas trigger again and
again the same chapter. So the only
thing we're doing here is to play some
enchantments energy enchantress and then
we're playing sagas and we we're I mean
I don't know how many saga options we
have but if we have choices we're going
to play the ones that where you want the
same chapter to trigger over and over
basically
saga. This should be
easy saga. No,
no, it's eight
mana. That's cool. We'll play it cuz we
want I mean the second ability is kind
of kind of nice, right? It's pumping
your commander to to be
massive. The man of Dominaria. Nope.
Exile target permanent.
Yes. Search for a legendary
creature. Sure.
I mean, we got these
creatures. This one is fine. Sure. I
don't think we have too many sakas.
So, we're playing them
all. Uh, draw a card.
No. Additional land. Nope. No. Target
creature gets plus one. Mico. Nope.
Jugan defense. Nope. Okay. Are we How
many do we have? Okay, we have quite a
few. Quite a few.
We won't be looking at all of them. Just
a a few examples of the best options.
Jurassic Park.
Nope. Oh yeah.
No. Doesn't do anything. Weather seed
treaty. Search for a basic land ramp.
Okay,
sure. Battle tokens. Nope. Binding.
Nope. Battle at the
hell. You can keep exiling things. six
mana, but we want to create a
eventually, right? So,
no, you search for a planes put into
your library. Your opponents each draw
two cards. This one, this is fine. Draw
cards. Nope. Target creature
indestructible. Return target creature
from the battlefield.
It's okay because first and second
ability you want to keep
triggering two counters exile permanent
from graveyard gain life
number this one the world spell you want
the last ability so
no the henceman
nope the knight of the doctor destroy
all
creatures
no this will exile your commander follow
the First
civilization more
draw. You can choose to draw or exo
which is
nice. Okay, you get the point. All the
best sagas, all the sagas where you want
to keep repeating the same ability and
eventually how do you get there? How do
you win?
Uh there's a new saga that's a decent
win condition. Well, this one I guess
you play it because it's cool, but
there's a new saga that's like huge.
It's this one. Summon nice of the round.
Yes.
And this one you don't want to you don't
want to remove. So sagas and uh can we
turn sagas into creatures? Of course we
can. All the enchantress stuff like
mix probably a bad
search. Starfield. Starfield of
mix. Starfield.
Yes. How else do you win with
enchantments? And then you play Tetris.
And we call it a day. A boring day, but
it's a
day. All
right. Hopefully, this is again the
boring uncommon of of Celestia, but I'll
be honest, I'm not too confident when it
comes to
Celestnia. Probably one of the most
boring color combinations, I'd say, when
it comes to commander.
Garnet Renoa. Why do these characters
give similar vibes? Are they like just
the same kind of role in different Final
Fantasy games? Final Fantasy 9, Final
Fantasy 8. When Renoa Hartilli, this is
a healer, right? Hartily create a doggo.
Oh no. Whenever Renoa attacks another
target creature gets plus one plus plus
one until the end of turn for each
creature you
control. We are
playing again I guess power matters but
you have to also go wide and play a
bunch of creatures and then when you're
playing a bunch of creatures going wide
you can just crater hoof. What's the
point of Oh, look. My hydra is eight
power. Now I'm going to make eight make
eight
treasures. Yeah. So, I don't think
you you can go wide, but when you go
wide again, this payoff just doesn't do
much. It makes one token what? Plus five
plus five plus eight plus eight. So,
what makes your dog
huge? The dog doesn't even do commander
damage. So, I think we just play a
generic aggro deck. play lots of
creatures and attack. And Renoa is not
bad for for the power it gives, right?
For how much it adds she adds to her
combat phase. So, yep. Let's beat down
with with Celestia. At least we're doing
something different. So,
creature.
Yep. M. Let's not restrict the
cost. Let's just play the best
creatures. Although we might have to
scroll for a bit
because we're starting with all these
all these game changers which we are not
going to
play. Avenger. Why not? Sun Titan. Sure.
Sure. Sure. Let's play these because
they're actually really good. But we
want some more aggressive token. No, no,
no. Musa is Toki good. Toki is
okay. Is okay because we want some early
drops that are
aggressive. Critter. Why not? Yeah, this
is the kind of stuff. Champion of
Lamphalt is actually excellent synergy.
Excellent
synergy. Forgotten ancient. Does that
synergize with our commander? Nope, does
not. Evolution Sage
Vampire Ku. Why is this card so high?
Your opponents can't cast spells.
Whenever one or control with power
greater than his base power, draw a
card.
It synergizes with our commander but not
with the
deck. It was nice to have
uh yeah I don't think it's aggressive
enough. Gas is fine. Is it where X is
the total power of creatures you
control? No, I don't think it's it will
come down reliably. Yes, Adeline. This
is the kind of card we want. And I guess
we're in Simic if we're playing aggro.
We do want a little bit of do we want a
little bit of hate
bears? I say no for now, but if you
want, you can definitely do that. Faber
is that is a big card. No, it's just a
two
two. This card is good. Can get pretty
big. But yeah, see Sim, not Simic.
Celestnia, we don't even have premium
aggro cards. We can't even beat that
even though we are the creature
color. Goraw is one of them. Goraw is
sick. Except it's fine. It's a good
card. Rishkar
Boromir. Yes. Again, Ranger to search
for Sarah
ascendant. And aside from that, we
are Can we play some cards that
synergize with the commander that care
about the power? Oh, yeah. Pathbreaker
Apex, of course. Pathbreaker.
I think there's more. We can find some
just have again have some
energy. Uh it will say equal to the
power
equal to the power
of
okay. Yes. Has to be
creature. Oops.
No. Lumara.
No. Sovereign when attacks for each
creature control power greater than.
Nope.
[Music]
Queen Kling Skitter Spike. Does that
work? It works. Okay.
Indestructible. It's all right. It's all
right. you can deal some decent damage
and if even if you pump it by three it's
you're dealing four damage to your
opponent but I was
thinking B what's Baldin do bald j your
turn creature science
no like where's my path breaker
Iex and there's one more five mana card
I'm looking
for is
Legendary cat trample creature dies have
power greater
than okay I'll just look for them path
breaker and
then there's another human that
has was it
covenant what's the what's
the covenant covenant sorry covenant
Right.
Yeah, it is doesn't have
code. It's a human for five mana. Bear
with me here. Last card I'm adding for
this deck. Human for five
mana. It says
plus different power.
Saggardian Zilla. At the beginning of
combat phase, choose number choose
number of creatures with different
powers. Each of them gets plus X where
access this power. Oh, it doesn't work
with our commander, does
it? Uh, another. Yep. No, doesn't work.
Sad. All right, moving on. Sarah Ferron.
Sarah Faron. This is like This girl is
like probably probably sings. actually
probably sings in the in the story in
the
game. The first legendary creature spell
you cast costs two less. Our own private
heaven. Yeah, it's the karaoke. Yeah,
she's inviting all the legendary
creatures to the karaoke,
right? Look at the back. Crystallized
Sarah legendary artifact. Yeah, she
turns into the karaoke. Yes. Let's see
who fulfills their focus for their fay
master are transformed into crystal and
grant life
eternal. That was close enough.
Okay, so your legendaries are cheaper at
the beginning of combat. On your turn,
you control two or more legendaries.
Transform, they get bigger. Okay, this
is this is solid.
Uh it's it's similar to Joda in that but
Joda eventually turns into like a value
deck because you just can't say no to
the value to the cascading value. But
this deck is straight up legendary
beatdown which I think is fine. It's a
fine theme first of all reoa reoa.
Sorry, I keep forgetting. But yeah,
Sarah, a team of legends led by Sarah
who inspires them with song
and
stuff. That's the theme. Now, let's take
a look at what sweet legends we have
access
to. Pew, pew, legendary creature.
creature. We want creatures.
Sorry. Isa, no tokens. Nope. Tosski.
Yes, cuz it gets pumped. Lauren, maybe
this. Yes, this is some
synergy. Uh, GA. Yes, cuz we have a big
board. Savella kind of. It's
okay. Adeline, yes. Oh, absolutely.
Double pump.
Tahira. Gorlclaw. Absolutely. Orir, yes.
Yes. Yes. The tiff. Noone. Sure. We're
not. Yeah, we don't create tokens.
Kodama. Wait. Modified. Modified. Do we
modify? We don't
modify. Nope.
Six. It's
okay. It's okay. We want some recursion.
Aison. Why not?
Aishnorn doesn't do that much. It's like
a like a hate bear. Denitha doesn't do
anything. Zandro,
absolutely. Kama maybe not. Noring clax
counters. We don't use counters. Coglas.
Sure. Okay. Yeah. So, we have a legends
beatd down deck. Sweet. Any synergy
here? Maybe we'll look for some synergy.
How we look for it is we search for
legendary creatures.
Yes. Cards that care about legendary
creatures.
BU does care about legendary creatures.
You're
right. I throw a coat. I actually didn't
know this was only legendary creature.
Doesn't change much, but it's
relevant. Ganjo. Sure. Plaza of Heroes.
Target legendary creature.
Sure. We can tap our legends for mana to
cast more legends. Yeah. Yeah.
Absolutely. Every legend will refund us
one
mana on that turn because next turn you
want to be attacking. Yes, of
course. Flowering. I mean, Tyrite
Sanctum, the
Shire. Yeah. Yeah. Legendary, legendary,
legendary. Okay, we have a
deck. Select
all. New category. Again, I don't want
to go too much into detail again with
decks that most people probably know how
to build.
So,
Sarah,
Sarah, close enough. Yuna, this girl is
important. I think she's from Oh crap.
She's
from Final Fantasy 10. Probably lives in
the zoo.
She
is are there? Oh, yeah. In in the
tactics game there there were beast
masters like people who control beasts.
She must be one of those. But then she
cares about
enchantments. So is she like conjuring
those stuff and
then conjuring those stuff to fight for
her. Yeah. Because otherwise she would
be creating creature tokens,
right? Yep. So your enchantments have
trample lifelink war too. So they are
beef. They are beefed. At the beginning
of your end step, return up to one
target enchantment card from your
graveyard to your to the battlefield
with final
decount. We're not going to do
enchantress if we can if we can help it.
I mean, she works well with the saga
creatures, but we'll see how many other
good enchantment creatures there are. If
there's enough, then we have just And
there's not much else we can do with
this really, is there? Yeah.
Enchantment.
Whoops.
Creature.
Whoops. Does this
work? We will see. We will see. Yes, it
works. Nice. The best
ones. Have to be careful with this one
because a lot of the new ones are not
going to be in EDH Wreck yet. at least
not high in the rankings. So, we have to
scroll down a bit, but we want to start
off with beat down, right? We're trample
life link. We want to do damage. We want
to start with the big ones like this
one. Not this
one. Helad,
sure.
Asta,
sure. Yeah, we want big
enchantments. Ranata, it's decently big.
Is sheeki really any good? Is not that
good. class is not enchanting
creature. Don't try to trick me.
Carametra
is if we can turn it
on. Nia, sure. Yeah. Hoping for lots of
devotion because once we have devotion
and these are word to indestructible,
trample life. Maybe just play enough
gods so they turn on each other.
Archetype. Good card.
Overlord is great.
Callix. Yeah, this is a good
card. Nthos Paragon, we are not gaining.
Oh, we are gaining
life, but we want to gain life before
combat damage. Probably still
good. Idolon is okay. Helion. Yeah,
sure. Let's play the gods. So, we have
some resiliency. Okay. Okay. And now
that we have a bunch of enchantment
creatures, we're going to need some
enchantment synergy. I'm not sure we
play enchantress here cuz they're these
enchantments are big. We are curving out
every turn. So, I'm not sure we want to
draw. Do we want to draw a card a turn?
Not really. What we want though is we
want those mass reanimator effects. For
example,
replenish. Whoops.
return all
enchantment.
Oops. Any other restrictions here? Nope.
No.
Yeah. So, it's like we have a we are an
aggro deck that has our
own our own living death kind of our own
mass resurrect which is
decent. Uh open the vaults is a bit
risky. Redress fate is
not. We replenish. There you
go. And triumphant
reckoning. Let's just see if there are
any cool saga creatures. I'm sure there
are.
Saga. Go back. Go back. Whoops. We
cannot go back. Was an error. We should
have looked first, but no problems.
Enchant saga creature. Saga creature.
Let's
go. EDH
recre. Absolutely. Yojimbo. Absolutely.
I don't even know what he does, but I
mean, how do you know? How do you say no
to these cards? Yeah, it's great.
Great.
Exion, good card.
Fenrare gets a land
in Nice of the round. Perfect. Good.
King
Mog makes
tokens. Uh, non-creature spell. Great
crit tok.
Oh, we don't have other tokens, but
sure. Sure. Okay. Yeah, I'm I was
waiting for this card. Summon type. Cool
card. Five mana. Seven. Seven. Okay, we
have a deck. Select all. Go in. We This
is Her name is Yuna.
Remember how many cards do we have? We
got 600 cards. How much is this pile?
$4,000. Not too bad, honestly. Baltier.
Baltier and friend. We are in gr
territory. And a human and a human
rabbit.
They're doing some cosplaying while
there's a massive ship behind them. I'm
guessing it's their ship. Otherwise,
they'd be shooting at it.
Yeah, but except they decided to not use
the ship and fight with they fight with
a shotgun and a an arrow. It's very gel
of you. That makes me worried about the
text. I hope it's good about Okay, it's
about vehicles. That's a good start.
Vehicles. You control get plus one. Have
vigilance and
breach. Whenever a vehicle ac crewed by
Belfier and friend this turn attacks, if
it's the first combat fix this turn, you
may
pay. So all your vehicles can attack
twice if they're
crude. But but the problem with vehicle
decks is that you have to have a
creature crewing each
vehicle, which is really annoying. We'll
have to find a way to figure to bypass
that, but once we can like once we do,
it's going to be fun. Yeah, this deck,
this commander looks sweet. So, start
with the vehicles, the core of the deck,
and then we see what kind of synergy we
can find.
Vehicle in
GR
go. And this deck is kind of aggressive,
right? We want to be on the
beat. Smuggler
copter. Yeah, we're not going to waste a
crew on smuggler copter. We have to
Yeah, they have to be decent
vehicles. Had
futter. This is
fine. Flagship. It's fine. Mana rock.
Sure. Weather light reveal historic cart
reveal vehicle. Sure. Chariot. His
vehicles are decent but not aggressive.
Not
amazing. We'll have to see. Exile
graveyard deals combat damage. Steal a
creature. It's not bad. Reckoner buster
44. Remove a charge counter. Draw a card
if there charge
counter. It This is a vehicle that
creates pilots. That's always a plus. Of
course, we want some bomb vehicles like
this one. Revert Titan. Two combats from
this would just devastate the table.
This one.
Gunship. Yeah. Again, the vehicle
vehicle that brings pilots in are
lovely. Clown
[Music]
car. I'm not sure about this one. You
pay six mana, you get a 33 and three
tokens.
No, this one slicer. It is not a
vehicle. Yes. Unlicensed. Here's
Too slow. Mech Titan's
core. This is not bad. This turns all
that into one huge vehicle. Yeah. Okay.
We got some cool
vehicles. I want to see some from the
new set. So, we're going to rank sort by
release
date. Yeah, the regalia.
Beautiful. Regalia.
Oh, Ether Drift. Oh, yeah. I forgot
about Ether Drift. It's a vehicle set.
What does this do? Thunderous
Velociped. Yeah, definitely. It's a
vehicle lord. This is also a man rock,
so sure, why
not? Live craft engine. Vehicles are a
creature type. No, no, it's okay.
[Music]
Earth Crumbler turns itself
on, but lumbering world wagon is
sweet. I have to read these vehicles.
Trample haste. This becomes a creature,
which is good. Discard a card. Return it
to the battle. That's pretty
aggressive. Okay, we got some cool
vehicles. And now we need synergy with
our commander. What kind of synergy can
we find?
[Music]
I can think of one card that is amazing
in this deck which is
called which is called
crap. I can't remember. I have to search
for it. It is a green card that says
it's a green card that says untap all
creatures crutches.
untap all creatures banner factors
drought. There you go. So, what you can
do with this card is yeah, it does untap
your opponent's creatures, but I think
you're you're coming out ahead because
say you have like three or four vehicles
on the field. You crew one vehicle with
your commander and then you crew them
with each other. Then you cast this, all
your vehicles are crewed and untapped
and you attack for two combat phases.
This is like alpha strike material.
Yeah, this is sick. And at the same
time, of course, uh we want start your
engine. I'm going to look for all
synergy. That's uh with
vehicle vehicle. Why does this OIA says
put a creature vehicle
card? It's not bad.
Ovia instant speed. Sure. Rex cycle this
card. Put two counters on vehicle or
creature. And I know it says vehicle,
but I don't think this does enough. It's
just a big dumb dinosaur that can
protect your commander. I'd rather play
protection spells. I'd rather play
protection spells that untap if those
exist. Defend the rider. Protection
spell that makes a pilot. Close enough.
But then we want to make a pilot
proactively, not reactively.
We'll probably still play it, but for
now we want to focus on the vehicle
synergies interpret.
No, we searched for the wrong color. We
should be searching for
red.
Yeah, red is where the
sweet sweet blowouts are. No.
Wait.
Yes, this is correct.
Go. What's that card again? Whenever
this vehicle Why does it have to say
whenever this vehicle attacks? Why can't
it just say H? That ruins our search
because all of them say whenever this
vehicle. Oh well, we will we will plow
through the stupid vehicles. What does
Chandra do? Shoot crew a vehicle.
Chandra creates a vehicle and crews a
vehicle. I say that's good
enough. Reckless crew. X number of
vehicles you control for each token. You
may. It's not that
good. Start your engines is pretty
good. Takeoff
celebrations. No.
Uh, Filigree Racer attacks. You may pay
two target.
No, there's one more. There's like an
eight mana card from the new set from uh
from jump start that. There you go. Push
to the limit. Push the limit. This is
nuts. Return everything. And they Yeah,
they boom people. All right. Now we want
some more synergy with our commander
because we want
untap. Why is that? Because imagine if
we
crew a vehicle and then we untap all
three and crew another vehicle. Now we
get two triggers of this. So say mid
game we have seven mana. Assuming the
untap spell is one mana, we can get
three
combats which is really good with the
two vehicles we crew.
Yeah. So, let's look for if we have any
untapped spells. Green or red.
Untap.
Untap. And we I'm pretty sure we're
going
to look for instance and sorceries.
Could be
artifacts. Probably
not. Okay.
Wh on top instant
sorcery red or
green. What is wrong with this? Oh,
partial partial
matches
rank. Oh, what if we just Yeah, what if
we just play extra combat cards
ourselves?
So let's say we attack with vehicles.
They have
vigilance. So we don't care
about them tapping. So what we're going
to do is we attack with the vehicle and
then we're going to crew all of our
vehicles and then untap all creatures
you control you. But just like
additional combat phase stack with
wealthier the additional combat
phase if this is your combat. Yeah, they
stack because usually the problem with
these kind of spells stacking is the
untapped part doesn't happen. But we
have
vigilance. Okay, so we're playing extra
combat spells. Yeah, they are sweet.
They are now sees the
day. Is that good? That's really good.
Right. Hey, is
it? Yeah, cuz we can untap
Balthier and then untap it again. And
now we get we we get three combat faces.
Yeah. Yeah. Holy crap. It's
nutty. Uh and also this one is just
untaps legless. Great card. Protection
on tap. Sees the spotlight. What does
that do? Nope.
Uh, overpowered mob rule, untap, savage
beating. Everything gets double strike
and
untapped. Does this work with vehicles?
Not really, cuz we we we can crew after
this happens. We can crew the board and
then they won't get double strike. Full
throttle, on the other hand, is
sick. Yep. Uh, seems like we don't have
many other untapped cars. Good untapped
cards. Emerald Charm just on top.
Is that worth
it?
Maybe. Do we not have other last night
together? Untap
them. Choose two target creatures. Untap
them. Put two plus one. They get
vigilance and draw of
haste. Only the chosen creatures can
attack. No, it's not good enough.
Okay, I think this is a solid skeleton.
Yeah, a very cool card. Very cool
deck. Dropping one vehicle a turn might
be a bit slow. So, we might need to need
ways to play them to cheat them
out. And how do we cheat vehicles
out? I'm not
[Music]
sure. I guess just ramp. We need some
ramp. Yeah, I I can't. Aside from OIA,
we're not going to be able to dump a
bunch of vehicles. Can we cheat
artifacts
out maybe in
red? And there are some options. The
last thing we need to do though is place
some creature
lands. Like these lands will help you
crew vehicles in a pinch, right? Middle
of vault. You don't want them to be
expensive to to turn on. But let's see
how many vehicles we have. Crew one or
lower. Uh crew
two. Okay. The crew is a bit expensive.
Crew two usually. Crew four here. Crew
four. So
maybe Yeah. I can't think of many lines
that will work here. Oh, there's one.
There's the
village
land
village. Forgot what it's called, but
turns into a
monkey. Treetop village. Yeah, this is
fine. And also cards
likeen that can create some tokens in a
pinch. Yeah, it's fine. All right, we
have a deck. Select
all. Not all
these. Don't. Please don't. There you
go.
Why? Okay, we're going to refresh the
page. Don't want to mess up the the deck
here. Okay. Select
all. New category. Beltier.
about
theater.
Okay. Whoops. We Oh, did we leave the
legends page? We did. Okay. Let's search
again. Final
Fantasy.
Legendary. Final
Fantasy. Where are we? F. Nope. Set.
Final Fantasy.
Okay, now we're sorting by color. Color
color.
Yes, we are. Oh, we're going
descending. Descending. Descending.
Descending. Please.
Okay. Legendary
creature.
So, at this point, I'm not even sorry
anymore. You chose to be
here. And this is
H. Yeah, I'm not thinking straight. And
so far, I'm having a great time. I think
it's really fun to to build decks like
this. Okay. Down, down, down, down,
down, down. Both here. Look at Holy
crap. Look how many we got we gone
through. How many do we have left? 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16. Not
too bad. We can do it. Uh,
Gladiololis. This
guy. Guard the king with our lives.
That's the way it's always been. It's
just the tough guy. The giant. What's
with the people with giant swords here?
It's like It's like a
sword
sword contest, right? It's like mine's
bigger or mine is bigger than yours.
Well, mine is even
bigger. And when Gladius, Gladiololis,
his his looks like the biggest,
honestly. This guy again probably has
conversations with his sword more than
with people. Search your library for a
land card. Put onto the battlefield.
Okay, it searches for any land. Whenever
land you control enters, another target
you control gets plus two and trample.
It's not great,
but at least it searches for non-basics.
So, we have a landfall deck that and
Guru is aggressive. So, we're playing
aggressive. And this guy can, you know,
come in
and get two landfall triggers. And if we
save some fetchlands, he can pump. Okay.
Grow aggro. We haven't done that yet
today.
So
creature. Yeah, beatd down is always
fun. Creature growl. And we want for
growl, we want like the power to be at
least four. I'd say greater than three
at
least to do the beat
down. Yeah.
Y or
Y power power greater than
three or
USD. We don't care about the
[Music]
money. Plus two trample. That's it.
Fine. Wait. Land enters tapped. Okay.
Fine. Yes. Extra combat. Why not? Why
not? Yes. Landfall
synergy.
Uh, this is good because it can benefit
from the
trample, right? On top each creature.
Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Blood thirster, not so much.
Recruiter, not so much. And
Zorak is
blocked. Sure. Trample is
helpful. Hideous taskmaster is
ridiculous. It's really good.
Ike, we don't have modified
creatures. Firebol
flutist.
No multiportio. Still
good. Yeah, we are playing landfall
beatd down. And in this deck, it makes
sense to play some ramp, right? To play
some good ramp cards. We want at least
two
lands. Search your library for two
lands.
a
hero.
Whoops.
Search
for two
lens. Search for lens should be able to
get us what we
want. Yeah. Cars like this.
Why? We don't
want Why? Oh, because of stats, of
course. We want cars like hero. Like,
they're good early, but late game also.
We can use them
to to do stuff to
pump. Escape shift. Yeah,
totally. This land and creature good.
Hydra. Good. But I was thinking more.
Oh, this is
like ah might as well go
big. Where's my hero? This is a creature
and a land and gets a land. I think it's
fine.
Um, what does road and home road ruin
do? Ruin deals damage to target.
No wave vitrial. Good. Clearing the
board of all
vitrio. Fine. I'll do it
manually.
Suck. Oh, and this is the deck we are
playing again. All
fetches for maximum. But again, if
you're
playing all fetches, are we really doing
it with this
commander if you like it? Who knows? So,
some fetches go in
there. Oops. Go in there. Sak
tribe. Not really. Herrow propotation
because I'm assuming our deck will have
some relevant non-basics. Good
non-basics. And restoration. That's the
other one. Cozen verse doesn't work.
Does it?
Nope. Plan of woodland is a bit
expensive. Spring Bloom Druid,
sure. Rolling regrowth, sure. Okay,
let's search for some non-basic lands.
What kind of non-basic lens would be
good with this
commander?
Fetchlands.
Uh, lands that reward big creatures. Kic
Warfront, but we already have evasion.
We'll just do a quick quick search.
Scroll
land. And it needs to
have Can't think of
much. No.
What? Land.
Yeah, I can't think of too much. I mean,
card draw is good.
Always too much relevant. Okay, hideway
is good.
Yes. Oh, that was this monster bridge.
Don't want to go too fast. Our commander
is expensive. So, I guess if we have
some cards that are working that are
built around the commander, we want
command beacon. You can search for it
with our commander. That's solid. Game
trial. Wolf run is decent. Wolf
run. Field of the dead. Sure, we're
getting lots of
lands. And yeah, we can also place some
landfall cards, but I won't bother
putting them here because seems fairly
obvious. I guess we'll pick one that is
the best landfall card. Which one is the
best landfall card? It
is skew mob, right? Sorry.
Scoot
no.
Nope. Scoot
[Applause]
swarm.
Beautiful. We have a deck. Select
all. This guy's called, what's his
name?
Gladadio. Gladus.
Radia, summoner of
mist. This seems like an important
character.
And yeah, that's a cool I like this
design. It's like a bit similar to
what's her
name? What's her name?
Yuna, maybe. What does she do? Landfall.
She cares about lands. You may discard a
card, draw a card. That's a good
landfall ability. Return target saga
card with meta value X or less from
graveyard to the battlefield with a
finality hunter on it against
haste. Yeah, seems like she's just
working with the lelay lines, channeling
the power of the lands and creating
these conjuring these things, these
summons that are sagas, I guess. What
are they called? I forgot what they're
called. Infrits or something.
something like that. She
probably Yeah, she probably has a lot of
spells and a god that she's angry at,
wants revenge. And with this deck, yeah,
we can again, we can do landfall. And
because she dumps the she dumps the
sagas into the graveyard by herself,
right? Kind of kind of we don't really
need to do much. So then we can just get
a saga every turn. Get a saga every
turn. I think that's a solid play
pattern.
And yeah, we just need to ramp to filter
our
hand. Every saga can be dumped into the
graveyard
and we play other cards that synergize
with sagas. Okay, let's take a look at
Gro
Sagas.
Saga. Saga.
Go. You can pay zero to return or
saga. Maybe not.
Um, considering the graveyard synergies,
the mending is always
good. But they're in back again. Turn
block is there back attempts to use a
search library for a mountain from the
battlefield. Hey, it triggers
landfall. Yeah, I guess we just play the
cool sagas. I I don't imagine green soul
saga to have too much
synergy among themselves. So, does it
really are we are we dropping this hard
in quality
already? Let's take a quick
look. We are not. We are not. It's just
EDH being weird or did we not sort by
track? We
did. Okay.
Play additional land. I'll pass. Create
a treasure. I'll pass. No. No. We want
this because we're doing one a turn. We
want them to be kind of impactful. And
also, we are definitely ramping a bit.
So, I'm guessing we're starting off with
like five mana sagas
minimum.
Yeah. But she returns them with finality
count. Okay. Yeah. Let's ignore the
small ones first. This one is decent
though. deals two damage to each
opponent and creature. Creates a
dragon. It's like a big discard. Yeah.
So, this is
fine. The flux. Nope. The parting of
ways exit five cards each number of time
counters. It's not
bad. We can get free
sagas. This is good. Wait, it says non
saga. Almost almost got tricked.
Um, of course
bahmut power stone tokens. Nope. Trolls
destroy land without your land card from
Gator. I wouldn't spend a turn doing
this. So,
no. This ramps I can just cast it from
my hand. I doubt I'm going to bring it
back,
but something. It's something. Sisters.
The Magus sisters. Three counters on
creature. put a shield counter
turn. This is not the kind of Saga. Even
though she gives Saga's haste, but
again, like I said, we're doing one a
turn. We are probably not going to do be
doing much beat down. So, I'll pass on
this for now. Also, it already has
haste, so negative
synergy. Instant sorcery spells
exile. This cares about
our from each graveyard. So, not just
us. So, this is
good. Summon Titan. This one is good
because it returns all lands. It works
with the
graveyard. Yeah. Okay. So, we have a
bunch of sagas. Now, what? Now, what? We
have a saga every
turn.
And we are tapping out for it kind of.
We're tapping mana for it. So the rest
of our hand has to be well or we need a
decent amount of ramp.
So search
land. Once again, why am I doing this?
Is for people who might look who might
have to look at the list. Search
land. Just to add a few just so they
know.
So the play pattern is play your
commander and then we ramp a
bit. So turn three ramp, turn four ramp
is all
right. Oh, do we want to play all the
fetches
again? I guess doesn't
hurt. I mean, if you have them, play
them. Personally, I actually really
don't like all color fetches, but
nowadays there's more and more upside
between the shuffling, between the
landfalls and all that. Uh, it's
unfortunate. I hope they patch the rules
one
day. See? Okay, let's see. Hero. Yes.
Okay.
Now, what is the rest of the deck going
to do? Saga enchantment interactions.
We're not going to play Enchantresses.
We are going
[Music]
to So, we don't have too much mana to
use because we are returning Saga every
turn. So, I'm guessing we can do some
graveyard
synergy. Madness.
No, return all from graveyard. Return
from graveyard. See if we have any of
those.
[Applause]
We don't really want Yeah, like this
kind of stuff is good. Splendid
reformationation pinnacle summon is
fine.
Eternal
Titania aftermath
analyst. This is fine. This is good.
Lots of
lands. Do we do landfall for the rest of
the deck? I don't really want to do
landfall
again. You can,
but
yeah,
Motani Dr. is
fine. Bumar is
good. So, I guess we are doing big mana.
I guess we're doing big mana. We are
capable of.
So, aside from dropping saga. Okay,
let's see if there's any other
enchantments
energy
enchantment. Enchantment enchantment.
It's all destroying
enchantments. Yeah. Sanctum viewer.
Sure. That's enchantment energy. Draw.
Do we need draw? Honestly, I think we're
fine for drawing because we're
discarding all these sagas and we're and
also we're just kind of discarding some
lands. So, we're drawing the other
cards. Now, we're we're trying to figure
out what the other cards are. That's the
question. Doesn't seem like we have a
ton of enchantments
energy.
Oh, we can
[Music]
play what's his name? Bellow. We can
play
Bellow. We will add him
soon. More counters on a permanent
a
player too
slow. Yeah,
bellow. This works with our
deck. Okay, so I think we have what we
need for now. We're going to drop this
into her name is Ryia. with the
uh Terra. This one I've seen and I Well,
let's read
it. Terra enters mail five cards. Put up
to one enchantment card mail this way
into your
hand. So, she's like resource gathering.
Kind of looks like from the art kind of
scouting the grounds. See what's what's
growing over here.
Then
trans exalt return it. transform so
expensive. I I honestly I don't like
these designs where you have to pay mana
to transform and activate that sorcery.
It's impossible for you to depend on the
backside too much because it's so
expensive and your opponent will just be
holding that removal waiting and the
front side is just not enough to build
around. So, we'll see. Now, this copies
target enchantment gains haste if it's a
saga but three lore counters on two
sacrifice.
Yeah, this seems like just another saga
deck. Saga
deck except non-leendary
sagas five
color. Anything else we can do with
this? Not really. Is this better than
Tom
Bombadoo? Okay, if this is like the best
saga deck there is, it's fine. We'll
build it. But we're not gonna we're not
put in just a few saga, but we'll figure
out some synergy if possible.
Saga, no color restriction because this
is five color. This is not cool. And
play the best
ones. Do we play flip sagas? We can, but
again there so
expensive. So expensive to play. Whoops.
And of course, we want to play the
expensive sagas because they're getting
copied,
right? Yeah, they're getting copied. So,
let's just narrow it down to CMC greater
than
four. Yay! The coming war. This is why
we're here. Why? What? Oh, power.
CMC. I don't want power greater than
four. Battle of the Hellvault.
Sure. Tom Bombadil.
Sure. Horus Heresy.
Sure. Protects our commander. Not
really. Kind
of. It's
fine. Evolution. Gain control of target
non mut. Nope.
Yeah, play a bunch of sagas and play a
bunch of enchantment synergy now that we
are
in now that we are in five
color. So much we can
do.
Replenish. Starfield of
mix and then see if we have some other
enchantment crap like for each
[Applause]
enchantment for each
enchantment. I think I put
saga power.
I don't want power. Freeze
enchantment. Sphere of safety. Why not?
Enchantment
payoff. Not too much over here. Boon of
the spirit realm. Whenever Boon spirit
damage under your control creatures you
control get
what? That is not good.
[Music]
Um yeah and after that with all these
sagas enchantments last
reanimation are there protections
enchantment you control health shroud
yes search for enchantments I think that
might get us
something aside from destroy all
enchantments. Oxy command is still nice
cuz we can do artifacts creatures some
creatures. Uh this ramps
us we won't have too many enchantments
but still still good because we need
lots of mana for for transforming our
commander.
What is this? Destiny Spinner can't be
countered. That's okay. Sterling Grove.
That's enchantment
payoff. Yeah, we have a
deck. Nothing too special, too
interesting here. Not a big fan of this
design. I honestly think Tom Bomb might
be better, but didn't look too much into
it. Terra
done. Black Walt number three. You fool.
Do I look like some moldy black mage
soldier? So, it's like Yeah, it's like
the character that's disguised as a
black mage for all his life just waiting
for you, the main character to come and
all the black mage around him didn't
know, right? And just
transforms. Always found this funny.
They're just waiting for for this one
moment. I don't know how they decide
when to do it, but seems like they did.
And this is like whenever it comes to
non creature spell, black walts number
three deals two damage to each opponent.
Now, this is just ridiculous, right?
It's the is it the best black red small
spells
deck? There is another one that's
similar, but I'm not sure. I mean, I
know it's to
walk. Yeah. I see to is target opponent
to any target actually. But this guy is
each opponent. So just a gutter snipe in
the commando and you just worry about
chaining spells, removing things and
then your commander will get the job
done. Yeah, it seems like one of the
best
uh what's it called? Best commander,
best spelling slinging commanders for
Ratosse. So we're going we're going to
try that. We're going to try that. But
we know we have a lot of small spells.
We know our commander can deal damage.
What are the synergy? What's the synergy
we're looking for? Small spells, non
creature
spell each opponent. Well, first card
first, which is
clinic. And
um we want small
spells. We'll start with instance and
sorceries because other non-creature
spells don't really have the same
effect.
So
instance,
oops instance and
sorceries power. Nope. Meta value less
than four. Even four is kind of high.
Although we do want we want to play some
cost. What? Okay.
[Music]
Sorcery. Sorcery.
partial
match.
Okay, I think we just play a bunch of
them. Play all the good ones. Not feed
this form. I hate feed this form. I
don't think it's actually good. Sure.
Two spells in one comparator. Sure. This
is Yeah, this is a powerful deck. I
think it's going to be a powerful
deck. Well, of course, deflecting swat
protection man. Sure.
Deadly dispute. We don't
have
no sign and blood draw two cards. Maybe
gamble.
Maybe terminate rebirth. Sure.
Removal
maybe. Read the bones. Yes. Ratos charm
is a good card.
So, lots of small spells just
to control the game, annoy your
opponents, cut awakening, table
trickery, of
course. And now the question comes to
how do we refill our
hand. So, let's see.
Whenever you
cast a
spell,
ratose, cutter snipe. Yes. Purgy. Perie
is great because the black sight allows
us to refill our hand and we can kind of
storm off a little
bit. Um, young pyromancer probably not.
Fire incription. Good card. I'm not sure
about the one damage ones. Our commander
already does two damage.
So runaway steamkin whenever you cast a
spell at red red your third spell every
third spell gives you three mana.
Probably not. Crucation mage is fine.
Otter
wizard glaring
flesh. Refilling our hand is going to be
tricky.
bothers some closet. Yeah, this is a
great card with small
spells. SGore witch cast copy as a
sorcery spell create one black green
pass against life. I do like the life
gain and we do need to kind of block,
right? We need to control the
board. All right, we have all these
spell slinging payoffs. Not really kind
of
some maybe some cost
reduction. Spells
cost less. There you
go. Black spells and red spell cost
less. I think it's fine. I mean worst
case it reduces it for our commander so
it serves like a as a
metarok right so let's play
them a cloud key have to choose between
instance and sorceries don't like
that blue and red no hazardous monument
dominance helm of awakening
no I think that's all we have for cost
reduction okay artist talent is good yo
this is crazy Good. Yeah, you're you're
exposed to loot. They cost less and you
can finish with
this. It's pretty good. I'm glad I kept
scrolling. Now I will scroll
more. I think we are
done.
Yeah. Next up, we are looking for just
card draw. We need ways to draw
cards. Simple as that.
Oh, I remember the card before I forget.
It's called something
amulet. Amulet of something something.
There you go. Primal amulet. It reduces
the cost of your spells and it flips
into a land that can copy spells. It's
always good.
Uh, we have
this. Uh, black market connections
doesn't really do that
much. Sure. Throw
possibility. Yeah, we're going to need
black for to draw us cards. But how does
black draw cards
though? I think black draws cards by do
we? Probably not.
demand answer. I think black draws cards
mainly by recasting things from
graveyard. So we are going
to cast from
[Applause]
graveyard black and red. Yes. Yes.
That's how we do
it. Cast from graveyard. Cast from
graveyard. Revise. What does it do? Add
to no
dragons increase in vengeance.
No pain
distributor. Finale of promise. We may
cast to one target turn from
graveyard. One each. That's decent. But
we're not going to pay 10 for X. Don't
think we get to do
that. Caravic crime exile onto one block
from reaver. Copy it. You may cast a
copy if you do lose two
life. We're not We have some target. We
have some commit crime stuff. Not a
ton of
prior to there you go. That's one way to
do it only black. Oh, any instant. Okay,
that's good. and also something like
mastery,
right? Okay. Yeah, this deck should be
fairly
powerful. Fairly powerful, I'd
say. Nice. Black
mage. New category,
black wolves.
Next up,
Garland. He's got Oh, man. This guy's
got main character pose, but side quest
energy. Side quest villain
energy. Like, what? All right, Garland,
we'll knock you. Yeah, there you go.
We'll knock you out down. This is
like I'm again AI wasn't a thing back
then but if it was I honestly would feel
like this dialogue a lot of these quotes
feel so
AI and whenever you cast a non creature
spell surveil one that's
it return this card from your graveyard
to the battlefield
transform I really hope the backside is
good because I don't want to build
around this servial
one the backside I I mean it's Sav mana
has to be decent, right? I mean, look at
him. He's Jeez. Chaos the endless. I
think I underestimated him. It's a It's
a badass
demon. Flying fight. Oh, when Chaos
dies, put it on the bottom of its
owner's
library. We are building around servo,
guys. We're building around servo. Also,
favorite text. Even as you die again and
again, I shall return.
How does that make sense? This is not
AI. You die again and again, but I shall
return. What? Like return from what?
Partying.
Celebrating. Yep. We're building around
Surville. Oh god. Every time cast spell
one. What non-creature spells can we
cast? Just normal the normal stuff.
You know what we are doing? Reanimator.
That's what we're doing because every
loot card, everything card, every other
card, we are we get to dump one more
card. And even the Metarox allows us to
dump cards into so we can fairly quickly
get some fatties
out. It's actually not the
worst. Okay, first to motivate us, we're
going to play the find the biggest
fatties we can
reanimate. Boom.
[Applause]
creature. Oh, sorry. What am I
doing? What did I mess up this
time? Greater than. So, greater than
six. What was I doing?
Shield
good battle sphere. Nope. Cosite can't
reanimate. Well is
good but
nope still can't reenate. Not
surprisingly not impactful enough
honestly. Sure he ex all their half
their library and then half and then
half. We'll see. We'll see. Archon's
good.
If that betray on the other hand is very
impactful kind of snowballs but
not it snowballs could win the game on
its own. Twitter for his card demon. I
wouldn't reanimate this
probably. Wood winwards. Okay. Kind of
locks our opponent down. Ancient bronze
dragon. Sure, because it brings more
creatures back. Razic is fine. We
tutor.
And that's a decent decent team for
cards to reanimate. I'd
say
Emercle, Lord of the
Void. Okay, it's not getting better. We
have 1, two, three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, nine. We do need more. So,
let's take a look
again to go
up. Lower our standards a little bit.
Ah, but is that
it? Oh, we can we can lower the scene.
We can we can accept six
CMC lower than six. No, I can just cast
I can just play man and cast it if it's
lower than six cuz six I remember there
is a card
called
Itali.
Yes,
sure. Yeah. No more sorings for
you. Scourge of the throne is not good
enough.
Okay, cool.
Now, I think that's it. We've got 12. I
want a few more. I want a few
more. So, again, greater
than
six, I guess. Ulamag is fine. Now
looking at it, instructible. I was
surprised there's I I guess we're in
Ratos, right? Not really. Not Not like
we're in a good color. Uh
Rudamog, this can lock down their board.
No more creatures for you. I'm sure t
for
something. Again, we don't want to
reanimate this, but it's better than not
having something to reanimate because if
we have lower than say 15 to 20 targets,
we might just not get a target. Prozac
is
fine. Also a
tutor. Okay. 17 targets. Actually, no.
16 targets. Raz and we're
cool. I like three. It's
doable. Okay. I think this is good. Now
we we play a bunch of uh yeah, loot
cards and discard
cards.
Um anything that discards.
[Applause]
draw this card, I
guess.
Sorry. Draw this
card. Boom.
Boom. Big score is quite
expensive. I think we own this
deck. Sure. Kath
[Music]
reunion. Cipher mind doesn't
reenate. Tormented voice. Are we just
playing all of them? Dark Deal.
Sure. Jaxis discard a card token copy of
creature you control. It's that's a fine
card.
Um yeah, we don't have to play too many
discard. Okay, pirates. No, that's it.
Strictly worse. Then better reunion is
good cuz haste. Ah, speaking of haste,
we want anger. We will add that
later. Dragon mage.
Okay, next up.
Anger. Next
up. Next up. What? Backup plants. If our
fatties don't they get answered. Living
the death. Living death. Of
course. Patriarch spitting.
[Applause]
Don't choose a creature type. What's the
one that returns all creatures from your
grave
from return all
creatures? Zombie Apocalypse Awakening.
Is this any good? Funeral room. Whenever
a creature girl dies. Nope, it's not
good. Bring her of the last gift is
good.
Did I misremember? Is there not a card
that does this? Oh, Bathor is good.
Seven mana bring everything back. And I
just remembered something. I forgot to
play reanimation
spells.
Smart. Uh, return.
Wait, I I'll just search. I don't know
how to animate dead because they're all
worded different. It's
like reanimate.
and uh
victimize. Yeah, we can sack our
commander. We suck our commander and
then it turns into the stupid chaos
thing. Yeah, seems
good. All righty, let's go
Garland. Next up, Kua Gnome Sorcerer.
Now, this is some side quest bots
energy. Two black
mages. At the beginning of your end
step, create a tapped. Oh, one of those
tokens. When you cast my spell, deal one
damage to each opponent. Then, if you
control four or more wizards, transform
coo. Is this the best spell slinging
commander in
Ratos? Crap. Is it? If a wizard you
control would deal damage to a
permanent, it deals double that
damage. This might be better than black
walts, but it's a little bit
different. Create a whenever you cast an
spell. Creates a token, transforms
doubles
damage. I think you do the same. I think
you just play spell sling. They go in
each other's
decks. Except we want to do we want to
transform it or do we want to just keep
making
tokens? Um beginning step create a
[Music]
token. Okay, we'll see. We'll
see because let's see if there are any
wizards that we can
use to transform him early if that's
what we want.
Okay. Dual caster
mage. I think these are fine. Wizards
trigger
double seems good. Yeah, we got some
wizards
energy. Maybe
board. Maybe board.
And
then, oh, this guy's a wizard.
Beautiful. Anything
else? Yeah, I don't think we actually
want to force the transform just because
we want to create some wizard tokens
first. But this one, this token creation
is actually quite slow and it's not ETB
or anything. So, we have to wait a
turn. Yeah, this is a bit slow.
So, uh, we are going to Oh, one car
mutable
vault. That's going to help us
transform. And what
else? What's another card? We want cards
that create this wizard token similar to
Kua. So, we will copy this text.
Yeah, all these cards. These also go
into uh black walts, but uh target
opponent sack. Sure, why
not? Lindlum.
Nutty. This is a wizard that enters,
creates a
wizard. I mean, it's two wizards, so
we're transforming.
Queen. It happens when she attacks, so
probably too
slow. Transpose. Draw a card. Discover a
card. Use life. Oh, wow. Okay. So, we we
make some wizards. And once we do that,
I'm pretty sure this the rest of the
deck is very similar to black bolts. Um,
do we care
about So, the backside. Okay, we'll put
in some spells. play some spells,
but instant. Can we play another card
type like battles? No. Planes walkers,
sagas, artifacts. This an artifact
commander. It is not.
Equipments.
No. No, I don't think
so. Got to do spells, man.
Okay, forgot to limit the
whatever. You get the
point. Spell slinging.
Yay.
Vote emperic
reanimate. F is looting just as
well. Now also another thing is the
commander once transformed is a 4 six
that doubles all damage. So this works
well with cars
like it doesn't work with what's it
called which is clinic but it works well
with cars like
again Chandras
ignition and also if we pump this by
merely seven damage it can kill people
late game. So that's another alternate
win condition. How do we pump by seven
damage? Well, something like black
blade. Black blade reforged.
Sorry.
Transcri fate
defied. Anything else we can
do? I don't think so. I don't think so.
Okay. Again, with these decks, I feel
like they're more open-ended than I'm
giving them credit for. So, if you find
something unique and powerful that
works, please comment. Let me know. I'd
be really curious. Her name is Kua. His
name is
Kua. I'm just guessing, honestly.
Apologies for any
mixups. EMTT Selch
Unared. It's the same post as Emit. same
post as Cooa like, "Oh, welcome to my
city." He doesn't even own the city, but
welcome to my city.
And you know what? He might own the
city. This is pretty sick. I mean, yeah,
this is pretty
sweet. What will become of our triumphs,
our hopes, our our despair? So
deep. Emit vigilance. Whenever enters
our attacks, draw a card and discard a
card. Another looter. The beginner
jobkeep. If you there are 14 or more
cards in your graveyard,
transform during your turn. You can play
the 14 cards from that you
mil if a card would put into your favor
any more
exo. So you can't loot the same card
again and again and you can't really
control the game because you only during
your turn. So you have to play
proactive and playing proactively from
your graveyard. What does that look
like?
Aggil beatd
down. But I mean when they wipe the
board, your commander's gone too. So
it's not
like also 14 cards to transform. Are we
doing reanimator
again?
Really?
Really? I guess we are cuz in reality
you are proactive and also being be able
to play cards from the graveyard you can
reanimate two three things a turn right
because you're milling yourself you have
all those cards in the graveyard rather
than just having that one reanimate in
your
hand so I think this is actually a
better reanimate
commander we'll see we'll
see
okay but first again we are going to
look at all the fatties
We won't look too closely anymore just
because we we just did that. So meta
value less than greater than six greater
than five and
demir and
creature
go. You're in. You're in. Yay. Blue does
have some solid creatures. I'd have to
say like as a whole is just
ridiculous. Uh artisan h maybe not.
Klac villas really is still
good. Rul maybe maybe not. Archon still
decent. That betray still good. Ancient
silver dragon drop 20. Sure. Cause sure.
Jin Gataxis that's good.
Doubles our void win. Good. Another
Jenga taxes. Hey. Yeah, blue does have
better targets roster.
Okay. I think we're good. I think we're
good. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Go fast. 16
target 15 targets
already. Toxil. Toxic throw is a good
one. Ancestral dragon. Why not? That's
decent. Doesn't win the rest of the
game,
but yeah, seems good. Now we want lots
of self
mail self-mail like
male each
player
mail
player because 14 cards is not easy. How
many loot spells can we Oh, we have the
mana cost restriction still. Also,
creature
restriction. So, let's take that away.
And take No, we don't have the creature
restriction. Altern is good. Is good.
Breach is too expensive. Brain freeze.
No. Mine crank. Nope. Childrip scour.
Sure. Play
one too expensive. Drown in the
dreams. How do we mow ourselves? Each
opponent was each opponent.
Why? Sacrifice an artifact. No.
Traumatize yourself. It's a bit too
aggressive. But I mean, as soon as you
get the traumatized down and flip your
commander, you are going off. So maybe
maybe play
it. Garuda.
Garuda. You play with top four pairs.
This is decent. It's like Mill and Rean
all in one. It's not terrible to bring
back from the gra.
So, what does this do? Ancient one. No,
it doesn't do
much. Glimpse the unthinkable might be
honestly decent
here. I guess we because we want to do
it fast. Dreamorn muse is a bit
slow. It's a bit slow,
but I guess we are a slower reanimator
deck. We're when when our commander
flips, we are reanimating like two three
things in one turn rather than rather
than just one. So, I guess it's fine.
But the condition is that we need to
find enough cheap reanimation spells. Do
we have
that return creature from
graveyard?
Okay. Dread return. Good get
enough three creatures. Yeah, but we
have
to on earth three and a value three or
less.
No persist.
Absolutely.
[Music]
Um stitch together. Yeah. Threshold. We
have
threshold.
Anything
else? What does this do in front for
funeral room? Sure, the other side
returns
everything if we get to eight mana. And
the funeral room is not terrible. It's
okay. Incarnation technique returns two
things. Overlord helps us fill the
graveyard with the impending
Yeah, this is kind of the skeleton.
Also, the
enchantments, dance of the
[Applause]
dead,
necromancy. Uh, what's the other one?
Reanimate. I think this is fine. We do
need more self mill. There was a card I
remember like a black silver library but
I forgot the name that it brings like a
it helps you fill the graveyard. It's an
enchantment. I will try to find it. Pay
one. Pay one. Type line
enchantment.
Oops.
Enchantment
block. This should be able to get us
there.
No, too many. Really? Wait, no. This
one. Repulse of
undeaf. Yeah. Pay one or three and three
life. Put a card get a card back, but
everything else goes to the graveyard.
Yeah. So, we are probably flipping our
commander on
turn turn four, turn five, the earliest.
So, we're not going to cast it until we
are ready to flip.
And we are going to have some protection
spells. Yes. So, some cheap counter
spells.
Oops.
Instant. Doesn't have to be counter
spell. Could be counter spells. But
let's say for example, I'm not going to
use the
search. I'm going to do
say what's it called? Target player
creature face. Oh, slip. Slip.
something slip out the
back and then like the blink
spells I forgot the name but I do
remember an offer you can't
refuse and also cards like
um what's that land
MDFC
[Music]
return
Uh, MDFC is what we're looking for.
MDFC. There you go. Malaka Rebirth.
These are also fine as protection
spells. Yeah, we have another reanimator
deck. This seems decent on paper. Damn
it. A little bit too dependent on the,
you know, the setup and on your
commander. But even if commander gets
killed, we can still play kind of
reanimation normally. I guess we want a
backup plan or something like that for
our fatties, for example, like uh
quicksilver amulet. But
yeah. All right. Gold bets crystal
collector. Whenever an artifact you
control enters at the beginning of
yours, let's see how many we have left.
Not many.
the beginning of
your end step. You control four or more
artifacts. Return target creatures cards
from your graveyard to your hand. Then
you if you control eight or more
artifacts, each opponent loses life
equal to that card's
power. Can this can be another
reanimator? It can,
but let's see. So getting eight
artifacts is not super
realistic, but getting four is kind
of. What kind of artifact tokens are we
using to get those four
artifacts? Can we play an artifact aggro
deck and our commander will just give us
value?
But black blue doesn't support that. So
well stuff if you control four more
artifacts. Yeah. The question is what
kind of artifacts we're going to use.
Matter rocks. Yes. And then when they
surveil things into the graveyard. Now
what? You just get to return something
to your hand every
turn. And equal to power. So that makes
big artifacts. So, I'm not sure we'll be
able to build around this, but I I I
think maybe we're playing. We'll see.
We'll check out the the option of aggro
because aggro works best with all all
three of these abilities, right? Because
we can get some value. We don't have to
The problem with aggro is running out of
cards, right? So, we can get some value,
get some stuff back, and at the same
time, if we get there, we can boom
people.
So, let's see what we have.
Artifact
creature
creature commander
bum no
restrictions. We will start we will
Yeah, we will start low to the ground.
This is not Oh, I guess they
are artifact
creature. Why? Oh, it has to be artifact
creature. Yeah. What was wrong with the
search? Oh, MDFC. That's the problem.
[Music]
My
apologies. Here you go. Let's find the
most aggressive ones. If we can find
like 15 to 20 good attacking creatures,
then we Yeah, we can do
it. Cost one less. Yes. Metamorph.
Yes. Baleful strikes. Yes. And ideally
we we prioritize token making Ethereum
sculpture. Psychosis probably is not
bad. It's fairly aggressive. Walking
blister. Not really. Golem. Nope. We
have battle sphere. It's like a nice top
end. Steel hell kite. It's not great,
but it's okay. Again, beggars can be
chooser. Scraper. We Yeah, we work with
graveyard. Worm coil engine.
Good. Crashing draw bridge. No. Thought
monitor. Yes. Maybe.
Maybe. We'll see. Steel overseer. Yes.
Makes our guys
bigger. Giving giving flash to our
artifacts. It's okay. Yeah, flash is
good. Kappa
Canonir. This is kind of
aggressive. Cyberdrive Awakener.
Noncreature artifacts.
We might have some
uh hanger back
walker that'll work. Colossus non
creature artifacts.
Nope. Uh autumn soldier copies as an
artifact. Yeah, it becomes can imagine
getting three worm coils. Master of
ethereum. Good. Triplicate titan is too
expensive I think. But you can just dump
it into the graveyard and use the
commander's ability to get it
back.
Maybe
Triniform Encore
12. That's too much and is not doesn't
do as much as the Titan. Ka is
good. K is good. Yeah.
Uh, this deck is not as aggressive as
we'd like to be, but let's see if we can
get some
tokens. Master transmitter.
No. Soul is good. Discount. Unear.
Nice. Seir Ginger. Artifact you control
was put into graveyard from the
battlefield. Put a postcard on Sir
Ginger. Put into graveyard from the
battlefield. Not really.
Artifacts get
pumped. Artifacts have text
proof. Artifacts make tokens.
Yes. Okay. We will do this for now. And
after this, we're going to look for some
artifact
[Applause]
payoffs. I suspect it's just Öza. We
will see.
spy network artifact
creature. What does tech do? It makes
artifact creatures
bigger. Oh. Oh, I missed it. It's not.
It's uncus. Sorry. That's good. Chief,
sure. Obelisk.
No. Yay. There. Yes. This is the payoff
card. Bior transference. Creatures
control artifacts. They already
are. Whenever you cast an artifact
spell, you may lose two life. Necron
warrior create a
token. Uh
uh. It's not amazing. You just got a
token. That's all.
Oh yeah, we can play some vehicles. Can
play some
vehicles,
but like this one is fairly decent. I
think the cyber. Yeah, you create. Yeah,
six mana 88.
Totally. What was this? Grand Architect.
What is this score
pre? Yeah, artifact pump.
The cyber controller enters each one of
those X cards. No. Oh, artifacts get
plus one. That's worth it. It's a mana
sync. I was hoping for more cards like
of course we'll play Tesarettes because
that's like the
payoff. Tesarette,
right? this one for the ultimate. But
the rest of this is also
decent.
Tesarette create a file for draw a card.
No, I'll draw two cards. No, this
Tesarette first activated ability. Draw
two cards. Discard two artifact. Gross.
No, this one. The bridge. Yes. Master of
the
bridge. Tesarus betrayal. Disarch.
No. Okay. Okay. I think we have a
deck. Oh, and we've lost some I think we
got enough big stuff for our commander
to
return. Yeah, I don't think our
commander ability is really worth for
for you to oh, early game boom get try
your best to get eight counters, eight
tokens artifact into play because the
payoff just isn't worth it. So, we want
to play artifacts kind of
organically. We play the ones that we
want anyways.
All right, next up, lock and
coal. Very
stealthy gold
beds. Lock and cold. Death touch,
lifelink. Whenever lock and cold deals
combat damage to a player, draw a card
and discard a card. We got vampire
knighthawk over
here. This is
terrible. It's so
bad. This might be the worst. One of the
worst ones here doesn't do anything. It
has to connect and then you loot. So,
you can't even loot reliably unlike the
other ones here. Death touch, lifelink,
gain
life. Can we work with the death touch?
We
cannot. It's like the guy who thinks
he's doing a lot, being
stealthy, being sleek, but actually he's
no one notices him. Just in the
background doing some espionage work.
this. Oh, I am stumped by this guy.
Human
rogue rogue
tribal. Okay, when you're stumped again,
we see which 99 this guy goes into. I
don't think this guy goes into any
99. Is there a rogue tribal deck that
kind of synergizes with what he's
doing? But the problem is he doesn't do
much.
So,
rogues.
Oh, rogue. Rogue
rogue. There's no synergy here. Just
random
rogues. Death touch is a nice blocker.
You can defend lifelink. Voltron.
Voltron. Deir Voltron because death
touch works with trample. Lifelink helps
you catch up and then draw discard as
additional value. Yep, we're doing
it. So, first
equipment that gives Trump
Triple and lifelink. We want Deir. Did I
not say Deir? I did not. My
apologies. My
apologies. Um, yeah.
Warhammer Trump. This is too big, too
expensive. Lean axe. Sick.
Four bearers blade vigilance
trample.
Yeah. T what? T45 power armor three
doesn't untap.
Brilliant. Oh, it's getting worse and
worse. Uh is
that no on is good. Chariot is good. You
can see our standard is dropping just
like that.
All right. All right. And now why why is
this open? I don't know. Uh
lifelink. Yeah, I already have lifelink
from Okay, but trample. Trample.
Yes.
Now double strike
because that also kills blockers. Yes.
Makes them unbeatable in combat.
I think the process of building EDH deck
honestly a lot of it is just about
lowering your standards. It's like when
when your standard is up there
everything looks like crap but then the
moment you lower it suddenly you're like
oh this is great. Wow. Amazing. Holy
crap. What does this card do? Yeah.
So expectation management is a important
part of commander deck building. Brass
knuckles. That's fine. Double strike is
good. Uh, Genji glove. Good. Rover
blade. Rover blade is
okay. Oh, equip four. Holy
crap. Okay,
now I doubt we have any equipment
synergy, but we should have artifacts
synergy,
right? Anyways, equipment. We'll see.
We'll see what kind of equipment energy
we
have. Armory, automaton, anchor to
reality. Artifist all equipment. Haste.
Hate. That's what it is. Enter the
battlefield. Attach control instru. Oh,
this is good. A great card. Blade of
shared
souls. Oh, I can make it copy of
another. Oh, eye control. No.
I candlestick carry
away. This is a rogue payoff equipment
except it doesn't allow me to equip more
equipments. Do I still play
it? I guess it's a rogue tribal deck.
Rogue
equipment. Cranial plating. Big
pump. Cryptic
coat. Cursed
windbreaker. Manifest. No. Deathrunner.
No. Yeah. And then we want some of the
traditional typical equipments. I mean,
he cares
about getting damage through. So, a few
[Applause]
swords. What did I do
here? Sword
of
Okay.
Sure. Might need all the swords just
because we are desperate for anything
that does
anything. Not hard at home. Hard home.
It's
fine. Sure.
Got to make sure we get that damage
through so we can
loot and uh protection indestructible.
Yeah, I think I think we got this
set. And my coat for the third
time. So, what is the rest of the deck
going to do? I'm pretty sure it's going
to be artifact
manipulation because blue does that.
Black doesn't really contribute
anything. I
think. Yeah, black doesn't do anything.
Sad. What can we do with
artifacts? Not much. Metamorph copy
artifacts.
Reservoir. Yeah. Fabricate.
[Music]
Talisman. I guess we can bring
equipments back. The ones we
loot. This is good. Yeah, Emry is
actually not
terrible. Urza. Yeah, cuz
we because we the artifacts can that the
equipments can top for mana. And yes,
Sai, Master Thopist.
Okay, some payoffs. And then next we are
going to do
some protection for our commander.
Again, slip is the best one
probably because face out. You keep all
your equipments. But aside from that,
just counter spells. Oh, and offer you
can't refuse. Why are you dealing with
our stuff? We are playing
garbage. Oh, and of course, we have a
cyber
drive
awakener. Turn your equipments into
creatures.
And of course, we want cards that
have Yeah, equipment tapping is a thing.
So, we want cards that have what's it
called? Not not conspire, not convoke.
It's
called I have to find it on a card. Word
of
invention, which is good in the deck.
Improvise.
Yes.
[Music]
Improvise. Sure. Next has improvise.
Improvise.
Target creature. No. Improvise.
Improvise. So
bad.
Improvise. Non artifact spells. You have
you cast have
improvise. What are we improvising
here? Our
commander.
Nah. Nah. This is fine. Draw three
cards. Two
mana. Good card. Improvise. Synth
infiltrator. You may have synth creature
on the battlefield except synth artifact
improvise. Don't really need it. Yeah,
that's all. That is the
payoff. Ooh, there's one more. Is there
one
more tap and untapped
artifact? We are desperate
here. Tap it. Untapped artifact. Yeah,
let's let's make mana. Oh, this is fine
because gives it gives the commander
unblockable
turnabout power stone.
No
terminal network terminal tap and untype
artifact draw a card then discard a
card. Guess fine. Are we doing anything
with the
discard? Doesn't seem like
it. Yeah, blue is doesn't reanimate.
Doesn't reanimate artifacts. So, we're
just looting for for value. Okay, we
have a deck. 32 cards. 32
cards. Why did I spend so much time on
this
guy? Luck. Cool. I hope I don't see him
in the
game or he's going to get it.
He's in Final
Fantasy 6. Okay. Barely dodged. Barely
dodged my bullet. Suffer off. This guy I
know he's important. He's
cool. Probably a
douchebag. Defin Def definitely doesn't
pay
rent because he lives in the main
character's
head. Vigilance enters creatures
opponent control get minus two. Whenever
a creature opponent control dies, he
gets bigger. Um, it's six mana. Not
great. This seems like the starter deck,
right? It's the starter deck card. Is
it? So, yeah. Not
great, but better than much better than
what we had to work with. We can do
blink. We can do close.
I want to clone him a bunch, but the
problem with cloning him is that this
ability isn't even static.
So, you're not going to kill the big
stuff. So, never mind about
[Music]
cloning. What else can he do? Vigilance
44. He's play removals, kill things,
pump him.
Not sure it's worth it to be
honest. Yeah, cuz he comes in, kills two
or three creatures. Is it
seven? How do you build around
minus? Oh, I know.
Okay, you
do split second 0
one. This kind of crap. This is what
you're going to do.
Whoops. 02. I think I
misremembered. Yes. This is what you
do. And then once you do that, you
continue to trigger
Sepharov. You can blink suffer off.
Clone
Sepharov. Okay. I like this game plan.
This is not good, but at least something
kind of special.
Okay,
creatures
become I think this will do blue black.
Yeah, this is the blue black color pie.
We are right in the color
pie. We're play. We're going to play
every single card. What is this?
What did I
do? Creatures
become. Yeah, we're going to scroll down
to the bad
ones. Maybe creatures is your opponent.
I don't know if
Yeah, is your opponent.
Okay. Something wrong
here. Your
opponent
creatures opponent
creatures and a
slash. Let's not do
it. Let's see.
Well, first this should go in.
Yeah, massacre
worm. Might as well. Doom with
giant. I think we found the right
keyword. Just have to scroll
down. Target creature gets minus three
minus three. Not good
enough. Minus one
counter. Ven.
Nope. Flat line. There you go. There you
go. Humiliator.
Yes. Oh, and we need this one card.
Yeah. Yeah. We
need C. What's it called? Exodon.
Exodon.
Yes. Exit.
Turn face down.
Beautiful.
Uh, this is situational, but this I mean
you can draw two cards, which is fine. I
mean, gruesome
realization doesn't do
anything. Rags to riches. No.
Arc fiend of Soros.
No plague engineer. No creatures you
can't
control. No, it's
too Where's the one I was looking for?
There's a spell
that creatures your opponent's control
become something.
not get minus something
something creatures become one one I was
going to do this become one
one hunted
family this is kind of cool seven mana
what really seven
mana not really okay and there's one
cursed roll
token
flash. This is solid in our
deck. And
then 01
creatures have
base. Maybe this
is which I should search for.
Master Minist. There you go. That's what
I should have searched
for. A slush
monster. It's
fine. Yeah. Yeah. Now we have 11 cards
that have decent synergy with our
commander. Should be more. See? Minus
one. Minus one counter.
Seriously, how do you just ignore the
minus one minus one?
How on
creature? Maybe not. Maybe each
creature, not target creature. C R E A H
on creature. Okay, we'll see. Oh, we are
in the right color for talks through,
are we
not? We are.
Beautiful. Okay, next. There's another
thing I want to search for. I forgot
what it's
called. I
forgot. Oh boy. Why? Why?
Why? Spark double. Spark double. Yeah,
we Okay, we're starting to do clones
because we want multiple Sephro
triggers, especially if they stick
around. So, we're not against doing
[Music]
that. Creature dying cost trigger
ability.
No
minus. It's strange. Although I feel
like we're not missing too much. This is
what we have to work with. So now we're
going to do copy target
non-leendary. Not
legendary. So that we get all the spark
double-ish clones. Do we? We do
not. Uh why not? Question. Why
not? Oh, because it doesn't target copy
a
really
except I'm just going
to
Sakashima. I know Sakashima.
Whoops. And we want ways to blink suffer
off, but we want to keep the counters.
So, keep counters. What's that card
called?
too much. It is an artifact. It is one
mana. The name is like it is
why move counters. That's
why the Oelith. Sure.
And next we are going to
play some blink
spells to keep triggering
suffer. Sure. I saw return blue not
artifact.
Yes. I return. Why not? Oh, because one
CMC.
Okay, there you
go.
Blink,
blink, blink,
blink,
blink. And now that we are getting
suffer triggers, lots of suffer
triggers. And maybe cloning suffer
off. I just remember we have to there's
one more card that turn
creature face down because we don't have
enough of
these. I this guy. Yes. Lifted
harvester. And we want
whenever creature dies. See, we got we
got this energy. We got the engine kind
of going on.
It's kind of iffy. It's kind of sketchy.
But now we don't want these because I
don't think we're killing creatures in
mass. But we absolutely want Mik Cook is
actually good. Mik Cook is actually
good. But we we want things like black
market. Yeah, I want the other
one. What's the other
one? Yeah, like grim. No, you control
revel in riches. Yes.
And then whenever a creature like this
kind of stuff, harvester of souls,
whenever something dies, you draw a
card. Talk to this goes in. It's
excellent. Yeah. And this is our
Sepharoth deck. How do we win with a big
Sepharof?
And so now that we are blinking and
cloning suffer off, I feel like I just
feel like we're missing
something. Your opponent's creatures are
dying.
And no, I think we can keep their board
clear and attack through. Okay, that's
our Sephar off
deck. No. Uh we are going to select all
go to new category called Sepharov.
Nice. Next
up, Alt Messia. Ultimsia time sorceress.
Whenever Ultia enters or attacks,
Surveil
2. Are we doing this again? No, but she
looks like she's got some some story. I
mean, look. Look at this. No way. It's
that
simple. End step. Oh, you pay this as
our eight cards
transform. This creature transforms into
it's a time
walk. Oh, okay. I am stumped. What do we
do with this? Yeah, there's no way we
are doing building around the time lock
cuz it's it's not happening. What? eight
mana. Exile eight cards. And even if you
pay for it, what's the point of time
walking when you when you're spending
all the mana in a turn on that you can
play I guess you can play creatures be
aggressive or something like planes
walkers. But again, we're not building
around this this ability. Looks like we
have to build around Surveil 2. And
again, this is different than the
previous ones like lock or the other the
Ratos ones because it's five mana. It's
expensive and surveil 2 more uh still
more. So, it's more of a midame kind of
thing. Graveyard synergies. So, I think
just a graveyard value deck with our
commander that eventually has some kind
of very little in
inevitability. Yeah, I a really cool
card with sweet art. I mean, look at
this heart, right? We want to make her
work. And yeah, we can do something like
where your opponents only see the front
side pretty much four games out of five
and then in that one game you transform.
It's like holy crap. That is sweet. That
is a sweet card. Time it will not wait.
No matter how hard you hold on, it
escapes you. Wow, look at that. You
transform and you read that to your
opponent, they will be terrified. Okay,
so graveyard matters seems
straightforward.
graveyard matters. So maybe we do
something like cast from
graveyard. I know
surveil surveil is kind of a theme was
kind of a theme in that round block, but
I don't think I don't think it's a lot
of stuff or anything too good color. My
apologies. I know we have like four
legends left and I messed up in the
first 50, but this is the last time. I
will get it right. I will get it right.
Grave collar. Wait, what type is our
girl here?
Ultramsia. Human Warlock. Human Warlock.
Okay. Necromancy. Bring stuff back.
Consuming aberration. But we're playing
with our own graveyard. So yes, start
with Yagamas world and build build from
there. See what happens.
Um, moving primordial metallergic
summoning. I are we do a spellbased deck
or just a good stuff deck in Demir. I
think I think we might be more spell-
based. So, let's just do this. Put this
here for
now. Yeah, there we go. Grave breaker.
Lameia spells from graveyard cost one
less.
What? Uh, Giza and Gerro. No, not
zombies. Oops. What happened here? Okay.
Anyways,
deserity memory
blunder. Yeah. So, a lot of these are
casting from opponent's graveyard, but
stuff like river
kelpie. Yeah, I think we can make it up
like this. Uh, somehow grave breaker and
metal didn't go in. So, we
go. Yeah, might as well just do a
flashback, right? Flashback, jump start
and all that. We've got enough. This
one, draw a card of Var. Discard a card.
If you discard, it's
sorcery. Sacrifice. Yeah. Yeah. This is
the kind of card we want.
Snapcaster. Secrets of the dead. Yes.
Guess what? We did the right search.
Yes. Gearhulog.
Sure. Got like a more traditional,
nothing too crazy. Graveyard deck is
fine. Uh, binding. No.
I like this. Uh, wait. Five. So, one
plus four to return a spell and then
whenever you cast a spell, you get a
honor. And see, this is the kind of
stuff where you have you have to
evaluate it based on the first mode
because the other ones are just not
good. If the first one the floor is bad,
then you don't play it. And the floor
here is not what we want. We There are
decks that want this, but not not ours.
Jace, of course. Oh, and there was a
there's like a similar card to Jayce in
the instro block. I'll try to find that
and then we're we're done for for this
for this search. Uh Hak or something
something
Hak can't
remember. Oh, and that one. Oh, that one
doesn't cast behavior. That's fine.
Never mind. It's not enough to chase.
All right, then. Flash back.
Flash. Sorry.
analysis. Absolutely. Army of the dead.
No sncaster. Sure, why not? Lear.
Yes. Think
twice. Maybe we don't have do we have
enough payoff for casting from
graveyards? No, we don't play creatures,
so we're not going to play Cly, but we
do play spells aside from insight from
Alchemy. Sure.
Evviserators inside memory illusions.
Yes. Yeah. So, we still I still think we
need more payoff. But can we find that
or do we just naturally get value? We
will see. Cars in
graveyard. Let's How about that? Cars in
graveyard. Yeah. Yeah, ag probably
coming in if we have it.
Whoops. Mine's burning alive. Factor
fiction. Yeah, this kind of graveyard
filling artifacts from graveyard with
Emory. We don't have artifacts
yet. Drown in the
lock. Number of cards in his controller,
but that's not what we're doing here.
Me. What does this do? Finale. Draw 10
cards.
No chemical
oversold.
Aftermath. Uh, not this one, but
aftermath is good.
Yeah. Little Allergic. We have already
search for Scand. Yes, that's this kind
of deck for search for Scand. Now, the
question here, the problem here is
winning.
Yeah, winning will be difficult. We
can't again depend on our commander to
beat people down with that transform.
So see if we can find some kind of
honestly with the commander transform it
might be
doable because we just need one or two
massive game ending
equipments, right? For example, or aura
equal to in graveyard. this kind of
card. Hopefully some some pump in
uh in equipments or some kind of
aura. Excuse
me. Nighthawk
scavenger. How about this? Each opponent
no one doesn't do it. Sir Ginger doesn't
do
it. Huh?
Crow fage mail four cards power
toughness number of creature cards in
all graveyards. No. Yeah, I think this
is this is it.
Glendering. Glendering equal creature
has first strike and gives plus one plus
for each instant or sorcery card in your
graveyard. One second. When ultimacia
transforms
uh at the end step. Okay. So then you
transform untapped and you put this on.
Goku deals combat damage to a player.
You may cast an instance spell. Yeah, I
think this might be good. But then uh
no, we are casting things from our
graveyard.
Yeah. So it doesn't really work with
these cards. Never mind. Yeah, like jump
start uh you know flashback. So then we
have to do the more traditional spelling
when conditions
like whenever cast
spell like shark
typhoon shark typhoon hallbreaker. Yes.
Hallbreaker horror horror displacer
kitten. In theory the kitten can kind of
you know go infinite with her commander.
You can just transform it, blink it,
transform again. As long as your
opponents don't have an op uh what's it
called? A uh removal or an answer, then
you win.
So, we do really have trouble closing
out games. So, we will have this as kind
of an option.
Yeah. Also, blinking isn't terrible.
Like, you can get to you get to protect
your things kind of and you get to reuse
like your commander's servo, too. Yeah.
Let's use it. Yes, sure. And then shark
testing. Nezahal doesn't really fit the
theme of the deck, but this card is just
nuts. Like the moment you play that
Nahal, he becomes your connect. It's
that good. Also, Ledger Feather. It's
good. Yeah, we need cards that fill our
graveyard that are good. And these two
are some of the
best. Ver is my shark typhoon. There it
is. Okay. Yeah, we have a deck. All
right, let's move
it. Her name is
Ultimia.
Wonderfully. Yes. Okay, good.
Now, this Ze dark mage, it's a statue.
He cosplays as a statue and
then surprises people when they when
they approach, but then people know
because they that's why they're here.
They're here to beat the dark mage. But
your struggle was all for not. Do you
see how close the darkness has drawn?
Well, let's see how close the darkness
has drawn. Menace Zande gets plus one
plus one for each non creature non card
in your
graveyard. Not very
close. This is I think the worst rare
we've seen. so far,
right? We're what what are we doing? Do
we play a control deck and then just use
him as a natural finisher similar to
that? It's just like that Golgary guy,
right? That Golgary guy with the
backside getting bigger for each
permanent in the
graveyard. But this guy is just the
same. It'd be boring to play just
control and then win with it. Would it
be boring? Would it be inefficient? Cuz
we need like seven. Not seven. No, no,
no. We just need four,
six. You know what? I think it's
doable. Yeah, cuz we play a lot of
smaller spells and he can grow fast. We
just need eight cards for this to be
twoshot. So, we don't even need to have
to like, for example, traumatize
ourselves. But, of course, we're going
to play traumatized because it's one
shot. So, okay, he's fine. I kind of
didn't pay attention to the actual size
of him because he's three already. And
then you can plus a bunch of
traumatiz.
Okay. Then we just play a bunch of small
spells. Yeah. Alex Thoscower.
No. And some control control
cards. Maybe temple. Maybe. We'll see.
Uh so we search for cards that are blue
and black that are
small less than
three. And we want none creature non
land. Okay. We want non creature non
land. Uh,
not
lander. Boom.
Okay. Yeah, we just played the best
ones. Sure. Let's add a fire rocks, but
we prioritize the ones that
uh that the ones that can help fill the
graveyard while they're doing their
thing. I guess we should have counter
spell. Yes, sure. Rift. Sure. Cast for
two
mana. Dark SH. Not really. The gate can
offer tutor. Sure. Yeah, we are bringing
this up to level what's it called?
Bracket four before we even have a
strategy. Brainstorm.
Great.
Sure. Mystic fora draws his cards and
fills the graveyard with non creature
non land card. Swan
song is is counter spells the only thing
we can do in the mirror and removals.
Let's go
to yes removals. We want
those. We don't want flesh lens. It
doesn't touch pre-ordaining is
good. Villager rights. No
tops. Rapid
hybrization. Sure. Draw cards. And so we
have a lot of really low to the ground
spells that hopefully we can control
very early on in the game. We can make
this guy 7 seven very early
and possibly more.
So what uh
yeah and something like black bit is
also nice for later on in the
game. But what I really want is because
we are depending on our commander a lot.
So we have to do you know equipment
griefs griefs
boots
boots then of course protection spells
move instant
Dive
down. Fleeting
reflection.
No. Oh, magic temper. This is good.
Amazing
skin.
Shall shield shore up. These are good
cards. Okay. So, we protect our
commander and uh he have a menace. So, a
decent chance of going through, but just
some unblockable. I don't even want not
sure I want unblockable cards cuz
it's we want a few. We want a few.
Okay, unblockable. We want it in We
don't It could be could be anything.
Could be lands. It could be World's
Passage. Oops. So, we will Yeah, we will
search for
that. Whoops. What did I do wrong?
Unblockable Commander U.
Um, can't be blocked. Is it changed now?
Can't be
blocked. I don't like how they don't
include the old text, but only the
oracle text. Just because I mean, what
if people don't know about the the old
text, right? Yeah. Whisper good access
tunnel does not work. Aquous form, no.
Brotherhood, regalia is good. Yes. The
black gate, absolutely. Also, there was
the the shisel or something.
Yeah. And this deck will be fairly
aggressive and you also get to answer
things, not just uh going all in, right?
So, it's kind of
fun.
Sat
go. All right, moving on to Azorius.
Today we have Absolute
Virtue. And this one I do know about the
lore even though I didn't play Final
Fantasy 11. It's just such a meme
almost. I read about it. It's apparently
a boss that's impossible to beat. Takes
players what 30 40 hours to beat. I can
only imagine that. And they took turns,
but like now I'm six hours into this
video and I'm
like I can barely hold on. But anyways,
I'm glad this one is near the end cuz
this is I mean one of the legends that
I'm most excited for. I'm not sure how
exciting it would be to play against,
but because of this top down and the
flavor, I think there's something really
cool we could do. Absolute virtue, eight
mana. This spell can't be countered.
Flying. You have protection from each
opponent. Now, protection from each
opponent means a lot. It basically means
you cannot lose the game. There are some
ways for them to get around it, but you
know, damage is all prevented. You they
cannot target you. So, I think what
we're going to do with this deck is
fairly clear is that we are going to
ramp out Absolute Virtue and then just
protect it. That's our entire game plan,
right? Your opponent is have it's like a
raid boss, right? Your three opponents
probably know about your game plan and
they will have to work together to
figure out how to beat you before you
you do eight eight eight and kill them
out. they have time and this is not fast
but this can be kind of annoying to play
against if your opponents are newer to
the game and they don't know how to work
around things like protection things
like you know for example you were going
to give it indestructible but again with
this commander I feel like this is the
right way to build it just so flavorful
and so different than other decks other
commanders so absolute virtue now we
have protection protection means
basically hex proof yeah I mean you
don't need hexroof on this guy and also
So not indestructible. So how can your
opponents kill this? They can make you
sacrifice. They can uh they cannot
counter it. They can destroy it with a
board wipe. Is that
it? I mean they can bounce it. Yeah.
Like cyclonic rift. So these are the
only ways for them to deal with absolute
virtue. So we're going to find some
protection. Now we're going to start
with indestructible, of course. Uh let's
see.
And also, I think we Yeah, I think I'm
not sure if we're going to prioritize
spells, like instance or artifacts, but
a bit of both would be nice. I'm
thinking spells more just because you're
in blue. You are capable of refilling
your hand, especially this deck will
have a lot of rep, right?
So, we can Okay, let's see.
Indestructible. And I think I want
games, right? because we don't we don't
want to find indestructible creatures.
So, let's
see. White should have a bunch. Blue,
not so
sure. Blue, I don't think has any. Yeah.
Okay, let's start off. Okay. Of course,
lands are always good. Lauren skate.
Excellent. Blacksmith uh smith will.
Yeah.
Yeah. Final
showdown. Yeah, this card is ridiculous.
It is a protection spell that's attached
to a word wipe. Valerous
stance.
Sure. Anything else? Take up the shield.
Great card.
Lifelink. Celestial armor.
Excellent.
Uh, divine
resilience. Selfless samurai. Although
these selfless cards are not bad because
they protect you against indestructible
and single like a single sacrifice,
single edict or like flesh flashback or
something. So maybe we play yeah for
example selfless savior and maybe the
samurai. Although at this point we can
just play we can just play selfless
spirit. I guess h why not let's play
them. Also, playing these ahead of time
is nice because you're dropping Absolute
Virtue as soon as you can and chances
are you might not have meta open, right?
So, you know what? I'm gonna play all of
them. Yeah, probably get it.
Sure. Carameress Blessing does not
work. Fight as one does work. No, it
does not work. Bodyguard does not work.
Does not work after the fact. It only
works I mean it doesn't work if you play
it first. Yeah. So, sheltering light.
How many do we have here? We got a 13.
13 is not
bad.
Convoke. So, this is basically one mana
just because you can always tap your
commander to convoke because you don't
need to block. There's no point
blocking. Really?
Okay. We have a an adventure for that.
Cool. Cool. Cool. And honestly, I don't
think we need a ton. I might cut a few
just because the only thing these are
protecting us from is board wipes,
right? And board wipes doesn't happen as
often as something like path to exile or
like spot removal. So maybe we'll cut a
few of these and maybe we will put in
some cards that are more, how do you
say, they can dodge more than one type
of removal. Like I want cards that can
dodge
bounce, sacrifice, and destroy. And the
only card that does that, the only cards
that do that are phasing out and blink,
slow blink. But the problem when you
phase it out and slow blink is that you
you lose protection. Your opponents can
alpha strike you. But I still think you
have to include a few of them just to
Yeah. just to protect your commander.
Let's usually they can't kill you in one
turn, right? Usually your commander's
gone. They have this window, small
window. Yeah. So you're usually fine.
But yeah, we'll include a few of those.
So first face
out out face
out sort
uh clic concealment costs three mana to
do protection. Are you sure? Is this the
only game changer we need to play?
Possibly. So who we'll see. Talon gates
on the other hand is ridiculous. So
good. Um, sniff out the back.
Absolutely. Tefairy. Just afairy. Nope.
Doesn't protect our creatures. Gadrials
just dismissal is one of the better
ones. Proliferate. We don't need
proliferate. Roll of the stars. Yes, it
cost two mana and two mana to activate.
But yeah, it dodges pretty
much. Yeah, like once this is equipped,
your commander is safe. The robe can be
destroyed, but your commander is just
always safe. Wait a second.
No, the robe is safe, too, because the
robe faces out too. Yeah. The moment the
robe is attached, your you can't your
your camera cannot be killed. The only
chance they can the only chance they
have is to make you use it and then
attack you.
Yeah.
Stack vanishing. Yeah. Oh, vanishing is
Wait, this is the same as robe, is it?
I guess we play
it. I think this is enough. Yeah.
And yeah, 20 like 19 pieces of
protection including
land. Yeah, I think this is fine. Now we
need lots of ramp. Lots of
ramp.
Whoops. Add
I'm thinking 15 to 20 pieces of rep,
which leaves us 20 spots in the deck for
something else. And we want Yeah. We
want the most aggressive, most the
greediest rep because as soon as you get
your commander out if they I mean blast
is fine. It's fine. Just protect your
commander. Yeah. So stuff
like Wait, we'll wait. We will first
play
animal go to Lotus.
Sure. Archive Power Stone Archive is
okay. Yeah. Again, this is not
definitive. You can play whatever rep
you like, but I like since your
commander is eight mana, I want the ones
that, you know, like four mana add two,
four mana add three, three mana add two,
this kind of stuff rather than a two
mana rock. 1000 rocks in this deck is
less value. Uh yeah, you get the idea.
So I'm thinking 15 to 20 pieces of rep.
And after that, you have 20 more slots.
But the play pattern of this deck, what
I wanted to be to be like thematic is
that we don't really worry about what
our opponents our opponents are doing.
We don't answer their stuff. All we do
is cast a commander, protect
it, and win with a commander. So I Yeah,
I I'm tempted for also for to be fair,
right? You don't deal with you don't
interact with them. They don't interact
with you. Uh so to for fairness and
flavor, I don't want to put in any
removal or any interaction against your
opponents. Not even counter spells, just
protection spells. Well, this is by
choice though. You can definitely do
something different. So, for the
remaining cards, I'm not 100% sure what
to do, but I know one thing I want to do
is I want to play a little bit of pump
because you want to you want to kill
them in surprise two hits. Yeah, the
surprise kill is usually what people
they expect you to take three turns, but
you can do it in two turns. So, what we
need for that is to give plus five,
which can be difficult in a blue white
deck.
Uh, plus so I think it might have to be
equipments or maybe auras for plus one
plus x. Let's see if we can find plus x
or
equipment.
Yes, I can't think of equip a few
equipments, but aura or
idolized. Nope. Uh, staff. A bone horde.
Katilda. What's Katilda? Number of
permanent you can throw that are spares
or enchantments. That does not
help. Tested frying pen. Uh gain one
one.
No strength. Testing hammer. Roll a
six-sided
die.
No razor field.
No hand of. Yeah, there. This is the
kind of card. This can easily give plus
five. Plus five.
Hedra
matrix too
expensive. Okay. What about aura? There
are no
auras. Plus one. I plus one for Yeah,
plus one. Four each maybe or four. Yeah,
plus one four. See if I can find
something. I know the black. Oh. Oh,
that clears. What is that? Nope.
Although plus five might be achievable
just because of how many rocks you have,
but I want something ideally a little
bit more consistent or a little bit more
independent of other things like black
blade. Just five mana and you can kill
someone pretty quickly. Nettle with no
mantle of the engines. No lion
slash ding
dagger. I thought there'd be some Oh,
this aura playing super control. Uh,
we're probably not going to have five
plays. Stratosythe,
no. Imperial plate.
Yes. Easily plus five.
Righteous
authority. Yeah, this easily plus five
again. I think that's all. I think this
is enough. We got we got how many of
these? We got five four or five of
these. What is this? Sigual distinction.
Put X charge counters on it. Plus X
move. So we have to pay six mana and
then it's plus
five. It's not bad. Do we have enough?
Well, we'll do these for now. Oh, and
also I just uh I did a dump. Clearly
clearly the rest of the deck has to be
draw spells. Yeah, there's no there's no
other cards. because we're don't because
all the cards we're playing are really
low value, right? Meta rock uh
protection. So, we need cards that
recoup all this lost card advantage. So,
draw
card blue,
white, and
uh doesn't matter what
type instance and sorceries are usually
best,
but yeah, I think we should look at the
type of instance and sorceries.
So
sorcery. This video should be titled six
hours of me learning how to use track
and not mess
up. I mean how to use scrifall and not
mess
up. Uh windfall frantic search. Windfall
honestly not terrible in this deck. It's
because you don't really like your thing
is not messing with your opponents. But
but maybe in blue we don't have to be
this extreme with our why are the low
cost draws so so popular they're
not I don't I don't play them in most
decks Seagate of course for tomorrow
absolutely
um born upon a
wind I like this but two is expensive
there's a there's one in white that does
the same which is nice because you can
flash in your commander. Speaking of
flashing in your commander, that flash
man should I will get it later. Uh
Laurian revealed. Yes, great
card. Sure.
Finale. I think blue has been power
crap. It's only popular because people
are not using the new ones yet. But this
one is like number five, number six best
x. And also my favorite like the best
crossb is not even being played in my
opinion. It
is recurring
insight. If you don't care too much
about instant speed interactions in
sighted record in
Icite.
Yeah, honestly it's your personal
preference because once you have your
commander out, you probably have like
eight or nine mana and you have three
mana up to protect it and with current
insight, you can you can make phase no
problem. And main phase ones are usually
more efficient.
Okay, we've got the deck draw spells
protection and rep. That's it. That's
it. And a little bit of pump. Honestly,
even pump feels feels impure because you
want to give your opponents time to deal
with this cuz again, it's only it's only
fun if you if this drags out for a
little bit. So, you kill one opponent in
three, hits another one in three,
another one in three. But then nine is
nine turns is way too slow. So, I think
two turns per opponent is kind of bare,
kind of reasonable. You have to you have
to judge. Yeah, but this is what we'll
have to test and see what the play
pattern is like. But for now, we have a
deck the what's it called again?
Absolute virtue
AV. Okay, Sid, Timeless Artificer. Next,
this one I also looked at and I also
didn't have much idea on how to
build because it does a lot of things.
It does artifacts. It does, you know,
having multiple copies so you can do the
throwing stone stuff and also it's got
cycling. And a lot of the lists I see
are it's like a mixture of all of that
and there's no focus which again sit
already isn't a really powerful card to
begin with. And if your deck is kind of
everywhere, I don't think it's going to
work too well.
So after looking at it, I realized the
only only good like only efficient or
good thing that it does is
like pumping artifacts, right? Because
if you cycle just three or four SIDs,
now every SID is like an overrun for
your artifact creatures. So this might
be what we do. Just artifact beat them.
Play maybe 15 or 20 SIDs and SID. Yeah,
Sid is your commander, but you have 15,
20 more. And uh go nuts. Cycle them.
Cycle them and play a bunch of cheap and
efficient
artifacts. Yeah, I think we want our
creatures to be really cheap so that we
have mana for cycling and uh we can
swarm the board early to take advantage
of Sid. So, I want to try that. I want
to try that. I'm not sure how many how
many efficient artifact creatures there
are, but I think we're going to play
lot of them.
Yeah. So,
artifact artifact
creature creature and uh blue
white at the same time. We want the mana
value to be less
than less than let's say three. Yeah,
let's be aggressive. Let's be
aggressive. See what we can get.
Did I not say archive creatures? Did Did
I
stutter? Oh, partial matches of
course. 6 hours in. I still don't know
how to use scrile. I feel
smart. Okay, let's
sort. This is not looking good. Two
mana. Two one. Good. As for Sentinel
Ornithopter is ornithopter. Yeah, I
think it's good. Yo, let's play all the
play all the zero drop ones. Why not?
Let's play
uh like what's it called? Ornithopter.
Yeah,
ornithopter. Okay. Ethereum copper
definitely. Ornithopter. Yeah,
sure. Mirror
retriever. Ornithopter.
Yes. Spell sky. Yes. To protect sid and
spell can attack.
Steel
overseers bit slow but still good I
think. Skirith
scriff toxic one metallic movement can
metallic move it choose artifact
creatures. It
cannot lion
sash yeah these are all good cards. Lion
sash ginger brute.
Okay, we're we're going deep. We're
going deep. Stone coil. Great
card. Uh, hanger walker.
Sure. Marvin. Does Marvin do anything?
Nope. Each legendary has w too. Okay,
sure.
Might ether sworn. Yes. Ether sworn.
Good card. Hope of
gear. Sure. Sir
Ginger. Yeah, because I'm going a bit
deeper here because I I want to see what
the deck kind of looks like. Afflict
three for artifact creatures. Do we need
that? Sure. Too
dark. K9. What's K9 doing?
No. Ferro Revoker
Crystal. Securron
Squadron. Argon
ravager. No, it's too too deep. Signal
pass is not too deep.
Medicican core. Oh, it's like it's made
for this
deck. Okay, so we have a board of small
creatures and art, small artifact
creatures. And so, yeah, the game plan
is we got what, 20 of these, 19 of
these, and then we play 15 SIDs and
cycle the SID. And but the problem with
SID against the cycling cost is so high.
Is there anything that reduces cycle?
Uh, let's try it.
Cycling. Cycling. If we don't have that,
we might have to play some dig spells
that dump cards into the
graveyard. Um,
cycling blue, white. Let's see what we
can
find. There's one card that makes things
cycling a thing. Not
sure. Oh, yeah. This is not a good
search.
cycle. Yeah, I'm just looking. I'm just
getting every single second. Fluctuator
cost two less to activate. Does not
work. 58 cards. Yeah, I cannot think of
too many cycling synergy. When I recycle
a card, when I recycle a
cart. No, no, no, no.
So, we don't have much synergy to work
with. And I guess we could play uh
what's the Astral Slide, but blinking
doesn't really help us too much. It kind
I guess it kind of protects other
things, but not too much. Okay, then we
search
whatever use cycle. See if we can get
something. I don't think so. The best
make a token. No. No. No. Uh, pay one
exile artifact or creature. No. So, we
don't get to really reduce cycling.
So, I guess every turn the game plan is
to
drop. No, early early turns the game
plan is to
drop. They saw like turn one, one drop,
turn two, two drop. Turn three, a one
drop and a cycling. Turn four, cycle
cycle. Turn five, drop a sid, and you
attack for, you know, plus four. It's a
bit slow, but we can make the game plan
more resilient with the reanimating
small stuff cards like uh
return X creatures
creatures from
graveyard. Guess we're going we're as
well here.
Any other payoff for small creatures?
Let's
see. Dance of the mans return to X if X
is six. So eight mana for them to be
big. This is fine just because we pay
five mana return three things,
right?
Yeah. Not the worst. Immortal
obligation. Nope. Rally ancestors. Exel
them. Exile those at the beginning. I
don't want to exile them.
No. Return creatures from graveyard.
What did I Oh, the
mana. Yeah. Some sometimes annoying when
you don't know which way you did wrong.
Is it the the text or is it the mana or
you just forgot to not set something?
But we we we eventually find it. Now the
internet's a bit slow. I guess they're
sick and tired of me looking at Scrifall
the Architect for all day, half a day,
and trying to warn me about the dangers
of getting addicted to things. Maybe
uh
Dusk to Dawn. Great
card. Reteather.
No. Redemption quite no salvation
engine.
Yes, it's a pump and it recurs. Although
the recursion part is not really not
really efficient. Got a crew
six smile at death return up to two
power two or less. Put a each of those
five minutes really expensive. We want
it to be
bigger. Rally. We saw that
one. Aurelius Vindicator Xtarget
creatures. No.
What about wake? Isn't there one from
foundations return? Oh, could it be each
creature? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I think
that's the word when it specifies like a
certain CMC is each creature. We'll see
if that's
correct. Are we wrong? Second sunrise
not
death. No, we are wrong. So,
uh, there's another card, too. I forgot
the name, but it's white. It's four is
two and two white. So, CMC is four and
it is white. And it says graveyard. It
has to say graveyard. It has to say
graveyard. Okay, we'll find it. We'll
find just that one card to see if it
works. Um, yeah, this is also another
one. What's wrong with this? Return all
creature and planes walker cards with
mana value X. Okay, so it's creature. Oh
yeah, creature. Okay, creature cards.
Okay. Yeah, good
card.
I brought
back. Can I find it or not?
I cannot. Okay, there's how many of
these are there? Why? No, never mind. I
give up. I give up. But I'll put it on
the screen if I remember. But aside from
that, this is a deck and I think we have
to play some protection spells. Yeah,
cuz we're not super fast and your
opponents will find a board. So, board
indestructible creature indestructible.
Is there a card that says artifacts get
indestructible? Creatures
indestructible once again. Boom. Boom.
Creatures
indestructible. Just add in a few. And
we also want to add in some artifact pop
to see if there's any corros. Well,
absolutely. Best best protection.
Flawless maneuver.
Sure. Uh
Montra any good?
No.
Bastion
monument. We don't go that
way.
Crescendo. Final showdown. Everybody
lives. Uh, make a stand. Make a stand is
good. So, pumps your board, too. We need
the pump. Okay. Then we look for some
artifact.
Artifact creatures.
Plus go. This is Oh, we are playing.
What's a tempered steel in EDH? How
sweet is that? How sweet is that?
Tempered steel. Can we find it? Artifact
creatures. Artifact creatures.
Yes, they must
wonder. Tempered steel. Master of
Ethereum.
Absolutely. Oops.
Uh, Untus. Is that good? It's not even a
not even a what's it called? Artificer.
Okay. But yeah, this is the skeleton of
the
deck. Honestly, I came in with no idea,
but I This looks decent. It might not be
as fast as I hoping it to be, but Sid
does pump for a fair bit. I mean, it was
like a static overrun for four mana,
right?
And when they kill your commander, you
can just place subsequent cysts that you
draw. You don't have to pay any
commander attacks. So the entire time
you just need four mana to to function
for like to do things. So yeah, seems
cool. We can play this deck. We can
probably go like 35 L maybe
lower. New category. Sid. Sid. Sid. Sid.
Oops. Sid. Sid.
Sid. Hope.
Esti. Oh, I forgot to do the flavor for
Sid because he's super interesting. I
have to guess what he is. But this one
is kind of obvious. He probably appears
in every game and in different form,
right? And probably has the same job in
every game.
And yeah, just a like it's like the
Pokemon Poke Center nurse and the
Pokemon lady. Also, what's her name?
Jenny the
cop. And I am ruining I'm ruining my
reputation in the Pokemon world, I'm
sure. Uh, but yeah. Anyway, sid hope
estime
estim link at the beginning of your
endst step each opponent mills x cards
where x is the amount of life you gain
this
turn. What the
what kind of ability would trigger this
kind of top down design? You mail your
opponent. So, it's like you're stealing
their
knowledge and you're also healing
yourself, but you steal how much you
heal.
determines how much you steal. If we
have the power to destroy cocoon, then
we'll have the power to save it. It's
just a very conflicted individual,
right? This guy like, do I want to mill?
Do I want life? And this all this in
white blue just this kind of dissonance
they're going for, I'm sure. Yeah, this
is what they're trying to do. It's like
what? You're milling and life gain in
blue. I mean, this seems fairly obvious
in that we want to gain life. Do we want
to gain
life? Yep. But once we gain the life,
what can we
do? Like how can we benefit from cards
being in your opponent's
graveyards? And the for for gain life,
like for example, if I take uh what's it
called? Uh no, not boon reflection.
Beacon beacon of
immortality. If we take this for
example, this is like the big play. Oh,
six mana. Boom. double my life total and
then I mill each
opponent. But then even that is like
you're milling each one for just 36. Why
not just play like traumatiz or
traumatized or the you know the mass
traumatized they released I forgot the
name casualty with casualty. So let's
think give it a again I'll give it you
know 10 20 seconds. What can we do with
this lifelink? When it hits someone, we
gain we mill everyone for
two.
Uh each opponent mills X
cards and also your deck doesn't really
is not going to benefiting from
opponent's graveyards. You're not
black. Blue is decent. like you can seal
some spells
but
no. So I think we still have to go for
the life game life game
plan and when we gain life we
incidentally mill our opponents as like
a backup backup win condition. So we
we'll see what kind of unique stuff we
have in blue for life game. Let's see
color
blue game
life. I doubt there's any
honestly. I mean blue cars can be life
but payoff in terms of payoff
we and also you have to do a light game
on your main face like on your turn not
main face and that's just so
restrictive.
What happened to gaining
life man? Gain
life. Illusion of grandeur game 20
lawyers. That's true. Blue does gain
life. Game 10. Game 20. Marina V.
Whenever you get life, draw that many
cards. Whenever you lose sight, just
draw that many
cards.
What? What?
That's Can we play
this? I mean, if your entire deck is
lightning, no way you No way. You have
zero cards in hand,
right? And when you lose
life, Oh, yeah. If any deck can play
this, I think this
deck. Yeah. Okay. Suddenly, we went from
something awful and weird into I like
it. Just this one card makes the I know
it's strange, but just play being able
to play this one card makes this deck
kind of worth looking forward to because
Yeah. What other deck can play this card
in
blue? Okay. Sugar coat gain life.
Yeah. Lifet gain life. No, that's it.
Okay. Okay. I guess we're going to play
some white life gang
stuff blue
white again only working on your turn is
painful. Your commander is really cheap
at two
meta. So is it just better for us to
link life rather than playing those
lightning spells? We'll see how good
lightning spells are. Okay, we'll see
how good they are. But I don't think
they would be amazing. Ether flux. Sure,
it's a payoff, but we can't really rely
on this to gain life for us because
we're not storming off with spells. And
again, cards like Soul Warden don't
work. Um, they don't work well. A
hammerous archive. Sure. Double left
game. I guess this can play similar kind
of to a combo deck because there are
cards that say double mill, not too
many. There are cards that say double
life gain, not too many. But you have a
bunch of those. You play one, you play
another, and suddenly gaining 25 life,
gaining 20 life will kill your
opponents,
right? So maybe we do that. War of Lost
Dreams stay. Play it. Approach of the
second sun. Now we're not approaching.
Fumigate. Excellent game card. Although
when you fumigate, you're not going to
trigger your commander anymore because
he's dead. But
but other left cards
have flare of
fortitude which is
clinic.
Really? Where else is our life going to
pay
off? Sun. No. Torch does not
work. When it says external is nice, but
it's all it does is light game. It
doesn't gain that
much double game.
Yes.
Solitude. Okay. I I will find some from
memory. Is this the kind of life game
payoff you want? If
you
Okay. Yeah. Getting four four angels per
life gain is per turn is not terrible.
Kind of
amazing. I feel like we're kind of
limited in terms of options. Like this
one just straight up frost card turn.
That's not good enough. You're in
blue. Yeah. Yeah. Sure. Some life can
pay
off. What this celestine return creature
access the amount of life you
gain. Okay, this is fine. It's a payoff.
How does this gain us
life? Pay life. Life and gains
indestructible. Of
course, whenever you gain life, get draw
a card. Again, we don't have on our
opponent's turn. So, this is limited to
one card turn, which is not good
enough. Sings revelation, great instant
doesn't work on our turn. So, yeah, this
is the late game payoff, right? Aani,
exotic, all your opponent stuff. If you
have 55 life, angelic accord, okay, why
not? Nath's paragon is nice because the
lighting it kind of stacks with your
commander. You gain five life, your
commander becomes a 7 seven and the next
turn you will gain seven life. Your
commander becomes a 1212 super slow but
you're a life in deck. What more can you
do? Faithful mending
tang good? No, not really. Sure. Play
them
all. And yeah, double life game. We want
There's a new card, the crystal, right?
It gives life game. Double life
game. Yeah, this should do. Double life
gain. What does this do? Angel of
destiny. And start. If you have least 50
more life, then start life each
player. Oh, this is a light payoff. like
it's super slow
but I mean again you're like it won't
work you will be playing thunder
sovereign
so skull
good sure it's not great
but ver vir is my gain life total oh I
my apologies twice is the word twice
life
gain boom reflection
uh
Uh fail of file of
galadriel. Five or less life.
No. The wind crystal. Yes. Now I want
twice
mill.
Bruvac. That's it. Isn't there a curse?
Oh, but that curse is only target
opponent. I want each opponent. Okay, so
we've got double life gain kind of
double mill
and and let's find the best cards for
gaining
life. Did I just do the same search
earlier? I think I did. Yeah, because
the life the cards that gain life and
the cards that trigger off life gain
have the same they say gain
life.
Uh what are the best cards for gain
life? I'm starting to think we can't
really only gain life on your our main
phase because some of the best life gain
cards are triggering on your opponent's
turns. But then a lot of the synergy
doesn't
work. So something like this helio
intervention. But this one you 10 mana
gain
16 not the worst. Also we can just use
the first mode. The second mode is like
late game late game in a pinch.
And I think we should also rely a little
bit on on a commander for liking. We can
uh suit them up suit the commander up
to Yeah. So some big big things
like black
blade blade
blade smart black blade. Uh what's the
other one
called? Can't remember the name. Is this
this like the last one, but there's
H whatever we've got. Yeah, we've got
kind of this build. This will need a lot
of work. It's only a lot of work, but I
think we have to test it to figure out.
I've never seen a commander like like
this and I never built a deck like this.
We'll have to figure out the ratio. You
know what? How do you how much light
gang? How much mill and Oh yeah, we do
want of course some cards that take
advantage of the meal. I use one card to
represent it. The Luvian from
here. Oh, there's also a big flashy card
uh
from I think it was Commander Masters. I
will search for that because it's
cool. But the card holding this deck
together making me not hate it
is the that artifact Marina Scmore. That
card. Yeah. So, going to
nine. I think this will No, this will
not get us there. We need blue.
This should get us there. How many noose
files are there? Prove me wrong. Well,
something is
wrong. N CMC CMC. No, less than nine. Of
course, can't be wrong
again. Appropriate this one. This one
del three times.
Yes. Okay. This is what we're gonna
have. Select
all. This commander is called
hope.
Hope. And now we are at Titus, the last
multiolor legendary. Yes, I won't be
able to do monocolor in the same video.
This will be that will be another 6
hours. But I will I will do it in a
future future like in the next week I'd
say. Yeah, I will try to get the
monocolor done because monocol I was
just looking at it a little bit and
there's some pretty interesting
commanders. So yeah, let's first look at
Titus Bliss Battle Star. So this is the
athlete but somehow fights with the with
his athletic powers. Yeah, kicking the
ball around, I'm guessing. And uh this
ball apparently is pretty big in Final
Fantasy. I saw a few cards depicting the
game. There's there's even a stadium for
it. So, let's hope this blast we end on
a strong note. Every Blitzer knows when
you got the ball, you got to score. Wow.
Inspirational. Whenever an artifact you
control enters, put a plus one counter.
Whenever Titus attacks, tap a
creature. Oh crap.
Whenever an artifact you control
enters
well commander is three mana on turn
four we
play Nope. We just have to play artifact
tokens. It's the only way out again. Let
me know if you have something
else. Mana rock
tribal artifact
tokens.
Mana. I feel like someone if if
someone's watched not six hours but even
two or three hours of this, they would
be screaming at me. Clear form. Clear
form. I want to see is there a clear
form
button. There probably is. I They're
They're definitely screaming at me.
Clear form, you idiot. Okay. Access
denied.
Uh rank
rank. Yay. Double tokens. Sure. Yeah,
we're making all the artifacts to open.
S maybe because we're not sure how many
artifacts we have to
cast white sunlight
beautiful although X can't be five X has
to be four
works li not enough not enough hanging
back walker sure that's decent
uh yeah this great illustrious wonder
glyph
Um, treasure map is decent because it
makes three treasure
tokens. Threefold Thunder Hulk. Yeah,
this will just be an artifact token
stack and then our commander won't do
anything. Just you won't be powerful
because you're playing against artifact
tokens. You'll win with that. Uh, yeah,
metalic summonings. Why
not? What does this elderorn do? Not
what we want.
Uh, similacrim synthesizer. Whenever
artifact enter creates a
token whenever artifact with mana three
or better enters out of
control. Sharding sphinx.
Sure. Or is a
prince? No. Swarm. Scared swarm. This
card is great. Actually
great. Uh, toy
shop. Creatures you control have base
power. equals the number of creatures.
Okay, this is
good. Whenever one or more non toy
creatures attack, create a one- one
artifact. Yeah, it's fine. Splicer
ancient
engineer. Oh, also I just I don't think
what we are searching for accounts for
treasure token. So, we will do that
too. Treasure. Ah, where are we?
Treasure.
Okay. Academy
manufacturer.
Yeah. Smother T.
Yes. We are bracket
four. Monologue tax. Cast your second
spell. Sure. I think I think this this
will get us like two treasures a turn.
One or two a turn. Is that worth it? On
average, one or two a maybe not. Maybe
not. Smuggler share. Draw a card for
each one. You drew two or more cards.
Create a treasure for each one. Have two
or more. This is also inconsistent.
We're not going to get that much that
much, I believe. Spells window.
Excellent. Master of ceremony. What that
do? Treasure token. Free.
No. Tempting contract. Want to make her
treasure. Nope. Reckoner. Bank
buster create a treasure
token. No, too
slow. Treasure chest. If I roll a 10 to
No, I can I can draw three cards gain
three life or four of them.
What? I thought there'd be more mass
treasure creators in blue, but
apparently not. And this is what we have
to work with. Okay, now that we have our
turtle, we will play our favorite
artifact pump
person, Cyborg Drive. I will never
forget his name now. Cyber Drive.
Awakener.
Yay. And then I wish we can play
Brut. I'll show you. This will be the
sweet the sweetest payoff, but we cannot
play it. So, yeah, this is the deck we
have. And how we win is we win with our
commander. And also, let me have
treasure, I guess. Okay, we'll see. For
each artifact we
control, for each artifact, I don't
think there's much for each
artifact. Um
yeah, plus one for each shard effect
enchantment
control arcade
sort. Yeah, we can play some equipments.
They don't have to go on our commander.
They can just beat people down with I
guess easily it's giving plus eight plus
10 have large
creatures. So Öza. Yeah.
Yeah. Okay. Okay. Yes. How we win is
with these zero colorless constructs.
They get bigger for each artifact.
That's how we win. So, where's the saga?
This is cheap now, right? Okay,
let's I'm just going to copy the text
because I know I won't mess it up. Plus,
plus one for each creature you control.
Oh, I'm not
sure.
Boom. So, basically,
every one of these tokens is our
commander. It's like our commander. They
get big. Yeah. Another This only makes
one dig site engineer. Yes. Yeah.
Similar. Yes. We put
it.
Oops. Uh or is this command tap
construct artifact creature with this
creature get artifact
control? Uh sure. Sure. It's not bad.
Okay, this is what we
have. How many cards now? 23
cards. Okay.
And I can think of something else to
add. The generic ramp spells, generic uh
blue controlling things. Oh, we want to
add
some I once again, this is like the
third time today. Okay, I'm forgetting
the name. Inspire.
Conspire again. I can search for work of
invention and it's called improvise.
Thank
you. All your spells have
improvise. Okay.
Spire and Satur. Great card. War of
Invention. Great card. Organic
Extinction. I remember that
card. Great card. Wait, not Arth
Creatures. Sure. Great
card. Rocket Matter isn't me anyways. We
don't need it. Draw cards. Great
card. Synth Infiltrator.
Sure. Yeah, because this is the payoff
for doing what we're doing aside from
our
commander. Okay, so this is the deck for
Titus. We are at the
end and I will have the link of this in
the description. Holy, I don't know what
to
say. I mean, if you're still
here, thank you from the bottom of my
heart. Why are you still here? But
seriously, why? What are you doing with
your life? And clearly, you love this
content. You can't get enough of me. So,
subscribe. But most likely, you are
asleep. That's how you made it to the
sixth hour and deep
sleep. My voice cannot wake you up,
which is good. But if you're asleep, I
have a message for
you. Take a deep breath. In, out, in,
out. You're feeling relaxed, calm,
receptive. When you wake up, you will
feel refreshed, stronger, smarter, more
attractive.
Even you'll be a powerful independent
thinker free from the shackles of bad
tech
building and the first thing you do when
you wake
up will be to click subscribe on this
channel. You may not know why but just
know that your day will be beautiful.
All your days will be beautiful if you
do that and you'll even write a comment
best video ever. And then you will smile
because it just feels
right. Yes.
Good. I will see you in the next video.